data generated by companies and
individuals like us has grown massively
over the past decade as per statista.com
the global data generated and consumed
would reach 181 zettabytes by 2025.
organizations need to gather and analyze
such large volumes of data and look at
their past business performances as well
as results and use that information to
prepare for the future that essentially
is data analytics so hey everyone
welcome to this interesting video
tutorial of data analytics full course
2022 by simply learn
this video will help you gain all the
necessary skills and knowledge within 12
hours to become a data analyst in 2022
our experienced trainers will take you
through the course but before we begin
if you love watching tech videos
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update from
us
so let's look at the topics we'll be
learning in this video
we'll start by understanding the basics
of data analytics and learn the top 10
data analyst skills for 2022
after that we learn the top 10 data
analysis tools followed by looking at a
use case in python
next you'll get an idea of how to
manipulate and visualize data using our
packages and then look at time series
analysis in r then we'll shift our focus
to understanding data analytics using
excel pivot tables and learn to create
excel dashboards moving further you'll
see some interesting data analytics
projects related to coronavirus spotify
world happiness report and olympics
finally we will learn some of the
important questions that are asked
frequently in data analytics interviews
so let's get started
hi guys
welcome to another video tutorial by
simply learn
in today's session
we will look at data analytics for
beginners
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
in this video
we will discuss what data analytics is
and the need for data analytics
then we will look at the different ways
in which data analytics can be used
followed by the various steps involved
in the data analytics process
after that
we will get an idea about the different
tools used in data analytics and the
companies using data analytics
moving forward we will see a case study
on how walmart uses data analytics for
better customer service
and finally we will perform a regression
analysis in r to predict sales based on
the advertising expenditure from three
mediums
tv ads radio ads and newspaper
advertisements
so what is data analytics
companies around the world are
generating vast volumes of data every
hour
this data could be in the form of log
files web server and transactional data
as well as various customer related data
also data has been generated at a rapid
rate from social media websites and
applications such as facebook instagram
twitter and whatsapp
companies want to use this data to
derive value out of it and make business
decisions that's where data analytics
comes into use
data analytics is the process of
exploring and analyzing large data sets
to find hidden patterns unseen trends
discover correlations and valuable
insights to make business predictions
data analytics improves the speed and
efficiency of your business
a few years ago a business would have
gathered information manually performed
statistical and complex analytics and
unearthed information that could be used
for future decisions
but today
that business can identify insights on
the fly for immediate decisions
most organizations have big data and
many understand the need to harness that
data and extract value out of it
so they use a lot of modern tools and
technologies to perform data analytics
some of the tools i will discuss in
detail later in this tutorial
now that we have looked at what data
analytics really is let us understand
the ways in which you can use data
analytics
first is improve decision making
data analytics eliminates a lot of
guesswork and manual tasks from choosing
the right content planning marketing
campaigns and developing products
organizations can use the insights they
gain from data analytics to make
informed decisions
leading to better outcomes and customer
satisfaction
it gives you a 360 degree view of your
customers which helps you understand the
behavior completely enabling you to
better meet their needs
second is better customer service
data analytics provides you with more
accurate insights of your customers
allowing you to tailor customer service
to their needs provide more
personalization and build stronger
relationships with them
your data can reveal information about
your customers communication preferences
their interests their concerns and more
it helps you give better recommendations
for products and services
next is efficient operations
data analytics can help you streamline
your processes save money and boost
production
when you have an improved understanding
of what your audience wants
you waste less time in creating ads and
content that don't match your audience
interests this helps you optimize your
campaigns create better content
strategies and hence improve results
and finally we have effective marketing
when you understand your audience better
you can market to them more effectively
data analytics also gives you useful
insights into how your campaigns are
performing so that you can fine tune
them for optimal outcomes
you also find out the probable customers
who are the most likely to interact with
a campaign and convert into leads
now let's discuss the various steps
involved in the data analytics process
as you can see on the screen there are
five process steps
now let me make you understand each of
this one by one
so the first step is to understand the
problem
before starting with the analysis you
need to understand the business problem
and define your goals
asking questions at the outlet is vital
because this would address issues such
as how can we reduce production costs
without sacrificing quality what are
some of the ways to increase sales
opportunities with our current resources
do customers view your brand in a
favorable way
answers to these questions will help you
build a clear road map with lucrative
solutions
also try to find out the key performance
indicators and consider the matrix to
track along the way
the second step in the process is data
collection
after you have finalized your goals it's
time to start looking for your data data
collection is the process of gathering
information on targeted variables
identified as data requirements
the emphasis is on ensuring accurate and
right data is collected
data collection starts with primary
sources which are also known as internal
sources this is typically structured
data gathered from crm software erp
systems marketing automation tools and
others
these sources contain information about
customers finances gaps in sales etc
under external sources you have both
structured and unstructured data
so if you are looking to perform a
sentiment analysis towards your brand
you would gather data from various
review websites or social media apps
the next step is to clean the data
the data which is collected from various
sources is highly likely to contain
incomplete duplicate and missing values
so you need to clean these unwanted
redundant data to make it ready for
analysis
so to generate accurate results
analytics professionals must identify
duplicate and analyst data and other
inconsistencies that could skew the
analysis according to a report sixty
percent of data scientists say most of
the time is spent cleaning the data
while 57 percent of data scientists say
it's their least enjoyable task
now the fourth step in the process is
data exploration and analysis
once data is cleaned and ready you can
go ahead and explore the data using data
visualization and business intelligence
tools
you can also use various data mining and
predictive modeling techniques to
analyze the data and build models
you can use different supervised and
unsupervised algorithms such as linear
regression logistic regression decision
tree k nn means clustering
and lots more to build prediction models
for making business decisions
and the final step is to interpret the
results
this part is important because it's how
a business will gain actual value from
the previous four steps
interpreting the results will help you
find unseen trends and patterns in the
data and gain insights
you can have a validation check if the
results are answering your questions
these results can be shown to your
clients and stakeholders for better
understanding and business collaboration
now that we have looked at the various
steps involved in data analytics
let's now see the different tools that
can be used to perform the above steps
so as you can see we have seven tools
including a few programming languages
that will help you perform analytics
better now let's discuss them one by one
first we have python
python is an object oriented open source
programming language that supports a
range of libraries for data manipulation
data visualization and data modelling
python programmers have developed tons
of free and open source libraries that
you can use
you can find many of them via the python
package index which is pypi
the repository of python software
python provides the default package
installer called pip or pip
python has libraries such as numpy for
numerical computation of data pandas to
manipulate data on numerical tables and
time series
then you have scipy for technical and
scientific computations it also provides
scikit-learn which is a machine learning
library for creating classification
regression and clustering algorithms and
finally it also has pytorch and
tensorflow for deep learning
up next we have r
r is an open source programming language
majorly used for numerical and
statistical analysis
it provides a range of libraries for
data analysis and visualization
some of these libraries are ggplot
tidevos plotly deployer and carrot
then we have tableau
tableau is a popular data visualization
and analytics tools
that helps you create a range of
visualizations to interactively present
the data build reports and dashboards to
showcase insights and trends it can
connect with multiple data sources and
give hidden business insights and
patterns
then
we have a competitor of tableau which is
power bi
power bi is a business intelligence tool
developed by microsoft that has an easy
drag and draw functionality and supports
multiple data sources with features that
make data visually appealing
power bi supports features that help you
ask questions to your data and get
immediate insights you can also forecast
your data for predicting future trends
so the next tool is click view
click view provides interactive
analytics with in-memory storage
technology to analyze vast volumes of
data and use data discoveries to support
decision making
it provides social media discovery and
interactive guided analytics
it can manipulate huge data sets
instantly with accuracy
up next we have apache spark
apache spark is an open source data
analytics engine to process data in real
time and carry out complex analytics
using sql queries and machine learning
algorithms
it supports spark streaming for
real-time analytics and spark sql for
writing sql queries
it also has spark ml lib which is a
library that has a repository of machine
learning algorithms
and then it has graphics for graphical
computation
and finally we have sas
sas
is a statistical analysis software that
can help you perform analytics visualize
your data write sql queries perform
statistical analysis and build machine
learning models to make future
predictions
sas empowers our customers to move the
world forward by transforming data into
intelligence
sas is investing a lot to drive software
innovation for analytics
gartner has positioned sas as a magic
quadrant leader for data science and
machine learning
moving on to the applications of data
analytics
data analytics has been used in almost
every sector of business these days
let's discuss a few of them
first we have retail
customers expect retailers to understand
exactly what they need and when they
need it
data analytics helps retailers meet
those demands
retailers not only have an in-depth
understanding of their customers
but they can also predict trends
recommend new products and boost
profitability
retailers create assortments based on
customer preferences invoke the most
relevant engagement strategy for each
customer
optimize supply chain and retail
operations at every step of the customer
journey
the second application is on healthcare
healthcare industries analyze patient
data to provide life-saving diagnosis
and treatment options
they also deal with healthcare plans and
insurance information to drive key
insights
using analytics they can discover new
drugs and come up with new drug
development methods
advanced analytics allows healthcare
companies to improve patient outcomes
and experience
cancer cells and diabetic retinopathy
can be discovered using medical imaging
at number 3 we have manufacturing
for manufacturers solving problem is
nothing new
they fight with difficult problems and
situations on a daily basis
from complex supply chains to motion
applications to labor constraints and
equipment breakdowns they deal with such
problems on a regular basis
using data analytics manufacturing
sectors can discover new cost saving and
revenue opportunities
the fourth application is related to the
banking sector
banking and financial institutions
collect vast volumes of structured and
unstructured data to derive analytical
insights and make sound financial
decisions
using analytics they can find out
probable loan defaulters customer
churnout rate and detect fraudulent
transactions immediately
the final application is based on
logistics
logistics companies use data analytics
to develop new business models that can
ease their business and improve
productivity
they can optimize routes to ensure
delivery reaches on time in a cost
efficient manner they also focus on
improving order processing capabilities
as well as performance management
with that
now let's look at the companies using
data analytics on a daily basis
so we have the e-commerce giant amazon
then we have accenture followed by the
american healthcare service organization
cigna then we have the american supplier
of health information technology
solutions services devices and hardware
cerner
followed by target and antivirus company
mccafe
next we have rapido which is an indian
bike rental company based in bangalore
after that we have flipkart
and the world's largest retail company
walmart
so sky's the limit on what you use it
for let's take a look at types of data
analytics
and this can be broken up in so many
ways but we're going to start with
looking at the most basic questions
that you're going to be asking in data
analytics and the first one is you want
descriptive analytics what has happened
hindsight
how many cells per call ratio coming out
of the call center
if we have 500 tourists in a forest and
you have a certain temperature how many
fires were started how many times did
the police have to show up to certain
houses
all that's descriptive
the next one is predictive predictive
analytics is what will happen next we
want to predict
this is great if you have a ice cream
store and you want to predict how many
people to work at the ice cream store in
a certain day based on the temperature
coming up in the time of the year
and then one of the biggest growing and
most important parts of the industry is
now prescriptive analytics and you can
think of that as combining the first two
we have descriptive and we have
predictive then you get
pre-scriptive analytics
how can we make it happen foresight what
can we change to make this work better
in all the industries we looked at
before we can start asking questions
especially in city development there's a
good one
if we want to have our city generate
more income and we want that income to
be commercial based
what kind of commercial buildings do we
need to build in that area that are
going to bring people over do we need
huge warehouse sales costco sales
buildings or do we need little mom pod
joints that are going to bring in
people from the country to come shop
there or do you want an industrial setup
what do you need to bring that industry
in there is our car industry available
in that area
if it's not a car industry what other
industries are in that area
all those things are prescriptive we're
guessing we're guessing what can we do
to fix it what can we do to fix crime in
area with education what kind of
education are we going to use
to help people understand what's going
on so that we lower the rate of crime
and we help our communities grow better
that's all prescriptive it's all
guessing we want foresight into how can
we make it happen how can we make this
better
and we really can't not go into enough
detail on these three because a lot of
people stumble on this when they come in
and are doing analytics whether you're
the manager
shareholder or the data scientist coming
in you really need to understand the
descriptive analytics where you're
studying the total units of furniture
sold and the profit that was made in the
past uh here we go into predictive
analytics predicting the total units
that would sell and the profit we can
expect in the future
gear up for how many employees we need
how much money we're going to make
and prescriptive analytics finding ways
to improve the sales and the profit so
we can sell maybe a different kind of
furniture we're going to guess at what
the area is looking for and how that
marketing is going to change
hello everyone we welcome you all to
this video by simply learn in today's
session we will learn a really
interesting topic that is the top 10
skills to become a data analyst in 2022
in today's digital world data is being
generated by companies and individuals
every second so the role of a data and
list holds supreme importance
so if you're looking for a career in
data analytics this video will help you
learn what a data analyst does and the
various skills you need to possess to
become a data analyst in 2022
before we get started make sure you
subscribe to the simply learn channel
and hit the bell icon to never miss an
update from us
let's look at the agenda for this video
first we will understand who our data
analyst is then we will understand the
top 10 data analyst skills for 2022
moving on we will look at the salary of
a data analyst and finally we will look
at the companies hiring data analysts
so now let's understand who is a data
analyst
a data analyst is a professional who
collects business data from various
sources interprets it and uses various
statistical tools and techniques to
extract insights and useful information
from it
they acquire data from primary or
secondary data sources and maintain
databases they also recognize and
understand the organization's goal and
collaborate with different team members
such as programmers business analysts
and data scientists to build an
effective solution to a business problem
now with this basic understanding of who
a data analyst is let's learn the top 10
data analyst skills for 2022
at number one we have structured query
language or sql
sql is a top skill that every data
analyst should have
data analysts use sql commands and
functions to store process analyze and
manipulate structured data using
relational and nosql databases
they also build data models and write
complex sequel queries and scripts to
gather and extract information from
several databases and data warehouses
some of the popular databases a data
analyst should be familiar with are
microsoft sql server mysql postgresql
and ibm db2
the second important skill for a data
analyst is microsoft excel
microsoft excel is one of the most
popular and oldest spreadsheet
applications for creating reports
performing calculations and analyzing
data
data analysts need to know how to handle
tabular data in excel so they should be
aware of features like sorting filtering
conditional formatting pivot tables
what-if analysis and functions such as
sumifs and countifs
the third crucial data analyst skill for
2022 is data cleaning and wrangling
usually the data collected by analysts
from various heterogeneous sources is
often messy and contains a lot of
missing values
so it is always crucial to clean the
data and remove noise missing or
erroneous elements
it is also important to format data
using tools and methods before using it
for analysis
are responsible for data mining as well
the data mined from various sources are
organized in order to obtain new
information from it some of the tools
you need to know for data cleaning and
wrangling are excel power query and open
refine the fourth skill on our list is
mathematics and statistics
data and lists often work on data for
higher dimensions that are greater than
three in order to interpret such data
they need to be good at linear algebra
and calculus
they also build predictive models and
statistical models such as linear
regression logistic regression naive
bayes and k-means clustering in order to
understand the working of these
algorithms they must have knowledge
about statistics and probability
coming to the fifth important skill for
a data analyst in 2022 we have
programming
data analysts need to master at least
one programming language preferably
python or r in order to work with
complex business problems analysts need
to write scripts and user-defined
functions to automate tedious tasks
python and r language provide a
collection of different libraries and
packages such as numpy pandas d plier
matplotlib gg plot which data analysts
can use to discover trends and patterns
from complex data sets
after this we have data visualization as
our sixth skill
another data analyst job role is to
visualize large volumes of data and
prepare summary reports and dashboards
for the leadership team and clients so
that they can make timely business
decisions
to do this data analysts use various
data visualization tools such as power
bi tableau and click view
using these tools data analysts can
integrate various data sets apply join
conditions sort and filter data as well
create different visualizations using
charts and graphs
the seventh skill for a data analyst is
industry knowledge
data analysts should have good knowledge
and understanding of the industry or
domain they are working in for example
if you're working in a healthcare domain
you need to know how healthcare
analytics can be applied to improve
patient care you should have knowledge
about the challenges faced in healthcare
and how you can leverage data and
analytics to solve the issues
only if you have strong industry
knowledge can you try to improve the
business
the eighth skill that is important for a
data analyst in 2022 is problem solving
a business deals with several problems
on a daily basis data analysts should be
ready to face those challenges
data analysts are expected to use their
problem solving skills work with the
team troubleshoot what went wrong and
provide an effective solution via data
analysis
a data analyst with good problem solving
skills can help a business identify
current and potential issues and
determine a viable solution based on the
data it collects
the ninth skill on our list is
analytical thinking
data and lists need analytical thinking
ability to break down a complex problem
into simple components and resolve these
components one by one
it is a must-have skill for data
analysts
analytical thinking includes deciding
the parameters that need to be
considered for defining data sets
analyzing them from different
perspectives and determining variable
dependencies coming to the 10th skill
among the top 10 skills for a data
analyst in 2022 we have communication
data analysts don't just interact with
computers and programs they also
interact with team members stakeholders
and data suppliers
so good communication skills are
essential
data analysts also present their
findings in front of an audience who
might not be familiar with the
analytical methods and processes so they
need to clearly translate their findings
and insights into non-technical terms
so those were the top 10 skills our data
analyst needs to possess in 2022. do you
think we missed out on any skills then
please put your answers in the comments
section below
now let's look at the salary of a data
and list
according to glassdoor the average
annual salary for a data analyst in the
united states is 69
517
while in india you can earn nearly 7
lakh rupees per random
finally let's look at the top companies
that are hiring data analysts in 2022.
here we have the consultancy and big4
giant deloitte and the pharmaceutical
company cerner corporation then we have
the tech giant ibm retail company
walmart and the e-commerce leader amazon
to achieve the goals of data analysis we
use a number of data analysis tools
companies rely on these tools to gather
and transform their data into meaningful
insights so which tool should you choose
to analyze your data which tool should
you learn if you want to make a career
in this field we will answer that in
this session
after extensive research we have come up
with these top 10 data analysis tools
here we will look at the features of
each of these tools and the companies
using them so let's start off
at number 10 we have microsoft excel all
of us would have used microsoft excel at
some point right it is easy to use and
one of the best tools for data analysis
developed by microsoft excel is
basically a spreadsheet program using
excel you can create grids of numbers
text and formulae it is one of the
widely used tools be it in a small or
large setup
the interface of microsoft excel looks
like this
let's now move on to the features of
excel
firstly excel works with
the windows version of excel supports
programming through microsoft's visual
basic for applications vba
programming with vba allows spreadsheet
manipulation that is difficult with
standard spreadsheet techniques
in addition to this the user can
automate tasks such as formatting or
data organization in vba
one of the biggest benefits of excel is
its ability to organize large amounts of
data into orderly logical spreadsheets
and charts
by doing so it's a lot easier to analyze
data especially while creating graphs
and other visual data representations
the visualization can be generated from
specified group of cells
those were few of the features of
microsoft excel
let's now have a look at the companies
using it most of the organizations today
use excel few of them that use it for
analysis are the uk based company ernest
and young then we have urban pro wipro
and amazon
moving on to our next data analysis tool
at number nine we have rapidminer
a data science software platform
rapidminer provides an integrated
environment for data preparation
analysis machine learning and deep
learning
it is used in almost every business and
commercial sector rapidminer also
supports all the steps of the machine
learning process
seen on your screens is the interface of
rapidminer
moving on to the features of rapidminer
firstly it offers the ability to drag
and drop it is very convenient to just
drag drop some columns as you are
exploring a data set and working on some
analysis
rapidminer allows the usage of any data
and it also gives an opportunity to
create models which are used as a basis
for decision making and formulation of
strategies
it has data exploration features such as
graphs descriptive statistics and
visualization which allows users to get
valuable insights
it also has more than 1500 operators for
every data transformation and analysis
task
let's now have a look at the companies
using rapidminer
we have the caribbean airline leeward
islands air transport next we have the
united health group the american online
payment company paypal and the austrian
telecom company mobilecom so that was
all about rapidminer now let's see which
tour we have at number eight
we have talent at number eight
talent is an open source software
platform which offers data integration
and management it specializes in big
data integration talent is available
both in open source and premium versions
it is one of the best tools for cloud
computing and big data integration
the interface of talent is as seen on
your screens
moving on to the features of talent
firstly automation is one of the great
boons talent offers it even maintains
the tasks for the users this helps with
quick deployment and development
it also offers open source tools talon
lets you download these tools for free
the development costs reduce
significantly as the process is
gradually speed up
talent provides a unified platform it
allows you to integrate with many
databases sas and other technologies
with the help of the data integration
platform you can build flat files
relational databases and cloud apps 10
times faster
those were the features of talon the
companies using talent are air france
l'oreal cab gemini and the american
multinational pisa restaurant chain
dominos
next on the list at seven we have nine
constance information minor on nime is a
free and open source data analytics
reporting and integration platform
it can integrate various components for
machine learning and data mining through
its modular data pipelining concept
nime has been used in pharmaceutical
research and other areas like crm
customer data analysis business
intelligence text mining and financial
data analysis
here is how the interface of nime
application looks like
now coming to the nine features
9 provides an interactive graphical user
interface to create visual workflows
using the drag and drop feature use of
jdbc allows assembly of nodes blending
different data sources including
preprocessing such as etl that is
extraction transformation loading for
modeling data analysis and visualization
with minimal programming
it supports multi-threaded in-memory
data processing 9 allows users to
visually create data flows selectively
execute some or all analysis steps and
later inspect the results models and
interactive views
nine server automates workflow execution
and supports team based collaboration
nime integrates various other open
source projects such as machine learning
algorithms from weka hedge tour keras
park and our project
9 allows analysis of 300 million custom
addresses 20 million cell images and 10
million molecular structures
some of the companies hiring for nime
are united health group asml fractal
analytics atos and lego group
let's now move on to the next tool we
have sas at number six
sas facilitates analysis reporting and
predictive modeling with the help of
powerful visualizations and dashboards
in sas data is extracted and categorized
which helps in identifying and analyzing
data patterns
as you can see on your screens this is
how the interface looks like
moving on to the features of sas
using sas better analysis of data is
achieved by using automatic code
generation ads as sql
sas allows you to access through
microsoft office by letting you create
reports using it and by distributing
them through it
sas helps with an easy understanding of
complex data and allows you to create
interactive dashboards and reports
let's now have a look at the companies
using sas we have companies like genpak
iqea accenture and ibm to name a few
that was all about sas so for all those
who joined in late let me just quickly
repeat our list at number 10 we have
microsoft excel then at number nine we
have rapidminer at number eight we have
talent at number seven we have nine and
at number six we have sas so far do you
all agree with this list let us know in
the comment section below let's now move
on to the next five tools in our list
so at number five we have both r and
python yes we have two of them in the
fifth position
r is a programming language which is
used for analysis as well it has
traditionally been used in academics and
research
python is a high level programming
language which has a python data
analysis library it is used for
everything starting from importing data
from excel spreadsheets to processing
them for analysis
this is the interface of r
next up is the interface of the python
jupyter notebook
let's now move on to the features of
both r and python
when it comes to the availability of r
and python it is very easy both r and
python are completely free hence it can
be used without any license
r used to compute everything in memory
and hence the computations were limited
but now it has changed both r and python
have options for parallel computations
and good data handling capabilities
as mentioned earlier as both r and
python are open in nature all the latest
features are available without any delay
moving on to the companies using r we
have uber google facebook to name a few
python is used by many companies again
to name a few we have amazon google and
the american photo and video sharing
social networking service instagram
that was all about rn python
at number four we have apache spark
apache spark is an open source engine
developed specifically for handling
large-scale data processing and
analytics
spark offers the ability to access data
in a variety of sources including hadoop
distributed file system htfs openstack
swift
amazon s3 and cassandra
it allows you to store and process data
in real time across various clusters of
computers using simple programming
constructs
apache spark is designed to accelerate
analytics on hadoop while providing a
complete suite of complementary tools
that include a fully featured machine
learning library a graph processing
engine and stream processing
so this is how the interface of apache
spark looks like
now let's look at the important features
of apache spark
spark stores data in the ram hence it
can access the data quickly and
accelerate the speed of analytics spark
helps to run an application in a hadoop
cluster up to 100 times faster in memory
and 10 times faster when running on disk
it supports multiple languages and
allows the developers to write
applications in java scala r or python
spa comes up with 80 high level
operators for interactive querying spark
code for batch processing joins stream
against historical data or run ad hoc
queries on stream state
analytics can be performed better as
spark has a rich set of sql queries
machine learning algorithms complex
analytics etc apache spark provides
fault tolerance through spark rdd spark
resilient distributed data sets are
designed to handle the failure of any
worker node in the cluster thus it
ensures that the loss of data reduces to
zero
conviva netflix iqea lockheed martin and
ebay are some of the companies that use
apache spark on a daily basis
at number 3 we have another important
growing data analysis tool that is click
view
click qlikview software is a product of
click for business intelligence and data
visualization qlikview is a business
discovery platform that provides
self-service bi for all business users
and organizations
with qlikview you can analyze data and
use your data discoveries to support
decision making
clickview is a leading business
intelligence and analytics platform in
gartner magic quadrant
on the screen you can see how the
interface of qlikview looks like
now talking about its features
clickview provides interactive guided
analytics with in-memory storage
technology during the process of data
discovery and interpretation of
collected data the qlikview software
helps the user by suggesting possible
interpretations
qlikview uses a new patent in memory
architecture for data storage all the
data from the different sources is
loaded in the ram of the system and it
is ready to be retrieved from there
it has the capability of efficient
social and mobile data discovery
social data discovery offers to share
individual data insights within groups
or out of it
a user can add annotations as an
addition to someone else's insights on a
particular data report qlikview supports
mobile data discovery within an html5
enabled touch feature which lets the
user search the data and conduct data
discovery interactively and explore
other server-based applications
qlikview performs olap and etl features
to perform analytical operations extract
data from multiple sources transform it
for usage and load it to a data
warehouse
the companies that can help you start
your career in qlikview are
mercedes-benz camp gemini citibank
cognizant and accenture to name a few
at number two we have power bi
power bi is a business analytic solution
that lets you visualize your data and
share insights across your organization
or embed them in your app or website
it can connect to hundreds of data
sources and bring your data to life with
live dashboards and reports
power bi is the collective name for a
combination of cloud-based apps and
services that help organizations collate
manage and analyze data from a variety
of sources through a user-friendly
interface
power bi is built on the foundation of
microsoft excel and has several
components such as windows desktop
application called power bi desktop and
online software as a service called
power bi service mobile power bi apps
available on windows phones and tablets
as well as for ios and android devices
here is how the power bi interface looks
like as you can see there is a visually
interactive sales report with different
charts and graphs
moving on to the features of power bi
it has an easy drag and drop
functionality with features that make
data visually appealing you can create
reports without having the knowledge of
any programming language
power bi helps users see not only what's
happened in the past and what's
happening in the present but also what
might happen in the future
it offers a wide range of detailed and
attractive visualizations to create
reports and dashboards you can select
several charts and graphs from the
visualization pane power bi has machine
learning capabilities with which it can
spot patterns in data and use those
patterns to make informed predictions
and run what-if scenarios
power bi supports multiple data sources
such as excel tech csv oracle sql server
pdf and xml files the platform
integrates with other popular business
management tools like sharepoint office
365 and dynamics 365 as well as other
non-microsoft products like spark hadoop
google analytics sap sales force and
mailchimp
some of the companies using power bi are
adobe axa carlsberg capgemini and nestle
moving on to the next tool so any
guesses as to what we have at number one
you can comment in the chat section
below
finally on the top of the pyramid we
have tableau
gartner's magic quadrant of 2020
classified tableau as a leader in
business intelligence and data analysis
tableau interactive data visualization
software company was founded in jan 2003
in mountain view california
tableau is a data visualization software
that is used for data science and
business intelligence it can create a
wide range of different visualization to
interactively present the data and
showcase insights
the important products of tableau are
tableau desktop tableau public tableau
server tableau online and tableau reader
this is how the interface of tableau
desktop looks like
now coming to the features of tableau
data analysis is very fast with tableau
and the visualizations created are in
the form of dashboards and worksheets
tableau delivers interactive dashboards
that support insights on the fly
it can translate queries to
visualizations and import all ranges and
sizes of data writing simple sql queries
can help join multiple data sets and
then build reports out of it you can
create transparent filters parameters
and highlighters
tableau allows you to ask questions spot
trends and identify opportunities with
the help of tableau online you can
connect with cloud databases amazon
redshift and google bigquery
the companies using tableau are deloitte
adobe cisco linkedin and the american
e-commerce giant amazon to name a few
and there you go those are the top 10
data analysis tools since this is data
analysis with python
we've got to ask the question why python
for data analytics i mean there's c plus
there's java there's
dot net from microsoft why do people go
to python for it
so the number of reasons one it's easy
to learn with simple syntax
you don't have a very high type set like
you do in java and other coding so it
allows you to kind of
be a little lazy in your programming
that doesn't mean that it can't be set
that way and that you don't have to be
careful it just means you can spin up a
code much quicker in python the same
amount of code to do something in python
a lot of times is one two or three or
four lines
where when i did the same thing say in
java i found myself with 10 12 13 20
lines depending on what it was
it's very scalable and flexible
so there's our flexibility because you
can do a lot with it and you can easily
scale it up you can go from something on
your machine
to using uh pi spark under the spark
environment and spread that across
hundreds if not thousands of servers
across terabytes of data or petabytes of
data so it's very scalable
there's a huge collection of libraries
this one's always interesting because
java has a huge collection of libraries
c has a huge collection of libraries dot
net does and they're always in
competition to get those libraries out
scala for your spark
all those have huge collections
libraries this is always changing
but because python is open source you
almost always have easy to access
libraries that anybody can use you don't
have to go check your licensing and have
special licensing like you do in some
packages
graphics and visualization they have a
really powerful package for that so it
makes it easy to create nice displays
for people to read
and community support because python is
open source it has a huge community that
supports it you can do a quick google
and probably find a solution for almost
anything you're working on
python libraries let's bring it together
we have data analytics and we have
python so when we're talking data
analytics we're talking python libraries
for data analytics
and the big five players are numpy
pandas matplot library scipy which is
going to be in the background so we're
not going to talk too much about the
scientific formulas inside pi and psi
kit
so numpy supports n-dimensional arrays
provides numerical computing tools
useful for linear algebra and fourier
transform
and you can think of this as just a grid
of numbers
and you can even have a grid inside a
grid
or data it's not even numbers because
you can also put words and characters
and just about anything into that array
but you can think of a grid and then you
can have a grid inside a grid and you
end up with a nice three-dimensional
array
if you want to talk three-dimensional
array you can think of images you have
your three channels of color four if you
have an alpha and then you have your x y
coordinates for the image we're looking
at so you can go x y and then what are
the three channels to generate that
color
and numpy isn't restricted to three
dimensions you could imagine
watching a movie well now you have your
movie clips and they each have their x
number of frames and each of those
frames have
x number of x y coordinates for the
pictures in each frame and then you have
your three dimensions for the colors so
numpy is just a great way to work with
in-dimensional arrays
now closely with numpy is pandas
useful for handling missing data perform
mathematical operations provides
functions to manipulate data
pandas is becoming huge because it is
basically a data frame and if you're
working with big data and you're working
in spark or any of the other major
packages out there you realize that the
data frame is very central to a lot of
that and you can look at it as a excel
spreadsheet you have your columns you
have your rows or indexes and
you can do all kinds of different
manipulations of the data within
including filling in missing data which
is a big thing when you're dealing with
large
pools or
lakes of data where they might be
collected differently from different
locations
and matplot library
we did kick over the sci pi which is a
lot of mathematical computations which
usually runs in the background of the
fur of numpy and pandas although you do
use them they're useful for a lot of
other things in there but the matte plot
library that's the final part that's
what you want to show people and this is
your plotting library in python
several toolkits extend matplot library
functionality
there's like a hundred different
toolkits to extend matplot library which
range from
how to properly display star
constellations from astronomy there's a
very specific one built just for that
all the way to some very generic ones
we'll actually add seaborne in when we
do the labs in a minute several toolkits
extend map plot library functionality
and it creates interactive visualization
so there's all kinds of cool things you
can do as far as just displaying graphs
and there's even some that you can
create interactive graphs we won't do
the interactive graphs but you'll see
you'll get a pretty good grasp of some
of the different things you can do in
matplot library
let's jump over to the demo which is my
favorite roll up our sleeves get our
hands in on what we're doing
now there's a lot of options when we're
dealing with python
you can use pycharm is a really popular
one
and you'll see this all over the place
so it's one of the main ones that's out
there and there's a lot of other ones i
used to use netbeans which is kind of
lost favor
don't even have it installed on my new
computer
but the most popular one right now for
data science now pycharm is really
popular for python general development
for data science we usually go to
jupiter notebook or anaconda and we're
going to jump into anaconda because
that's my favorite one to go to because
it has a lot of external tools for us
we're not going to dig into those but we
will pop in there so you can see what it
looks like so
with anaconda we have our jupiter lab we
have our notebook
these are identical jupiter lab is an
upgrade to the notebooks with multiple
tabs that's all it is and we'll be using
the notebook and you can see that
pycharm is so popular with um
python that we even have it highlighted
here in anaconda as part of the setup
jupiter notebook can also be a
standalone so we're actually going to be
running jupiter notebook
and then you have your different
environments
i have we're going to be under main pi
36 there's a root one and i usually
label it pi 3 6.
the reason is is currently as of writing
this tensorflow only works in 3 6 and
not in 3 7 or 3 8 for doing neural
networks
but you can actually have multiple
environments which is nice there they
separate the kernels so it helps protect
your computer when you're doing
development and this is just a great way
to do a display or a demo
especially if you're looking for that
job pull up your laptop open it up or if
you're doing a meeting get it broadcast
up to the big screen so that the ceo can
see what you're looking at
and when we launch the notebook it
actually opens up a file browser in
whatever web browser you have this
happens to be chrome
and then you can just go under new
there's a lot of different options
depending what you have installed
python3
and this just creates an untitled
version of this and you can see here i'm
actually in a simply learn folder for
other work i've done for simplylearn
and that's where i save all my stuff and
i can browse through other folders
making it real easy to jump from one
project to another
and under here we'll go ahead and change
the name of this and we'll go ahead and
rename it
data analytics data analytics just so i
can remember what i was doing
which is probably about 50 of the
folders in here right or files in here
right now
uh so let's go ahead and jump in there
and take a look at some of these
different tools that we were looking at
and as we go through the demo let's
start with the numpy uh the least
visually exciting and i'm going to zoom
in here so you can see what we're doing
and the first thing we want to do is
import numpy
and we'll import it as np that is the
most common numpy terminology
and let's go ahead and change the view
so we also have the line numbers
i don't know why we probably won't need
them but make it for easy reference uh
and then we'll create a one dimensional
array we'll just call this array one
and it equals np dot array and you put
your array information in here
in this case we'll spell it out uh you
can actually do like a range in other
ways there's lots of ways to generate
these arrays but we'll just do one two
three so three integers
and if we print
our array one
we can go ahead and run this
and you can see right here prints one
two three you can see why this is a
really nice interface to show other
people what you're doing with the
jupiter notebook
so this is the basic we've created an
array this is a one dimensional array
and then the array is one two three
one of the nice things about the jupiter
notebook is whatever ran in this first
setup
is still running it's still in the
kernel so it still has the numpy
imported as np and it still has our
variable
arr1 for array one equal to np array of
one two three
so when we go to the next cell
we can check the type of the array we're
just gonna print
we say hey what's what is this
setup in here and we want type
and then we want what is the type of
array one
let's go ahead and run that
and it says class numpy nd array so it's
its own class that's all we're doing is
checking to see what that class is
and if you look at the array class
probably the biggest thing you do
i don't know how many times i find
myself doing this
because i forget what i'm working on and
i forget i'm working with a
three-dimensional or four-dimensional
array uh and i have to reformat somehow
so it works with whatever other things i
have and so we do the array shape
the array shape is just three because it
has three members and it's a
one-dimensional array that's all that is
and with the numpy array we can easily
access
stick with the print statement
if you actually put a variable in
jupyter notebook and it's the last one
in the cell
it will be the same as a print statement
so if i do this where array 1 of 2 is
the same as doing print
array of 2. that's those are identical
statements in our jupyter notebook
we'll go and stick with the print on
this one
and it's three so there's our print
space two and we have zero one two
two equals three we can easily change
that so we have array
one of place two
equals five
and then if we print our array one
uh you can see right down here when it
comes out it's one two and five
and there i left the print statement off
because it's the last variable in the
list
it'll always print the variable if you
just put it in like that
that's a jupiter notebook thing don't do
that in pycharm i've forgotten before
doing a demo
and we talked about multiple dimensions
so we'll do an array
two dimensional array
and this is again a numpy array
and in the numpy array
we need
our first dimension we'll do one two
three
and our
second dimension uh three four five and
you can see right here that when we hit
the uh
we'll do this we'll just do array two
and we can run that and there's our
array two one two three three four five
we can also do array two
of
uh one
and then we can do let's do zero it
doesn't matter which one actually do
two there we go
and if i run this it'll print out five
because here we are this is zero
uh zero one two three is under zero row
three four five is on our one row and we
start with zero and then the two zero
one two goes to the five
and then maybe we forgot what we were
working with so we'll go do array two
dot shape
and if we do array two of shape
we'll go and run that
we'll see we have two rows and each row
has three elements a two dimensional
array two three if you looked up here
when we did it before it just had three
comma nothing when you have a single
entity it always saves it as a tuple
with a blank space
but you can see right here we have two
comma three
and if you remember from up here we just
did this array two of oh let's go what
is that one
comma two
we run that we get the five you can also
count backwards this is kind of fun
and you'll see i just kind of switch
something on you because you can also do
one comment two to get to the same spot
now two is the last
one zero one two it's the last one in
there we can count backwards and do
minus one and if we run this we get the
same answer whether we count it as
let's go back up here whether we count
this as 0 1 2
or we count backwards as minus 1 minus 2
minus 3. and you can see that if i
change this minus 1 to a minus 2 and run
that
i get 4 which is going backwards minus 1
minus 2. so there's a lot of different
ways to reference what we're working on
inside the numpy array
it's really a cool tool it's got a lot
of things you can do with it
and we talked about the fact that it can
also hold things that are not values and
we'll call this array s for strings
equals np.array
put our setup in there brackets
and let's go
china
um
india
usa mexico
it doesn't matter we can make whatever
we want on here
and if we print that out
and we run this
you can see that we get another numpy of
ray china india usa mexico it even gives
us our d type of a u6
and a lot of times when you're messing
with data we'll call this array r for
range
just to kind of keep it uniform
in p dot
a range
so this is a command inside numpy to
create a range of numbers
and if you're testing data maybe you
want maybe you have equal time
increments that are spaced a certain
point apart but in this case we're just
going to do integers
and we're going to do
a setup from 0 20 skipping every other
one
and we'll print it out and see what that
looks like
and you can see here we have 0 2 4 6 8
10 12 14 16 18 like you expected it
skips every one
and just a quick note
there's no 20 on here uh why well this
starts at 0
and counts up to 20. so if you're used
to another language where explicitly
says uh less than or less than equal to
20 like for x equals 0
x plus plus
x is less than 20. that's what this is
it just assumes x is less than 20 on
here
and if we want to create a very uniform
set you know 0 2 4 6 what happens if i
want to create numbers
from 0 to 10 but i need 20 increments in
there we can do that with line space so
we can create
an r uh we'll call this l
equals i don't think we'll actually use
any of this again so i don't know why
i'm creating unique identifiers for it
but we'll do np
lin space
and we're going to do 0
to 10 or 0 to 9. remember it doesn't it
goes up to 10.
and then we want to let's say we have 20
different um
increments in there so we're creating a
we have a data set and we know it's over
a certain time period and we need to
divide that time period by 20 and it
happens to just have 10 pieces in it
and here we go you can see right here we
have 20 or it has 20 pieces in it but
it's over 10 years and we got divided in
the middle and you can see it does it
goes 0.52 remember the others are 10 on
the end so it goes up to 10.
uh and then we can also do random
there's np.random
if you're doing neural networks
usually you start it by seeding it with
random numbers and we'll just do
np.random and we'll just call this array
we'll stop giving it unique numbers
we'll print that one out and run it
and you can see we have random numbers
they are zero to one so you'll see that
all these numbers are under one and you
can
easily alter that by multiplying them
out or something like that if you want
to do like zero to a hundred
um you can also round them up if it's
integer zero to a hundred there's all
kinds of things you can do but generates
a random float between zero and one
and you have a couple options you could
reshape that
or you can just generate them
in
whatever shape you want and so we can
see here
we did three and four and so you can see
three rows by four variables
same thing as doing a reshape of 12
variables to three and four
and if you're going to do that you might
need an empty data set
i have had this come up many times
or i need to start off with zero
and i don't know you know because i'm
going to be adding stuff in there or it
might be zero and one where one is uh if
you're removing the background of an
image you might want the background is
zero and then you figure out where the
image is and you set all those boxes to
one and you create a mask so creating
masks over images is really big and
doing that with
a numpy array of zero
and we can also uh
give it a space
and we'll just do this all in one shot
this time
and we'll do the same thing like we did
before
zeros and in this case we'll do uh 2
comma 3.
and so when we run this
i forgot the asterisks around it i knew
it was for getting something there we go
so when we run this
you can see here we have our ten zeros
in a row
and maybe this is a mask for an image
and so it has uh
two rows of three digits in it so it's a
very small image a little tiny pixel
and maybe you're looking to do something
the opposite way instead of creating a
mask of zeros and filling in with ones
maybe you want to create a mask of ones
and fill them in with zeros and we'll
just do just like we did before with the
three comma four
and when we run this you'll see it's all
ones and we could even do this even
maybe we'll do it this way let's do
10
10 by 10 icon and then you have your
three colors
so creates quite a large array there for
doing pictures and stuff like that when
you add that third dimension in
if we take that off it's a little bit
easier to see
we'll do 10 again
and you can easily see how we have 10
rows of 10 ones
and you can also do something like
create an array
and we'll do 0
1 2.
and then in this array
we actually print right out
we want a repeat so you can actually do
a repeat
of the array and maybe you need this
array
let's repeat it three times
so there's our repeat of an array repeat
three times
and if we run this
you'll see we have zero zero zero one
one one two two two
and whenever i think of a repeat i don't
really think of repeating being the
first digit three times the second digit
i really always think of it as
zero one two 0 1 2 0 1 2. it catches me
every time
but the actual code for that one
is going to be tile
and again if we do a range 3
and we run this
you can see how you can generate one
zero one two zero one two zero one two
and if you're dealing with um an
identity matrix um we can do that also
if you're big on you're doing your
matrixes and we'll just identity
i guess we'll go ahead and spell it out
today may tricks
and the command we're looking for is um
i e y e and we'll do three and then
we'll just go ahead and print this out
there we go there's our identity matrix
and it comes out by a three by three
array because there's our matrix
and then it puts the ones down the
middle and for doing your different
matrix math
and we can manipulate that a little bit
too
we talk about
matrixes
might not want ones across the middle in
which case we now have the diagonal so
we can do an np dot
diagonal
and we do a diagonal let's put in the
diagonal
one two three four five and when we run
this
again this generates a value and by just
putting that value in there is the same
as putting print around it or putting
array equals and then print array and
you can see it generates a diagonal one
two three four five and there's your uh
your beginning of your matrix array for
working with matrixes
and we can actually go in reverse uh
let's create an array
equals remember our random
random.random and we'll do a five by
five array
oops there we go
five by five
and just so you can see what that looks
like
helps if i
don't mistype the numbers
which in this case i just need to take
out the brackets
and there you go you have your your five
by five array set up in there and we can
now because we're working with matrixes
we might want to do this in reverse and
extract the diagonals which would be the
0.79 the 0.678 and so on
and we simply type in
np.diagonal
we put our array in there
and this will of course print it out
because it returns it as a variable and
you can see here here's our diagonal
going across from our matrix
and we did talk about shape earlier if
you remember you can do
print the shape out you can also do the
dimensions
so in dimensions very similar to shape
it comes out and just has two dimensions
we can also look at the size so if we do
size on here
we can run that and you can see has a
size of 25 two dimensions and of course
5x5 and that was from the shape from
earlier that we looked at
there's our 5x5 shape
and if you remember earlier we did
random well you can also do
random i talked a little bit about
manipulating zero to one and how we can
get different answers you can also do
straight for the integer part
and we'll do minus
10
to ten
four
and so we're going to
generate random integers between minus
10 to 10.
we're going to generate four of those
once we run that we have 7 minus 3 minus
6 minus 3.
they're all between minus 10 and 10 and
there's four of them
and now we jump into some of the
functionality of arrays which is really
great because this is where they come in
here's your array and you can add 10 to
it and if i run this
there takes my original array from up
here
with the integers and adds 10 to all of
those values so now we have oh this is
the decimal that's right this is a
random decimal i had stored an array
but this takes a random decimal the
random numbers i had from 0 to 1 and
adds 10 to them and we can just as
easily do
minus 10
we could even do
times two
and we could do divide by two
and it would it'll take that
random number we generated and cut in
half so now all these numbers are under
0.5
another way you can
change the numbers to what you need on
there
and as you dig deeper into numpy we can
also do exponential so as an exponential
function
which would generate some interesting
numbers off of the random
so we're taking them to the power i
don't even remember what the original
numbers in the
array were because we did the random
numbers up there
here's our original numbers and if you
build an exponential on there
this is where you get e to the x on this
and just like you can do e to the x
you can also do the log so if you're
doing logarithmic functions
that reinforce learning you might be
doing some kind of log setup on there
and you can see the logarithmic of these
different array numbers
and if you're working with log base 2
you can do you can just change it in
there in p log 2.
you have to look it up because this is
not log one two three four five
it is log and log two
so just a quick note that's not a
variable going in that is an actual
command there's a number of them in
there and you'll have to go look and see
what the documentation is but you can
also do log 10. so here's log value 10.
some other really cool functions you can
do with this is your sign
so we can take a sine value of all of
our different values in there
and if you have sine you of course have
cosine
we can run that
so here's the cosine of those and if
you're doing activations in your numpy
array you're doing a tangent activation
there's your tangent for that
and the tangent activation is actually
uh from
neural networks that's one of the ways
you can activate it because it forms a
nice
curve between uh from whether you're
generating one to negative one uh with
some discrepancy in the middle
just jumping a little bit in there into
neural networks
and then we get into let me just put the
array back out there so we can see it uh
while we're doing this
as we're getting into this you can also
sum the values so we have np sum
and you can do a summation of all the
values in this array and you'll see that
if you added all these together they'd
equal 12.519
and so on i don't know what the whole
setup is in there
but you can see right here the the
summation of this
one of the things you can also do is by
axes so we could do axes equals zero
and if we run the summation of the axis
equals 0
and you can think of that
in numpy
as the rows
so that would be
or
you can think of that in numpy as being
the columns we're summing these columns
going across
and you can also change this to one
and now we're summing the rows
and so that is the summation of this row
and so forth and so forth going down
and maybe you don't need to
know the summation maybe what you're
looking for is the minimum
so here's our minimal you're looking for
and this comes up a lot because you have
like your errors we want to find the
minimal error inside of this array
and just like
the other one we can do axes equals zero
and you can see here
0.0645 is the smallest number in this
first column is 0.0645 and so on
and if you have a minimum well you might
also want to know the max maybe we're
looking for the maximum profit
and here we go you can see maximum 0.79
is the maximum on this first column
and
just like we did before you can change
this to a 1
on axes you can take the axes out of
here
and just find the max value for the
whole array and the max value in here
was 0.8344 so on so on
and since we're talking data analytics
we want to go ahead and look at the mean
pretty much the same as the average this
is the mean across the whole thing and
just like we did before we could also do
axes equals zero
and then you'll see this is the mean of
this axis and so on
and we have mean
we might want to know the median
and there's our median our most common
numbers
uh if we have median we might want to
know the standard deviation
or if we have the average a lot of times
you do the means in the standard
deviation
we can run that and there's our standard
deviations along the axes we can also do
it across the whole array
if we're going to do standard deviations
there's also
variance
which is your var
and there's our variance across the
different levels
and so if we looked at that we looked at
variance we looked at standard deviation
the median and the means
there's more but those are the most
common ones used with data analytics and
then going through your data and
figuring out
what you're going to present to the
shareholders
and some other things we can do is we
can actually take slices
you'll hear that
terminology and a slice might be like we
have a five by five array but maybe we
don't want the whole array maybe we want
uh from one on we don't want the zero in
there so we got up to four and maybe on
the second part we just want
two
to row three and see this notation right
here says one to the end and if we run
this you can see how that generates a
single row to the end and then row two
and three now remember it doesn't
include three
that's why we only get the one column so
if you wanted two and three you would
need to go ahead and go two to four so
it goes up two four
we could also do this in reverse
just like we learned earlier we can go
minus one oops
and when we go to minus one
it's the same thing because we have zero
one two three four this is the same
thing as two to four goes two to the
last one
also very common with arrays is you're
going to want to sort them so we still
have our array up here that we randomly
generated and we might want to
sort it and we'll go and throw an axis
back in there
uh
axes equals one if we run this
you can see from the axes that it sorts
it
the point two being the lowest value to
the highest value by the row
we can also change this of course to
axis zero
if you're sorting it by column so maybe
your values are based on columns
and then of course you can do the whole
array
and we can sort that
don't usually do that but you know i
guess sometimes you might that might
come up
and so you can see right here we have a
nice sorted array
uh something now let's just go ahead and
reprint our array so we can look at it
again starting to get too many boxes up
there
something else you can do with an array
is we can take and transpose it
this comes up more than you would think
when you transpose it you'll see that
the rows and the column are transposed
so where
0.79.57 0.064
is a column
now we've switched it and we have
0.79.42
as the index
you can see this really more dramatic if
we take a slice
and we'll just do a slice of the first
couple
and then we'll just do all the other um
the full rows and if we run this you can
see how it comes up a little bit
different and we'll just do the same
slice up here so you can see how those
two look next to each other
there we go there's our slice run
and so you can see the slice comes up
and it has one two three four five
columns now we have one two three four
five rows and three columns versus three
rows
and the original version when they first
started putting this
together
uh was a function so the original
version was transpose and this still
works you can still see it generates the
same value as just a capital t
so many times we flip this data because
we'll have an x y value or we'll have an
image or something like that and it's
being read one way into the next process
and the next one needs it the opposite
so this actually happens a lot you need
to know how to transpose the data really
quick
and we can go ahead oh let's just take
um here's our transpose we'll just stick
with the transpose on here
and instead of doing it this way we
might need to do something called
flattening
why would you flatten your data uh if
this is an array going into a neural
network
you might want to send it in as one set
of values instead of two rows
and you can see here is all the values
as a single array it just flattens it
down into one array
so we covered our scientific
means transpose median
some different variations on here
some of the other things we want to do
is what happens if we want to append to
our array
so let's create a new array
you're getting tired of looking at the
same set of random numbers we generated
earlier
so we'll go ahead and create a new array
here something a little simpler so it's
easier to see what we're doing
and four five six seven eight
uh that's good enough i'll just do four
five six seven eight
and if we print this array
there it is four five six seven eight
and we might wanna append something to
the array so we have our array we need
to extend it you've got to be very
careful about appending things to your
array and there's a number of reasons
for that
one
is run time because of the way the numpy
ray is set up
a lot of times you build your data and
then push it into the numpy array
instead of continually adding on to
the array
and then it also usually it
automatically generates a copy for
protecting your data so there's a lot of
reasons to be careful about appending
this way but you can certainly do it
and we can just take our array we're
going to create a new array array one
and if we print array one and we append
eight to it
you'll see four five six seven and then
there's our 8 appended onto the end
and if you want to append something to
an array
you'd probably also want to oops
array 1. let's try that again there we
go now we have the 8 appended onto the
end
so you can see four five six seven eight
and then we pinned it another eight on
there
and if you're going to append something
you might want to
go ahead and insert instead of appending
it might be you need to keep a certain
order and we can do the same thing we do
our array
and we're going to pin
or
insert
at the beginning and let's go ahead and
insert uh one two three one two three
and we go ahead and print our array two
we run it and you can see one two three
a pin is inserted at the beginning
uh inserts a lot more powerful and that
you can put it anywhere in the array we
can move it to the one spot and there we
go one two three uh we can do a minus
one
just for fun and you'll see it comes up
one two three and we're counting
backwards by one
i imagine do a minus zero
and run this and it turns out that minus
0 puts it back at the beginning because
that's why it registers a 0 just takes a
minus sign off
and just like we add numbers on we might
want to delete numbers
and so
let's do an n p dot delete
well let's keep it a little bit make it
a little easy here um to watch we'll go
ahead and create an array three
and we'll do np delete
we're just working with array
two
and we want to do is delete zero space
so if you look at this here's our array
2 our rate 2 starts with 1
and when we delete the space on here
and print that out
we deleted the one right out of there
and we can also do something like this
where we can do it as a slice
and we can do let's do one comma three
and if we run one comma three you'll see
we've deleted the one space
and the three space out which deleted
our two and four
now keep in mind when you're messing
with
adding lines and deleting lines
you have to be really careful because
there's a time element involved
as far as where the data is coming from
and it's really easy to delete the wrong
data and corrupt what you're working on
or to insert stuff where you don't want
it
so there's always a warning when we talk
about manipulating numpy arrays
and just like anything else we're doing
uh we'll create an array c
which equals we'll just do our
our numpy array that we just created our
number array 3 and we can do copy so you
can make a copy of it
maybe you want to protect your original
data or
maybe you're making a mask and so you
copy the array and then the new array
make all these alterations and change it
from values to zero to one
to mask over the first one
and of course we if we do
array c since it equals a copy of
uh array three it's the same thing one
three five six seven eight
and now we're getting into uh combine
and split arrays
i end up doing a lot of this
and i don't know how many times i end up
fiddling with this and having a mess
so
but but you do it a lot you know you
combine your arrays you split them you
might need one set of data for one thing
another set of data for the other
so let's go ahead and create two arrays
array one or a two
and i want you to note
in the terminology we're gonna look for
is concatenate what that means is we're
going to take
um
we'll call this a raycat i like a raycat
there we go
um our array cat
our concatenated array
we're taking array one and two
and it's
very important to really pay attention
to your axes and your counts i can't
merge two arrays that have like if their
axes are messed up and i'm merging on
axis 0
it's going to give me an error and i'll
have to reshape them so you got to make
sure that whatever you're concatenating
together works
and what that means
as you can see here we have one two
three four one two three four
and then five six seven eight five six
seven eight along the zero axes
these each are four values um so it's a
two by four value and if we go ahead and
switch this to one you can see how that
flips it a little bit so now we have one
two three four five six seven
eight it's interesting that we chose
that one if i did something like this
where this is now
there we go
and we concatenate it
run this and it gives me an answer okay
because i have two by two and i'm using
axes one but if i switch this to axis
zero where now it's got three and five
it gives me an error so you gotta be
really careful on that to make sure that
your whatever axes you are putting
together that they match
um so like i said this one oops x's one
axis one has two entities and since
we're going on axes one or by row you
can see that it lets it merge it right
onto the end there and you could imagine
this if this was a
xy plot of value or the x value going in
and the predicted y value coming out and
then you have another prediction and you
want to combine them this works really
easy for that
and we'll go back and let's just put
this back to where we had it
oops i forgot how many changes i made
there we go i'll just put it oops i
messed up in my concatenation order here
there we go
okay so you can see that we went through
the different concatenation axis is
really important when you're doing your
concatenation values on here
and we'll switch this back to one just
because i like the looks of that better
there we go two rows
now there are other commands in here
so we can do
cat v
equals npv
v stack
this is nothing more than your
concatenation
but instead we don't have to put the
axes in there
because it's v stands for vertical
and so if we print out
cat
v and we run this
you can see we get the one two three
four one two three four and that would
be the same as making this axis zero for
vertical stack and if you're going to
have a vertical stack
you can also have an h stack
so if we change this to from v stack to
oops here we go h stack
and we'll just change this from cat to
cat
and i run this
it's the same as doing axis zero the
process is identical in the background
um this is like a legacy setup your
v-stack and your h-stack most people
just use concatenate and then put the
axes in there because it's much
has a lot more clarity and is more
more commonly used nowadays
the last section in numpy we're going to
cover uh is
underst is kind of uh data exploration
and that'll make a little bit more sense
in just a moment
sometimes they call them set operations
but let's say we have an array one two
three four five six three whatever it is
i think we generate a nice little array
here and what i want to go ahead and do
is find the unique
values in that array
uh so maybe i'm generating what they
call a one hot encoder and so these
values then all become i need to know
how long my bit array is going to be
so each word how many how many each word
is represented by a number and then i
want to know just how many of those
words are in there if we're doing word
count very popular thing to do
and you can see here when we do unique
we have one two three four five six
those are our unique values
some of the things we can do with the
unique values is we can also instead of
doing just unique
we can do uniques
our new unique values and counts of each
unique value
and this is very similar to what we just
did up here where we uh we're doing np
unique
but we're going to add a little bit more
into there
and it's just part of the arguments in
this and we want to do return
counts
equals
true so instead of just returning the
unique values
we want to know how many of those unique
values are in each one
and we'll go ahead and print
our uniques
and print
our counts
when we run that uh you can see here we
have our unique value one two three four
five six just like we had before
and then there's two of the first of two
ones two twos two threes two fours one
five two sixes and so on and you can go
through and actually look at that if you
want to count them
but a quick way to find out your
distribution of different values
so you might want to know how often the
word the is used versus the word and if
each word is represented as a unique
number
and along the set variables we might
want to know
let me just put a note up here
we're going to start looking at
intersection
and we might want to also know
differentiation
and
neither
so when we're whoops neighbor
neither
so what we're looking at now is we want
to know hey where do these two arrays
intersect and we have one two three four
five three four five six seven we might
wanna know what is common between the
two arrays
um and so when we do that we have
np
intersect
and it's a 1d array one dimensional
array
and then we need to go ahead and put
array
one array 2.
and if we run this
we can see they intersect at 3 4 5
that's what they have common
and because we're going to go ahead and
go through these and look at a couple
different options let's change this from
intersect 1d
and we'll do the same thing we'll go
ahead and print this
so we might want to know the
intersection where they have
commonalities
another
unique word is union of 1d
so instead of intersect
we want to know all the values that are
in both of them so here's our union of
1d when we run that you can see we have
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 so that's all the
different values in there
and the last one of the last words we
have two more to go
as we want to know what the set
difference is
uh and so that's where the you'll see if
you remember set we talked about that
being the what they call these things
so the set difference
of a 1d array when we run that
you can see that one
is only in one array and two is only in
one array
and if we want to know uh what's in
array one but not in array two we might
wanna know what is in array one but not
two and what's in two but not one
and this would be the set xor
one d on here so we have the four
different options here where we can do
an intersection what do they both have
in common
we can do a union what are all the
unique values in both arrays
we can see the difference what's in
array 1 but not array two so set diff
one d
and then set x or what is not in one
but is in two and what is in not in two
but in one
so we dug a lot in numpy because we're
talking there's a lot of different
little mathematical things going on in
numpy
a lot of this can also be done in pandas
although usually the heavy lifting is
left for numpy because that's what it's
designed for let's go ahead and open up
another python 3.
setup in here
and so we want to explore what happens
when you want to display this this is
where it starts getting
in my opinion a little fun because
you're actually playing with it and you
have something to show people
and we'll go ahead and rename this we're
going to call this
pandas
and pie plot
so pandas pie plot
just so we can remember for next time
and we want to go ahead and import the
necessary libraries we're going to
import pandas as pd
now remember this is a data frame so
we're talking rows and columns and
you'll see how
pandas work so nicely when you're
actually showing data to people
and then we're going to have numpy in
the background numpy works with pandas
so a lot of times you just import them
by default
seaborn sits on top of the matplot
library
so sometimes we use the seaborn because
it kind of extends it's one of the 100
packages that extends the matplot
library probably the most commonly used
because it has a lot of built-in
functionality
almost by default i usually just put
cborn in there in case i need it and of
course we have matplot library as pi
plot as plt
and note we have as pd as np as sns as
plt
those are pretty standard so when you're
doing your imports i would probably keep
those just so other people can read your
code and it makes sense to them that's
pretty much a standard nowadays
and then we have the strange line here
uh it says amber sign matplot library
inline
that is for jupiter notebook only so if
you're running this in a different
package you'll have a pop-up when it
goes to display the matplot library you
can with the
most current version of jupiter usually
leave that out and it will still display
it right on the page as we go and we'll
see what that looks like
and then we're going to go ahead and
just do the seaborn the sns.set and
we're going to set the color codes
equals true let them just keep the
default one so we don't have to think
about it too much
and we of course have to run this
the reason we run this is because these
values are all set if we don't run this
and i access one of these
afterward
it'll crash
the cool thing about jupiter notebooks
is if you forgot to import one of these
you forgot to install it cause you do
have to install this under your anaconda
setup or whatever setup you're in you
can flip over to anaconda and run your
install for these
and then just come back and run it you
don't have to close anything out
and we'll go ahead and paste this one in
here real quick we have car equals
read underscore csv
and then we have
the actual path
this path of course will vary depending
on what you are working with
so it's wherever you save the file at
and you can see here i have like
my onedrive documents simply learn
python data analytic using python slash
car csv it's quite a long file
when we open that up what we get is we
get a csv file and we have the make the
model the year the engine fuel type
engine horsepower
cylinders and so on
and this is just a comma separated file
so each row is like a row of data think
of it as a spreadsheet
and then each one is a column of data on
here and as you can see right here it
has the make model so it has columns for
a header on here
now your pandas just does an excellent
job of automatically pulling a lot of
this in so when you start seeing the
pandas on here
you realize that you are already like
halfway done with getting your data in i
just love pandas for that reason
numpy also has it you can load a csv
directly into numpy
but we're working with pandas and this
is where really gets cool is i can come
down here
and i can print remember our print
statement we can actually get rid of it
and we're just going to do car head
because it's going to print that out
the head is going to print the top
values of that data file we just ran in
and so you can see right here it does a
nice printout it's all nice and inline
because we're in jupyter notebook i can
scroll back and forth and look at the
different data
and just like we expected we have our
column and it brought the header right
in
one thing to note is the index it
automatically created an index 0 1 2 3 4
and so on and we're just looking at the
head so we got 0 1 2 3 4.
you can change this you might want to
just look at the top two
we can run that there's our top two bmws
another thing we can do is instead of
head we can do tail
and look at the last three values that
are in that data file
and you can see right here it numbered
them all the way up to eleven thousand
nine hundred thirteen oh my goodness
they put a lot of data in this file i
didn't even look to see how big the file
was
uh so you can really easily get through
and view the different data in here
when you're talking about big data
you almost never just print out car
in fact let's see what happens when we
do if we run this and we just run the
car
it's huge
in fact it's so big that the pandas
automatically truncates it and just does
head plus tail so you can see the two um
so we really don't want to look at the
whole thing i'm going to go back to
let's stick with the head
displaying our data there we go so
there's a head of our data gives us a
quick look to see what's actually in
there
i can zoom out if we want so you can
actually get a better view
although we'll keep it zoomed in so you
can see the code i'm working on
and then from the data standpoint we
course want to look at
data types what's going on with our data
what does it look like
now this you know you show your when
you're talking to your shareholders
they like to see these nice easy to read
charts they look like a spreadsheet so
it's a nice way of displaying pieces of
the chart
we talk about the data types now we're
getting into the data science side of it
what are we working with well we have
make model we have an integer 64 for the
year
uh engine fuel type is an object if we
go up here you can see that there most
of them are
like you know it's a set manual rear
wheel drive
so they might be very limited number of
types in there
uh and so forth and you'll it's either
gonna be a float64 an integer or an
object is the way it's going to read it
on here
and
the next thing you're going to know is
like your columns
and since it loaded the columns
automatically
we have here the make the model the year
the engine
the size all the way up to the msrp
and
just out of something you'll see come up
a lot
is whenever you're in pandas you type in
dot values
it converts it from a pandas list to a
numpy array
and that's true of any of these uh so
then you end up in a numpy array so
you'll see a little switch in there in
the way that the data is actually stored
and that's true of any of these
uh in this case we want car dot columns
you have a total list of your car
columns
and like any good data
scientist
we want to start looking at analytical
summary of the data set what's going on
with our data so we can start trying to
piecemeal it together so we can do car
describe
and then we'll do is we'll do include
equals
all
so a nice panda command is to describe
your data
if you're working with r this should
start looking familiar
and we come down here and you can see
count there's a
make the model the year
how many of each one
how many unique values of each one
the top value of each one what's most
common the frequency the mean
clearly on some of these it's an object
so really can't tell you what the
average is
it'd just be the top ones the average i
guess
the year what's the average year on
there
all this stuff comes down here your
standard deviation your minimum value
your maximum value
uh what's in the lower quarter
50 mark where's that line at and what's
in the upper 75 percent the top 25
percent going into the max
now this next part is just cool uh this
is what we always wanted computers to be
back like in the 90s instead of 5 000
lines of code to do this maybe not 5
000.
all right i built my own plot uh library
back in 95 and the amount of code for
doing a simple plot
was um
i don't know probably about 100 lines of
code
this is being done in one line of code
we have our car which is our pandas we
generated that it's our data frame and
we have dot hist for histogram
that is the power of seaborn now it's
still going to generate a numpy graph
but seaborn sits on top and then we can
do the figure size this is just um
so it fits nicely on the paper on here
and we do something simple like this and
you can see here where it comes up and
does a map plot library and does
subplots and everything
but we're looking at a histogram of all
the different pieces in our database
and we have our engine cylinders
that's always a good one because you can
see like they have some that are they
had a null on there so they came out as
zero
um maybe a couple maybe one of them had
a two-cylinder engine away back when
four is a common uh six a little less
common and then you see the eight
cylinder
uh 12-cylinder engines whether it's got
to be a speedster or something
but you can see right here just breaks
it down so now you have
how many cars
with how many whatever it is cylinders
horsepower
and so on and it does a nice job
displaying it
you can see if you're working with your
uh um
you're going into your demo it's really
nice just to be able to type that in and
boom there it is it can see it all the
way across
and we might want to zero in
and use like a box plot and this time
we'll go ahead and call the um seaborn
sns box plot
and we're going to go ahead and do
vehicle size in versus
engine horsepower xy plot and the data
comes from the car so if we run this we
end up with a nice box plot
you see our mid-size compact and large
you can see the variation there's our
outlier showing up there on the compact
that must be a high-end sports car
a large car might have a couple engines
and again we have all these outliers and
then your deviation on them
very powerful and quick way to zero in
on one small piece of data and display
it for people who need to have it
reduced to something they can see and
look at and understand and that's our
seabourn box plot our sns.box plot
and then if we're going to back out and
we want a quick look at
what they call pair plotting
we can run that and you can see with the
seaborn it just does all the work for
you
it takes just a moment for it to pull
the data in and compile it
and once it does it creates a nice grid
and this grid if you look at this one
space here which is you might not be
able to see the small number it says
engine horsepower this is engine
horsepower
to the year was built
and it's just flipped so everything to
the right of the middle diagonal is just
the rotation of what's on the left and
as you expect
the engine horsepower
gets bigger and bigger and bigger as
time goes on so the the year it was
built the further up in the year the
more likely you are to have a heavy
horsepower engine
and you can quickly look at trends
with our pair plot coming up and look
how fast that was that was it took a
couple a moment to process
but right away i get a nice view of all
these different information which i can
look at visually and and kind of see how
things group and look
now if i was doing a meeting i probably
wouldn't show all the data
one of the things i've learned over the
years is
people myself included love to show all
our work you know we're taught in school
show all your work prove what you know
the ceo doesn't want to see a huge
grid of graphs i guarantee it
uh so we want to do is we want to go
ahead and drop
the stuff that might not be interested
in and we're gonna i'm not really a car
person
a guy in the back is obviously so you
have your engine fuel type we're going
to drop that we're going to drop market
category vehicle style popularity number
of doors vehicle size
and we have the axes in here if you
remember from numpy we have to include
that axis to make it clear what we're
working on that's also true with pandas
and then we'll look at just that what it
looks like from the head
and you can see that we dropped out
those categories and now we have the
make model year
and so forth
and we took out the engine fuel type
market category etc
and this should look familiar to you now
when you start working with pandas
i just love pandas for this reason look
how easy it is it just displays it as a
nice
spreadsheet for you you can just look at
it and view it very easily
it's also the same kind of view you're
going to get if you're working in spark
or pi spark
which is python for spark across big
data this is the kind of thing that they
they come up with this is why pandas is
so powerful
and we may look at this and decide we
don't like these columns
and so you can go in here and we can
actually rename the columns
simple command car equals car rename
columns equals engine horsepower equals
horsepower
this is just your standard python
dictionary
um so it just maps them out and you know
instead of having like a lengthy effect
here we had
engine horsepower
we just want horsepower we don't need to
know what's the engine horsepower
engine cylinders we don't need to know
that it's for the engine there's only
one thing we're describing if we're
talking about cars and that cylinders
and we'll go ahead and just run this and
again here's our car head and you can
see how that changed we have model year
in horsepower versus model year engine
horsepower engine cylinders and just
cylinders
again we want to keep reducing this so
it's more and more readable the more
readable you get it the better
and of course we can also adjust the
size a little bit
so that when it prints out instead of
splitting it on two lines we get like a
single line we can do that also that's
just your control mouse up or plus sign
you use in chrome that's a chrome
command
and if you remember from numpy we had
shape well pandas works the same way
we can look at the shape of the data so
we now have
11 914 rows and 10 columns
so you'll see some similarities because
pandas is built on numpy
and questions that come up just like you
did in numpy we might want to know
duplicate rows and so we can do car
and look at this switch here
we're doing a selection this is a pandas
selection with the brackets
but we want to select it based on car
dot duplicated so how many duplicates on
there so we're starting to look a little
bit different as far as how we access
some of the data on here this can be a
logical statement and we get the number
of duplicate rows we have 989 rows by 10
columns again
and this is one of those troubleshooting
things that we end up doing a lot more
than we really feel like we should uh we
might go ahead and do like a car count
uh just to see how many rows we're
dealing with
and then right after that we might want
to go ahead and say hey um
let's drop duplicates so remember we did
all the duplicates on there so car
equals car dot drop duplicates and then
we can print the head again we'll just
do car head here and you can see the
data on there um looks the same as
before
and just note that we did car equals car
drop duplicates
there are commands in here where you can
do where it changes the actual value and
it works on some of them and not on
others depending on what you're doing
but by default it always returns a copy
so when we do this we're reassigning it
to car
and you can see it's the same header but
we want to go ahead and do count and see
how the count changes let's go ahead and
run this and you can see here instead of
11 914 we have 10 925
uh so we've removed
about 100 cars
that were duplicated just slightly under
100 there
and then as we're prepping our data we
might want to know um
car is null
so it's going to count the values of
null and then we want to sum that up
and when we do that we do the car is
null function dot sum
uh we end up with uh hp the horsepower
is 69 have no values and 30 have
cylinders have no values
now if you don't put the sum at the end
it's just going to return
a mask with the true false of is it null
or is it not
by
zero and one so you're summing up the
ones underneath each column
and this of course then you have to
decide what you're going to do with the
null values there's a lot of different
options it might be that you need to put
in the average or means
maybe you want to put in the median
value
there's a lot of different ways to fill
it
usually when you first start out with
the data a lot of them you just drop
your null values and you can see here
car dot drop in a
which is equal to all and then we're
going to go ahead and count it and you
can see that we've dropped almost
another 100 values so from 10 19 25
to 10 8 27
maybe 75 or so values
so we clean that this is really a big
part of cleaning data you need to know
how to get rid of your null values or at
least count them and what to do with
them and of course if we go back to
counting our null values we should now
have
no null values
there we go and you'll see there's zero
null values
i don't know how many times i've been
running a model that doesn't take no
values and it crashes and i just sit
there and look at it trying to get why
did that crash it should have worked uh
it's because i forgot to remove the null
values
so we've been jumping around a lot we're
going to go back to uh finding outliers
and let's go ahead and bring that back
into our seabourn and if you remember we
did a box plot earlier
this time we're going to do a box plot
just on the price
and you can see here
our price value
and we have the deviation with the two
thinner bars on each side of the main
value and then as we get up here we have
all these outliers in fact we have one
way out here that's
probably a really expensive high-end car
is what we're looking at
if you were doing um fraud analysis you
would be jumping on all over these
outliers why are these deviation from
the standard what are these people doing
again this is probably like i said a
really high-end expensive car out here
that's what we're looking at
and we can also look at the
box plot for the horsepower
and we'll put that in down here
and run that
and you can see again here's our
horsepower and it just jumps and there's
these really odd huge muscle cars out
here that are outliers
and we're going to jump into making this
a little bit more
as you start displaying your data or
your information to your shareholders
we're going to look at plotting a
histogram for the number of cars per
brand
and the first thing we want to go ahead
and do
is we have with our car go back over
here here we go
uh we have our make value counts largest
plot and we're going to do a kind equals
bar
fig size 10 5.
and
right off the bat we jump up here we see
chevrolet it's going against what was it
it's figure race
the value counts and we want the largest
value so here's our value counts and
compared to what the different cars are
chevrolet puts out a lot of different
kinds of cars i didn't realize that they
made that many cars
or different types
and then for readability let's go ahead
and add a title number of cars by make
number of cars and make if you looked at
this the first time you would have been
like what the heck am i looking at well
we're looking at the number of cars by
make and then you can see here now we're
talking about the type of cars
and the different ones are put out lotus
i guess only had a few different kinds
of cars over there very high-end cars
and then as uh doing data analytics and
as a data scientist one of the things i
am most interested in is the
relationship between the variables
so this is always a place to start we
want to know what's going on with our
variables and how they connect with each
other
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to go ahead and set a figure
size because we want to make sure
it fits our graph
we'll just go ahead and set this one
plot figure set to figure size 2010.
if you never use the matplot library
which is sitting behind seaborn whatever
is in the plt
this is what's loaded it's like a canvas
you're painting on so the second you
load that
pie plot as plt
anything you do to that is affecting
everything on it
and then we want to go ahead since we're
using seaborn
we'll go ahead and create a variable c
for
relationships or correspondence
and car.corr
that's a correlation in
seabourn on top of pandas again
one line and you get the whole
correlation on there
and because we're working with seaborn
let's put it into a nice heat map if
you're not familiar with heat maps that
means we're just using color as part of
our
setup so we have a nice visual
and we can see here that the seaborne
connected to the pandas prints out a
nice chart
we'll talk a little bit about the color
here in a second it prints out a nice
chart this is a chart i look at as a
data scientist these are the numbers i
want to look at
and we'll just highlight one of them
here's cylinders
versus horsepower
the closer to one the higher the
correlation so 0.788 pretty high
correlation between the number of
cylinders and how heavy the horsepower
is
i'm betting if you looked at the year
versus
horsepower
we just look at that one here's year and
horsepower 0.314 not as so much but if
you combine them you don't actually add
them but if you combine them you'll
start to see an increase in horsepower
per year and cylinders you could
probably get a correlation there
and just like 0.78 is a positive
correlation
you might notice if we look at cylinders
and or let's look at horsepower and
mileage
so if we go here to horsepower to
mileage you get a nice
negative we'll do cylinders that's a
bigger number
with cylinders to the miles per gallon
it's a minus 0.6 so it's a negative
correlation the closer to -1 the more
the negative correlation is
and then the chart you would actually
show people is a nice heat map this is
all our colors and it's just those
numbers put into a heat map the darker
the color the higher the correlation you
can see straight down the middle um
obviously the year correlates directly
with the year horsepower with horsepower
and so on that's why it's a one the
closer the one the higher the
correlation between the two pieces of
data
now this is a good introduction pandas
goes way beyond this most the
functionality in numpy since panda sits
on it is also in pandas and then it even
has additional features in it and we use
seaborne pretty extensively sitting on
top over our pie plot so keep in mind
that our pie plot has a ton of other
features in it that we didn't even touch
on in here
we couldn't even if you had a soul
course in it uh there's just so many
things hidden in there depending on what
your domain you're working on
but you can see here here's our seaborn
and here's our matplot library that's
all our graphics that we did and then
the seaborne works really nicely with
the pandas we really like that
so that wraps up our demo part for today
let's learn about data manipulation in r
and here we will learn about
d player package
and when we talk about this d player
package it is much faster and much
easier to read than base r so d player
package is used to transform and
summarize tabular data with rows and
columns you might be working on a data
frame or you might be getting in a
inbuilt r data set which can then be
converted into a data frame so we can
get this package the plier by just
calling in library function
and this can be used for grouping by
data summarizing the data adding new
variables selecting different set of
columns filtering our data sets sorting
it selecting it arranging it or even
mutating that is basically creating new
columns using functions
on existing variables so let's see how
we work with dplyer now here
i can basically get the package here so
i can just say
install dot packages d plier now we
already see the the package here which
is showing up so i will just select this
one i can do a control enter and that
will basically set up the package
package d player successfully unpacked
so that is done now you can start using
this package by just doing a library d
player and this was built it shows me my
version of r
so let's also use a inbuilt data set
that is new york flights 13 so we can do
install dot packages and that will
search and get that relevant data set i
can again call it by using library
function now once that is done we can
look at some sample data here by just
doing view flights and that shows me the
data in a neat and a tabular format
which shows me year month day
departure time schedule departure time
and so on
now we can also do a head to look at
some initial data
which can help us in understanding the
data better
so what is this data about how many
columns we have what are the data types
or object types here it shows me how
many variables we have
so this is fine now we can start using
the plier and in that we can use
say filter function if we would want
to look in for specific value now here
we have the column as month so i will do
a filter now i'm creating a variable f1
i'm using the filter function
on flights
which we already have
and then what we can do is we can
basically
look at the month where the month value
is 0 7
so let's look at that
and this one
you can do a view on f1 which shows me
the data wherein you have filtered out
all the data based on month being 7.
so this is a simple usage of filter we
can take some other example we may want
to include multiple columns so we can
say f2 filter
flights and here we will say month
is equal to 7 day is 3
and then look at the value of f2 if you
are interested in seeing this
and that tells you the month is 7 and
days 3 you could also look into a more
readable format by using view on f2 and
that gives me my selected result so we
are just extracting in some specific
value we can keep extending this so here
we can say flights
is what we would want to work on i'm
using the filter function so i can
straight away
instead of creating a variable then then
doing a view i can also do a view in
this way i can just pass in my filter
within the view and within this i am
saying filter
i would want to look at the flights
month being 0 9 day being 2 and origin
being lga
and then that shows me the value here
and obviously you can scroll and look at
all the columns and if you see the
origin column it shows the selected
value so now we have filtered out our
data based on values
in three different columns
now
what we can also do is we can use and or
we can use or operators so i could have
done this
in a a little different way so i could
have said head which shows me
initial result i will do a flight so
within my head function i am passing in
this
and what does that contain so you are
saying flights and in this flights data
set you would want to pick up the month
being the column so we use the dollar
symbol here we given a value and i'll
say and and i'll again say flights
wherein i will select the day being two
and and and remember when you talk about
and it is going to check if all the
values are met true so then you say
flights origin
lge a and you look at the value so in
this way i can
filter out
specifically multiple values by
specifying columns now we could have
done it in this way we could have
created a view or we could have assigned
this to a variable and then done a view
on that where we could have selected
month being day and origin or you can be
more
specific
in specifying all the columns it makes
the code more readable so let's look at
the values and here you are looking at
head which shows me based on month day
and then you can look for further
columns for other variables that is
origin being lga
now what we can also do is we can do
some slicing here to select rows by
particular position so i can say slice
and i would want to look at
rows one two five and i can do this
so you can always assign or look at the
view of this
i can just do here so when i did a slide
one is to five it shows me
my entries
for one to five
now similarly we can do is
slice 5 to 10
and now you are looking at
5 to 10 values
so you can always look at the complete
data and then you can slice out
particular data now mutate is usually a
function which is used when you would
want to apply some variable on a
particular data set
and then you would want to
add it to
your
existing data frame or you would want to
add a new column so this is where you
use
mutate which is mainly used to add new
variables so let's see how you work on
mutate
so it's pretty simple so you create a
variable over delay now i would want to
do a mutate so that it adds a new column
so i'm selecting my data which is flight
i will call the new column as overall
delay
and then basically
i can look at
overall delay being arrival delay minus
departure delay so let's create this and
let's look at view of this which shows
me
or which should show me my new column
which is overall delay which was not in
my original data set so you can anytime
do a head on this one to compare the
value so this one shows me arrival delay
and then there are many other variables
what you can also do is you can do a
view
and you could have just look at flights
if you would want to compare
so you can look at the flights and this
one would not have any
overall delay column so it basically
shows me 19 columns only
what we see here
and if you
do a view on overall delay then that
basically shows me 20 columns so we know
that the new column has been added
to
this overall delay so if you would want
to work with 20 columns you will use
overall delay if you would want to work
with your original data set you will use
flights now you can also use a transmute
function
which is used to show only the new
column so we can do an overall delay and
at this time we will say transmute we
will say flights overall delay
the computation remains same but at this
time if i look at view on overall delay
it only shows me the new column so
sometimes we may want to compute result
based on two variables or two columns
and just look at the new value and then
we can decide if we would want to add it
to our existing structure
now you can also use summarize
and summarize basically helps us in
getting a summary
based on certain criteria so we can
always do a
summarize
and
what we can do is we can look at our
data
and we can say on what basis we would
want to summarize this particular data
so we can do a summarize function now
summarize on flights i will say average
a time and i would want to calculate an
average so for that i am using inbuilt
function called mean
i will do that on airtime column
so
let's look at flights once again and
here we can see there is
arrival time not a time sorry arrival
time and we would want to do some
average on this particular data we would
want to summarize this
so what i'll do is i will use the
summarize function
i will say average airtime and this one
i will look at mean of a time so let's
see if there is a a time column i might
be
let's look at this one and i will delay
and yes we have an airtime so we were
actually looking at summarizing based on
airtime not the arrival time
so air time is how much time it takes in
air for this particular fight and we
will want to use the trans summarize
function not the transmute so summarize
flights average a time and this one we
will calculate the mean of average a
time
and
i will also do a any removal which is i
am saying true so let's do this and that
basically shows me the average a time is
151
i can also do a total a time where i am
doing a summation of values or i can get
the standard deviation
or i can basically
get multiple values such as mean
i can say total airtime where i am doing
a summation
and then i can look at other values
which is if you would want to put in
standard deviation here you could do
that so let's look at the result of this
summarize and this basically allows me
to get some useful information which is
summarized based on a particular
function such as mean sum standard
deviation
or
all three of them
now let's look at grouping by so
sometimes we may be interested in
summarizing the data by groups and
that's where we use the group by
function
so we can always
use
the group by clause
now
here we are taking a different data set
so we will say for example let's look at
head of mt cars
and that is basically my data set on
empty cars now that shows me the model
of the car
it shows me my lathe cylinder part this
and your horsepower and various other
characteristics or variables in this
particular data set so here
we can say let's do a grouping by gear
so there is a column called gear so i
will call it by gear i will look at my
data set and then what i am using here
which you see with these percentage and
greater symbol
is called
piping
so that basically
feeds your previous data frame into next
one so this is sometimes useful and you
can get this by just saying control
shift and m and you can then use this so
we are going to
have
piping so i am saying empty cars now
this is my original data set
where i did a head
or i could have done a view on this one
if you would want to see it in a more
readable format and that basically shows
me the data so we are using a different
data set so i want to group it by the
gear column so i'm going to call it by
gear and
this one takes my data that is empty
cars i'm using the piping and then i'm
saying group the data based on gear
column that's done now let's look at the
value of by gear
or
you can always do a view so remember
whenever you're doing a group by it is
giving you a
internal object where your data is
grouped based on a particular column
so we can look at the values here you
can do a view that shows you your data
grouped based on a particular column
now i can again use the summarize
function
where i would want to now work on the
new one where it was grouped based on
gear so i am doing a summarize and here
i am going to say gear 1 which will be
having the value of summation on the
gear column
and then i am saying gear 2 which is
mean well you could give some meaningful
names to this
and let's look at the value of this one
where we are basically now looking at
the values which is sum and mean values
based on the gear
similarly we can use look at different
example so we can say by gear
and i'm again using piping
but earlier we had taken gear
we had grouped the data and we called it
by gear so we took our original data set
empty cars but now within this
particular data which was grouped by
gear
i will take this data set i will use the
piping and i will summarize it where i
am saying
within this particular data set i would
want to get the sum or i would want to
get the mean and then you can look at
the values
so
what you are doing is
you are
either looking at your original data set
or you're looking at the data which was
already grouped and then you can look at
the values
now here what we can do is we can group
by cylinder say might be you are
interested in looking at data which is
summarized based on the cylinder column
you can do that and then for this by
cylinder i am doing a piping where i am
using the summarize function and
summarizing will then be done based on
the mean values of the gear column or
the horsepower
so let's do this
and then you can basically look at the
value at any point you may want to look
at the data set again so just go ahead
and you can look at what does the value
contain
and
by cylinder or by gear and do a head and
it gives you the value
so you can always do some summarizing or
grouping in these ways
now here we are going to use sample
underscore n function and sample
underscore
fraction for creating samples
so for this
let's take the flights data set again
and we would want to
get 15 random values now that is done
and it shows me 15 rows with some random
values from the data what you can also
do is you can do a portion of data by
using sample underscore
fraction and here i'll say flights i'll
say 0.4 which will return 40 percent of
the total data so this can be useful
when you are building your machine
learning where you would want to split
your data into training and test might
be you are interested in some portion of
the data so you can do this
which is very useful function
and then you can look at the value of
that
now what we can also do is we can use a
range function so like we were doing a
grouping by or we were
trying to pull out a particular column
so in the same way we can use a range
which is a convenient way of sorting
than your base are sorting so for range
function
let's do a view
based on a range so we will work on the
flights data set which we have
and here what we would want to do is we
would want to arrange the flights data
set which is based on year and departure
time and we are doing a view out of it
so that basically
gives me the data
which is arranged based on
your year and departure time now i can
do a head to give me
some highlighting of that data
now
the piping operator what we are using
can be used in these ways also so here i
will say df i will just assign the data
set empty cars to it let's look at the
df which has basically your different
models you can obviously
look at the head or view of it to look
at useful information we can also go for
nesting options which can be useful so
we are
creating a variable called result here
now that has the arrange function
so
what does this arrange function do so
when we would want to use arrange to
sort the data so i would want to sort
the data but what data would i sort so i
will use sample n
which will give me some portion of the
data or some sample data now what is
that sample data so here we are using
nesting that is
earlier when we did a sample we just
said data and how many random samples we
want but instead of giving that what we
are going to do is we are going to use
filter here
now this filter will work on df
so filtering will happen based on the
mileage which is greater than 20
i will say size is 5 and i would want to
basically arrange this in a descending
order so i'm using the des
on this particular mileage column by
default it is always ascending
so let's get the result out of this
which will basically show me the mileage
details in a descending order so this is
my data frame and now
we can look at the result what we have
created
so just do a view or do a head
and look at the view so here you see
mileage
where the highest value is on the top
and we were only interested in five
values in a random sample so that's why
when you did a view it shows your five
values and it shows in a descending
order based on mileage so we have
not only used an inbuilt function we
have not only arranged the data that is
we have sorted the data but we have
sorted the data based on a descending
order on a particular column we have
said the value should be greater than 20
and we have also said we just need five
random samples
now let's look at some other examples so
you can always do a multi assignment
so i can say filter
wherein i'm going to use
df which was assigned empty cars
i'm going to say mileage should be
greater than 20
then i say b which is going to get a
sample out of a
and i just want 5 random values
so let's look at that so we have b which
is
going to get a
set of 5 values from a
now i will create a result variable
which will arrange b which is sample
data in a descending order now let's
look at the result of this and that
basically shows me what we were seeing
earlier so you can do a multi assignment
where you can create a variable get a
sample out of it and then basically
whatever is that result you can arrange
that or sort that in a descending or by
default ascending order
so same thing we can do it using pipe
operator
so piping
so here i will say result i'm passing in
my df that's the data set i'm using
piping and which basically tells what
you need to do on this particular data
set so i'm going to filter out the data
based on mileage 50 sorry mileage 20
then i'm going to push that
or forward it to
get the random sample and whatever is
this random sample is going to be pushed
so you are arranging this in a
descending order so this is one more way
of doing it and then basically you can
look at the result so these are some
simple examples where you can use your d
plier with multiple assignments or using
your nesting to filter out the data
you can also do a
arrange which is to sort the data you
can get some random samples out of it
you can summarize the data
you can also summarize the data based on
one or two or multiple columns and you
can use some inbuilt functions to
summarize the data based on some
functions which are applied on the
variables or on the columns
you can transmute it
where you would be interested in only
looking at one column
you can mutate it where you want to add
a new column
you can slice it
and you can give the conditions where
you can say and on or
to filter out the data
so what we can also do is on this
particular data set which we have say
for example df
where i have my data let's look at this
one
and if i just do a df at this point it
shows me my data set
and if you would be interested only in
particular column
then your d player also allows you to
either we can do a filter or we can
simply do a select
now for selecting we can choose
uh our data so for example i'll say df
underscore
i'm interested in mileage i'm interested
in horsepower
might be i am interested in
your cylinders in this
and for this one what i can do is when i
would want to do a select
i can basically say
selected df let's call it some name
i can say
control shift m
which is for piping and then basically
what you can do is you can do a select
and you can choose your columns so i was
interested in mileage
i was interested in
horsepower
i was interested in cylinder and here
what i'm doing is i'm using a select
where i can look at the new data frame
so let's do this
and
i'm sorry here we will have to give it
df
this is where you are passing in your
data
yeah now this one is done and we can
look at the value of this one by just
doing a df
or
head
on df
underscore
mileage horsepower cylinder and look at
the selected result so you can be
looking at selective columns i could
have done this filter but filter will
always look for
a condition say your mileage is greater
than 20 or might be your cylinders are
more than 4 or something else but when
you do a select you are selecting
specific columns
so view always gives you all the columns
head gives you highlight but then select
can be useful when we are interested in
looking at only specific data so this is
how you can use the player for
manipulation
for your data transformation for
basically filtering out the data
by selecting particular data and then
working on it so similarly there is one
more package called tidr and we'll see
how we can use data manipulation
done using your tidr package
let's
learn about that idr package it makes it
easy to tidy your data
and this basically helps you creating a
more cleaner data
so
which is easy to visualize and model now
this comes with mainly four functions so
you have gather which makes
your data wide or it makes white data
longer so that is basically used to
stack up multiple columns
you have spread function which makes
long data wider that is stacking the
data together or stack
if you would want to unstack the data to
data
and you are talking about data which has
same attributes
and then your spread can spread the data
across multiple columns
you have separate which is function
which splits single column into multiple
columns
and to complement that you have one more
function which is unite and that
combines multiple columns into single
columns so these are four main functions
which are used in your idr package so
let's look how we work with this
so let me bring up my r studio here now
for this first is let me just clean up
my screen here doing a control l
so i will install the package it is
already installed but we can just do a
control enter
and then
i can say do you want to restart r prior
to reinstall
install i'll say okay
and it is basically going to get the
package
now it says package tid tidy r that is
idrs has been successfully unpacked
let's use that package with using our
library function
and that was built under our version 3.6
now i can basically
start using these functions so for
example here we are creating a data
frame so let's say n is 10
and then we basically would say
we will call it white
now that's the variable name i'm using
the data.frame function
i'm saying id which will be
1 to n so that will take the values from
1 to 10 and then these are the values
which have
ten entries so this is a vector phase
one phase two phase three let's create a
data frame out of it now that's done we
can have a look at our data frame by
just doing a view wide and that shows me
the id column and it has face dot one
phase dot two and face dot three now we
can use our function so for example we
can work with gather that is reshaping
the data from wide format to long format
and basically you can say stacking up
multiple columns
so let's see how we do that here i'll
call it long i'm working on white i'm
using the piping
functionality and then i'm using gather
so this one i will say what will be the
data which i will use
so we are using wide as a data frame
then i am saying response time so that
will be basically one more column and
then you have your columns which you
would want to
basically stack so i'm saying from phase
one to phase three so let's do this
and once this is done let's have a look
at our variable long so this one shows
me that i have an id column
i have the response time column and i
have the face column which we mentioned
and that basically has all the values
stacked in so you have face dot one
phase dot two and face dot three so if
all the columns are being stacked here
so all my data so now i have totally 30
entries in this one so this is basically
using your gather function now sometimes
we may want to use
a separate function now separate
function is basically splitting a single
column
into multiple columns so which we
would want to use when multiple
variables are captured in a single
variable column okay so let's look at an
example of this one so let's say long
separate that's what we will call we
will work on this long which has all the
data stacked in
as the columns we selected then i'm
saying separate i want the face column
and then i would say when i separate the
columns what are my column names now i
could also give a separator by giving a
comma and then mentioning the separator
if that is required so let's do this
now once this is done let's have a look
at our long separate so what we see here
is the
column which we used so we were doing a
face column and that was to be
split and we wanted to split it into
target and number so that's what we see
here so you have face being split into
target and number and then you have the
response time so this is how you use the
separate function now there is also
something called as unite function which
is basically a complementing of separate
function so it takes multiple columns
and combines the elements to a single
column so for example here
we will
call it long unite
and we will take long separate which was
separating the data we want to unite so
we will take phase target
number
and we want to have a separator between
them so let's basically do this
and now let's look at the result of this
unite
so you see you have the face and target
merged together so you have face dot one
the separator is dot as we have
mentioned and we have united multiple
columns so
this is one more function of your tie dr
which helps you
basically
tidy up your data or put it in a
particular way
now then you have your spread function
and this is basically for unstacking so
that is
if you have if you would want to convert
a stack to data or if you would want to
unstack the data which is of same
attributes spread can be used so that
you can spread the data across multiple
columns
so it will take two columns say key and
value and spread it into multiple
columns so it makes long data wider so
we can look at this one we will say long
unite
i'm using the piping i will use the
spread function i'll work on the face
column and response time and let's do
this and then let's do a view on this
so it tells me our data is back in the
shape as it was in the beginning so
these are four functions
which are very helpful when we work with
idr package
so let's learn about
visualization
and here we will learn about
r which can be used for your
visualization now
one thing which we need to understand is
because of our ability to see patterns
which is highly developed we
can understand the data better if we can
visualize it
so the efficient way or effective way to
understand what is in our data or what
we have understood in our data we should
or we can use graphical displays that is
your data visualization so there are
actually two types of data
visualizations so you have exploratory
data visualization which helps us to
understand the data and then you have
explanatory visualization which helps us
to share our understanding with others
so when you talk about r
r provides
various tools and packages to create
data visualizations
and which can be used for both kind of
data analysis or both kind of
visualizations
so when you talk about exploratory data
and visualization the key is to keep all
the potentially relevant details
together
now the objective when we talk about
exploratory data analysis is to
help you see what is in your data
and the main question is how much
details can
we interpret
now when you talk about different
functions which we see here such as plot
which is more for a generic
plotting you have bar plot which is used
to plot data using rectangular bars or
you can say creating bar charts you have
histogram or hist function to create
histograms where you look at the
frequency
of the data are basically used to look
at the central tendency of the data you
have box plot which is used to represent
data in the form of quartiles you have
gg plot which is a package which enables
the user to create sophisticated
visualizations with the little code
using the grammar of graphics
and then you have plot lee or plot ly it
creates interactive
web-based graphs via the open source
javascript graphing library now before
we see some examples here let's also
talk about
when you talk about plotting let's also
try to understand what kind of
plots you can have and what kind of
techniques you have so let me open up my
r studio here
now for example i can pull out a
particular data set
and let's look at this one
so
here i can look at
all the panes and that shows me the
information now what i can do is
i can install
and get the inbuilt data sets and then i
can simply do a plot
wherein i am doing a plot on chickweight
data set
so let's see what does that show it
summarizes the relationship between four
variables in chick-weight data frame
which is in our's built-in data set
package now from these plots we can see
for example weight varies systematically
over time
you can also see that chicks were
assigned to four different diets
now when we talk about explanatory data
analysis
or visualization that shows others what
we found in the data this means we need
to make some editorial decisions
what features we would want to highlight
for emphasis
what features are distracting or
confusing and you want them to be
eliminated
right so there are different ways of
doing it now when you talk about your
graphics or visualizations you have
i would say
three different types or you can say
four so you have the base graphics which
is easiest to learn now here we are
having an example of base graphics
where i can use the base graphics
i can get a
data set using library
then i can simply create using plot
function to
a generate a simple scatter plot of
calories with sugar
from u.s serial data frame in the mass
package
and then i can give it a title so this
is basically a simple example of base
graphics now you also have what we call
as grid graphics which is powerful set
of modules for building other tools
now you also have latest graphics which
is general purpose system based on grid
graphics and then you have your gg plot
2 which implements grammar of graphics
and is based on grid graphics so you
have different ways now here since i
already have used library and i have the
data set i can just do a x so i can
assign the
sugar related values to x and calories
related value to y
then i can use one more which is library
function and calling in grid now i can
basically use functions such as push
view port if i would want to create a
plot using your grid graphics to
create the similar kind of plot which we
created using base graphics but this
will give you much more power than base
graphics
it will have a
steep learning curve but
it is usually useful so i can do this
where i'm saying push view port
then i can basically say i would want to
have a data viewport
i would say different functions of your
grid package so i am saying rectangle
you have x-axis y-axis given some points
here
and then basically you can add details
to the graph by giving the names to the
columns and you can
basically create a simple grid graphics
based plot here
now there are different other options
which we can use to create plots now
before we go into understanding how you
create plots let me just give you a
brief on
what are the different kind of plots and
how they can be used so here we will
look at these different plots now for
example
we have a bar chart which is a graph
which shows comparisons across
discrete categories
so you have x-axis which will show the
categories being compared and y-axis
which represents a measured value
and height of the bars are proportional
to measured values
now
to create different kind of charts you
can use ggplot which is a package for
creating graphs in r
it is basically a method of thinking
about and decomposing complex graphs
into logical subunits and that is a part
of tidy works ecosystem so it takes each
component of graph accesses you can give
scales you can give colors you can give
the objects and you can build graphs on
particular data you can modify each of
those components in a way that's more
flexible and user friendly you can if
you are not providing details for the
components then ggplot will use sensible
defaults
and this basically makes it a powerful
and flexible tool now here
are
different options when you use your
ggplot such as you can use geom or what
we call as geometric objects
to form the basis of different type of
graphs for bar charts you have for line
graphs you have scatter plots that is
underscore point you have underscore box
plot for box plots you have quartile for
continuous x violin for richer display
of distribution and jitter for small
data so here is some simple example
where i would not go into too many
details here but you can just have a
look at this one
where we are
using library function to get the
ggplot2 package
then basically we would want to look
into the mileage data we would want to
look at the structure of it
and then we can basically
get the tidy words package finally we
can create a bar chart
using geo underscore bar
and we can basically also mention what
would be in x-axis now you can also give
different colors to basically add more
meaning to your data
you could also go for stacked bar charts
so here we are actually telling ggplot
to map the data in the drive column to
fill the aesthetic so here i am giving
aesthetic access class
and i am saying what is the data we need
to have and then we are using geom
underscore bar
so you can also have dodged bar
in your gg plot that is not bar charts
which are stacked but next to each other
and you can create that by using
your position as position underscore
dodge okay now you can obviously use
your different packages which are
inbuilt and you can create your bar
charts
and you have other kind of graphs such
as line graph which is basically a type
of graph that displays information as a
series of data points connected by
straight line segments such as this one
and for this one we are using if you see
geom underscore line
now you can also create a scatter plot
which is a two dimensional
data visualization that uses points
to graph the values of two different
variables one in an x axis one on y axis
like what we saw in base graphics
example
and they are mainly used if you would
want to assess the relationship or lack
of relationship between two variables
and you also have histogram which i
mentioned is mainly to look at the
distribution of a data to look at the
central tendency of the data
basically looking at
your
large amount of data for a single
variable you would be interested in
saying where is
more data found in terms of frequency
whereas lesser data found in the graph
how close the data is towards its
mid point or what we call as mean median
mode
so you can use histogram where you can
categorize the data in what we call as
bins so these are some basics on
different kind of graphs now we can look
at some examples and see how that works
so what we were seeing is some quick
examples of base graphics or grid
graphics now here
let's do
an example of pie chart for different
products and units sold so you want to
create a graph for this first let's
create a vector and pass in the value
here
now i can also create labels which i
would want to assign to these values
and then basically i can plot the chart
by saying pi so that's the kind of chart
which i would want to create
and i would say the data would be x and
labels
so let's do this and that shows me a
simple pie chart now i can also give
main details here so instead of just
doing a pi x comma labels i can say what
is the main and then what kind of
coloring it should follow so this is the
way you can create a simple
uh plot now i can also find out what is
the percentage
and then basically
i would be interested in plotting the
pie chart which takes x
which takes the labels which will be the
percentage which we are calculating here
by doing a round function
and then you can basically give details
to your
graph you can say what color it follows
you can basically look at the legend
where it needs to be
in your chart
what are the values
and then basically fill up the colors so
let's run this one and that shows me the
percentage which was calculated and it
gives me the details
and we can always have a look at our
plot now if you would want to go for a
3d pie chart then
you can get the package which is plotrix
let's use that by calling in the library
function let's pass in some data to x
and let's give some values or labels
which will make more meaning to the data
and then let's plot the 3d graph so i'm
saying pi 3d here where i'm using x and
labels
then i'm basically doing an explode
which will basically control how your
graph looks like and basically give the
values so it also takes the title when
you say main and by chart of countries
now let's create
data for graph so again we are having a
variable here we are create using the c
function creating a vector
and then let's create a histogram for
this one
where i would say x lab what would be
your data around x axis what is the
color what is the border and here i am
creating a simple histogram
which as i discussed earlier will always
show
your values on the x-axis and y-axis is
more of frequency and then you can look
at the set of values and what is their
frequency
and we can basically use this histogram
for exploratory data analysis look at
the data try to understand what is the
central tendency of your data values now
we can also give some limits by using
the x lim and ylim and then i can also
specify what is the limit so we have
given some values here wherein we have
said your x limit is 0 to 40
and y limit is 0 to 5. now if you
compare this with the previous one which
we had created
this one
based on the frequency had taken the
limits but we can assign limits
explicitly by giving this and then
create a histogram which makes more
meaning
now let's take
another data set that is air quality
let's view this to see what does that
data contain so you have
ozone solar wind temperature month and
the day so this is the kind of
information we have in the air quality
now let's use the plot function to draw
a scatter plot where as i mentioned you
would be interested in analyzing
variables and see
what is the relationship between them so
to plot a graph between ozone and wind
values
so we will say plot we will say the data
which is air quality from that i would
be interested in the ozone column or
ozone field and the wind field i can
create a plot based on this
now i can also be saying what should be
the color what is the type of the data
which you would want to create and you
can look at the info information so you
can create a histogram you can create a
scatter plot to basically understand the
data better and then infer some
information from that data so let's take
the air quality data set itself without
specifying any particular column and you
can create a plot which shows me all the
different values which you have in the
data and it basically shows you the
difference this is more of an example
like what we did for chickweight where
we did a base graphics now you can
assign labels to the plot so that is
when you are creating a plot you can say
air quality you will say ozone
and then that's your ozone concentration
you have your y lab which is the number
of instances
you have what is the title ozone levels
in new york city what is the color so
these are the details what we have given
with our plot function and let's look at
the data so it just tells me that this
is the ozone concentration
uh the number of instances what you have
and you are looking at the data now we
could also create a histogram by picking
up a particular column that is such as
solar
from your air quality and that basically
shows me the frequency
of solar values and we can then try to
find out what is the mid
what is the mean what is the standard
deviation and so on you can also look at
your histogram and try to understand if
it is left skewed and right skewed so we
can do that
now here let's get the temperature out
from this particular data set
let's create a histogram on temperature
and that basically shows me
the frequency of the temperature values
and
what values have the most frequency or
most occurrence
now you can create a histogram
with
labels
so let's do that with the limit
and then let's also use text to
basically given the values which also
takes the values
and for each set of frequency or each
set of values it gives me the labels
now you can have a histogram with
non-uniform width so you could do that
by doing a hist function
and then
passing in your temperature you can say
what will be the main what is the title
what will be your x lab
it will tell you a limit around x axis
what is the color what is the border
what are the breaks you would want to
have
for your bars and you can
simply create a histogram using this so
this basically takes the breaks which we
have given
such as 55 to 60
60 to 70 70 to 75 and so on so this is
basically creating a histogram with
non-uniform width
and it purely depends on the kind of
values what you have
now you can also create a box plot which
sometimes helps us in understanding the
the data quartiles also understanding
our outliers so you can create multiple
box plots based on the data from air
quality so we'll select all the data and
then we'll do some slicing on the data
so let's create a box plot which tells
me the values and if you look at these
points here
like single dots these are basically
your outliers
we can learn about that more in later
sections
so you can use
your gg plot 2 library to analyze
a particular data set so for that we
will first
use the install dot packages and get
ggplot2
so it says do you want to restart r and
i can say yes so let it get the package
i think the package was already there
and now
let's look at
using ggplot2 so for that i have the
library function
and let's do a attach where i'm getting
a data set which is empty cars
now then i will create a variable p1 i
will use ggplot i will pass in my data
i'll give the aesthetics
what is the columns which you would be
interested in
and then you are using geom underscore
box plot to basically create a plot
which gives me the box plot for the
values here and this is based on
the cylinders which is there in your
data
so we can always look at what does our
data contain
and what kind of values or features are
available in the data now let's create a
box plot we will also use the coordinate
function and that basically gives me
based on the data so i've changed the
coordinates now if you
look at the previous one where we
created a plot we had mileage on the
y-axis and cylinders
on the x-axis
now i did a coordinate flip and that's
like your transpose function so you have
created the box plot but you have just
flipped the coordinates
you can create a box plot and then say
fill
which is the factor of cylinder so that
can be used to fill up the values in
your box plot
now what we can also do is
we can create factors so we have learnt
about factors earlier which is usually
used to work on categorical variables
so here let's create a factor
which is empty cars gear you have am you
have cylinder and if you look at the
factors which we have created we have
passed our data
what is the field or the column we are
interested in
what is the level of values there and
what are the labels for those values
right so we have learnt about factors
you can always look into the previous
section and learn more about factors
now let's create a scatter plot
by using the ggplot function again we
will use the data as empty cars i will
go for mapping option and then i will
give my aesthetics that is what would be
x what would be your y
and you also would want to use
what kind of
function you are using so let's go for
geom pawn point and that basically helps
me in creating a scatter plot now you
can create a scatter plot by factors
so here we will say gg plot
so notice in all of these cases
depending on the kind of data you have
depending on the kind of plot you are
interested in you will use the ggplot
and then basically a function with that
or the inbuilt package so here i'm
saying data is empty cars i am going for
mapping which basically will take the
values for your x and y
what is the color
and the coloring will be done based on
the factor values now if you remember
factors will obviously have some levels
and
[Music]
those levels will basically help you in
differentiating between your categorical
variables so i'm saying as dot factor on
cylinder and then i'm using geom point
to basically create this scatter plot so
let's do this
and
i can
look at the values of this one so it
says
must be there is an error which says
must at least one color from the hue
palette so let's look at that one so the
error which we were facing when we gave
color as the factor values was because
when you look at these factors which
were created with some labels if we look
at the values of these it tells me there
are any values in that particular column
similarly your gear
or similarly you can completely look at
the complete data set it tells me
cylinder you have am you have gear now
these have some
we have created some labels but these
have n a values
so what we can do is we can create a
scatter plot as we did earlier by giving
the aesthetics and that's a simple
scatter plot
wherein i'm also using geom point so
that i can have these points by defaults
or with defaults
you can also
give a color specific basically if you
would want to have different kind of
data in the same plot or i can
create scatter plots by different sizes
by giving a size or
i can give a color and size and that's
again one way in which you can create
your scatter plots now let's also see
how you can visualize
one more data set which is mpg
so i can also do it in this way where i
set ggplot2
and then pass and look at the data set
what we have here
you can just do a view on this to see
what my data contains if the fields have
any any values if that's going to affect
your plotting so now what we can do is
we can create a bar plot or a bar chart
so i am saying gg plot the data would be
as we have given in previous lines that
is ggplot2 mpg then i will
say what should be in my aesthetics and
what kind of
chart are you going to create so i'm
saying geom underscore bar so that's my
bar chart and that has basically your
class and count now you can create a
stacked bar chart where your information
is stacked in the same bars
and we are still using the same data
we are going for aesthetics which is
class and then when you say geom bar
which creates your stack bar we will use
fill
which is drive
and we can always go back and look at
our data for example
you can always look into this so you
have the drive column here
and you are also working on this
complete data set so let's go ahead and
create a stacked bar chart and that
basically gives me the information where
you have the drive information which is
stacked
here now you can do a dodge
by giving the position as dodge so we
are still going to go for a stack chart
but this time the bars will be next to
each other and that can also be done
which is very useful
you can use this by using geom point
where you are mapping and you are
specifying what are your aesthetics so
we were creating a scatter plot
now you can also use
or give more details where you can say
color can be based on the class
and we have different classes and based
on that my points have been colored
now you can also use a plot
lyu or plotly library so let's install
this one
i will say yes for example let it
basically restart so that all my
packages are updated
then i can access that package using
library function
and then
create a variable
to which you are assigning your plot
underscore ly plot so data is empty cars
what will be your x-axis what will be
your y-axis and details on your marker
which we have given
wherein i will give a list which is size
color which is a combination
and then you have your line
what kind of color it will have and what
will be the width so this is where i'm
going to use plot ly
and let's look at this plot
so it basically gives me some
information now we see some warnings
which are getting generated but there is
you don't need to worry about that so
you can look at the packages what you
have
and what options you are using so
similarly we can create one more plot
using plot ly and look at the values of
those so that's a plot with a trend
which explains me about my data
so this is a simple small tutorial on
understanding or
how you can have your graphics or
visualization
used to understand your data obviously
there are much more examples much more
ways in which you can pass into your
plot functions
or your gg plot
and the inbuilt
packages which are available in r for
your visualization now that could be for
exploratory data analysis or
explanatory data analysis so try these
graphs and see if
you can change these options and try or
create new visualizations
good morning and good evening everyone
so welcome to this session where we will
learn on time series analysis using our
programming language so this is
basically a mini project
where we will look at time series data
and how we can analyze it visualize it
to basically find some important
information or gather insights from the
data now when you talk about time series
analysis time series is basically any
data set where your values are measured
at different points in time
so when you talk about time series data
data is usually
uniformly spaced at a specific frequency
for example hourly weather measurements
you have daily counts of website visits
monthly sales total and so on so when
you talk about time series that can also
be irregularly spaced and sporadic for
example times stamp data in computer
systems event log or history of 9 11
emergency calls
now when we work with time series data
for example here i am taking a energy
data set we can see how techniques such
as time based indexing resampling
rolling windows can help us explore
variations in electricity demand and
renewable energy supply over time now
here we will look at some aspects of
this data set which i am considering so
there is this is open power systems data
set and here is the data set i have we
can look at the data set now this is in
a simple format it has time it basically
has values for consumption
and then you have data for wind and
solar and wind plus solar so in certain
cases you have only the date and the
consumption but then if we scroll down
we will also find
data for wind solar wind plus solar and
so on so this is a time series data set
which we would want to work on
sometimes you may also have the data
collected which just does not have the
time but it may also have
time stamp that is it would have say
hour minutes and seconds and that can
also be worked upon so let's consider
this data set and let's work on this
project where we will analyze this time
series data set
now here we can work on this time series
data we can basically create some data
structures out of it such as data frames
we can do some time based indexing we
can visualize the data we can look at
the seasonality in the data look at some
frequencies and also do some trend
detection
now when you talk about this data set it
has electricity production and
consumption which is reported as daily
totals in gigawatt hours
and here are the columns of the data
which i was just showing you so you have
data you have consumption you have wind
you have solar and wind plus solar so
this is the data we have and we will
basically explore say electricity
consumption and production in germany
which has varied over time so some of
the questions which we can answer here
is when is electricity consumption
typically highest and lowest how do wind
and solar power production vary with
seasons of the year
what are the long term trends in
electricity consumption solar power and
wind power how do wind and solar power
production compare with electricity
consumption and how has this ratio
changed over time
we can also do wrangling or cleaning of
this data or pre-processing of data and
create a data frame and then we can
visualize this
now let's see how do we do that so i
will open up my rstudio and let's look
at the data set so here is the data set
now i'm picking it up from my machine
you can also pick it up from github so
all the data sets or similar data sets
can be find in my github repository and
here
i can look in the data sets you will
find
a lot of different data sets here there
are some time series data sets such as
power
i can search for power or you have
basically
coal
or you have
this
opsd
germany daily data set and there are
many other data sets which you can work
on
now to
get the documentation on this project
you can also look in my github
repository and you can search for
repositories
and then basically you can look in data
science and r
and here there is a project folder where
i have given the documentation sample
data set and also
your time series analysis related
document this is also the code which you
can directly import in your r studio and
you can practice or work on this project
so let's see how does that work
so first thing is we will create a data
frame
from this data set now here if you see i
am using header as true so that it
understands the heading of each column i
am also giving row.names and i'm
specifying date so there is this date
column in the data set as i showed you
earlier let's look at it again so you
have date consumption wind solar wind
plus solar so you can suggest that date
should become the index column which can
be useful so you can do this now let's
just
create this
let's look at what does this data frame
contain
and here if you see it shows me some
data which
has been
now as a part of this data frame
structure
it starts with consumption wind solar
wind plus solar and if you see this one
is becoming my index column so i can
always do a head and look at part of the
data frame using head or tail so look at
the first records so let's see this now
that shows me the head data i can also
do a tail and look at the
ending values so if you closely see here
we have wind
solar
wind
dot solar and that basically has n a
values so there are missing values but
let's look at the tail and that tells me
that there is some data available for
wind and solar and wind solar
now we can always look in a tabular
format using view
and we can look at the data so this
shows me that there are
values in these columns we see any
values but if i really scroll down
i can see
some values which would be available for
wind and solar and wind solar so i can
just use view now i can look at the
dimensions of this particular object
and that tells me there are 400
4384
rows and four columns you can always
look at the structure that is check the
data type of each column which can be
very useful so if i see here i don't see
the date column because date column was
considered as an index which can be
useful but i also look at my other
columns they are of the num types so
that's the data type for each
attribute or each column here
now we would be interested in looking at
this date column so let's look at the
data type of this date column
now if i try to do this this will show
me that this is null because date as a
column does not exist because we created
it as an index so if i look at row names
and then i search
for my data show me the index column or
row.names it tells me these are the
values that's the date column
which we are seeing here now we can
access a specific row by just doing a my
data and give the index value or row
name value so let's look at that and
that shows me based on this index you're
looking at the value you can obviously
search for a different date something
like this you can also pass in a vector
and you can give
range of values so that is
0 1 2006 to 4 of january and we can look
at this one so it shows me
these are the values so here actually
i'm not giving a range but i'm just
selecting
multiple values from row.names now we
already know that in r you have a
summary function so you can always do a
summary and that gives you
for each column it gives you minimum
first quartile median mean third
quartile and maximum values so we are
looking at consumption we are looking at
wind solar and wind dot solar
now this is good but then if i would
want to really visualize the data access
the data do some analysis then it would
be good to
take all the columns and then we can
later decide to change the data type of
say date column if we want to use it so
earlier i was using date as
row.names or the name of the rows or
index what you call in any other
programming language so here i will just
use my data set and i'll say header is
true i'm calling it mydata2 let's look
at the data and this one shows me five
columns where in my first column is the
date
consumption wind solar and so on now
looking at the structure
so let's look at the data type
so it tells me that if now i'm
interested in looking at the date column
from my data to data frame it tells me
it is a factor with four 384 levels and
these are the values
so
it is not in a date time format it's a
factor
now what we can do is we can convert
this into a date format how do we do
that so let's have a variable x and i'm
going to use as dot date function and
i'm going to pass in my date column so
that's
assigned to x now let's look at the head
of x and it shows me the values we will
also see what kind of class it is
and we will look at the structure of x
so class already says it is date type
and look at the structure so it shows me
the format
now we have converted this column or
column related value into x now how do i
basically
extract values out of it or make it a
part of data frame so first i will use
so all once it has been converted in
date format i will go for as dot numeric
and here i will create a variable called
year and i will just do a format on x
which is basically of date type and then
i am saying
percentage y so that will get me the
year component out of this let's look at
the values
that shows me ear component
now similarly we can get the month out
of this and then basically look at the
month values we can get the day out of
it and we can get the day component now
if i look at my data 2 which we had
created earlier this basically had date
consumption wind solar wind solar so
what i can do is i can add these
extracted columns such as year month day
to my data frame using a c byte that is
column bind and i will assign it to my
data to again so let's do this and now
if you look at head it shows me
date so that should be date format
consumption now this one might not be
date format but we'll see you have
consumption wind solar and we have
extracted the year month and day which
can help us for group by we can do some
aggregations we can do a plotting
and we can do various things by these
additional columns now let's look at
first three rows here so i'll say one is
to three for my data two and that shows
me some data here you can always do a
head and look at the sample of data so
that basically shows me month
day
your columns and then you have your date
now what we can do is we would want to
visualize this data we would want to
basically understand the consumption now
as i said
if we want to visualize the data say for
example i want this which is consumption
of data over years and this one is in
terms of gigawatts per hour as we were
mentioning here gigawatt hours so if i
would want to create this visual to
basically understand the pattern of the
data how do we do it so we can you
create a line plot of full time series
of germany's
electricity consumption using the plot
method now how do we do that so here
one of the option is i can straight away
use the plot method
i can then say what would be in my
x-axis what would be on my y-axis
what would be the type of
graph i would want to plot what is my
name on x-axis y-axis and this is the
simplest way so i am saying my data 2 i
am extracting the year column
and here i am taking the consumption so
let's create a plot
and here if you see we are looking at a
plot we do see some tick times and we
see that the data has been divided with
every two years so from 2006 onwards to
2016
but then really this data does not give
me
uh you know a very useful way of looking
at the rate or understanding it might be
what i can do is i can use the same way
but i can give apart from x-axis and
y-axis i can say
the
limits that is x limit is 2006 to 2018
and y limit is from 800 to 1700 so we
can do this and let's look at this again
this is a plot but it really does not
help me in visualizing and understanding
the data so what are the better options
i can go for multiple plots in a window
as of now we are just sticking to one
plot in window so if you would want to
have multiple plots you can always
change the value here and make it two or
three that will say how many rows and
how many columns as of now we will just
keep it as it is par
mf row now
if i would want to plot i can straight
away give the column name so i am
interested in getting the consumption
now i can just do a plot i'll say
mydata2 and i will choose the second
column which is consumption which we saw
here from our data so consumption was
the second column so i can just do a
plot in a straight away way without
mentioning your x-axis y-axis limits and
so on and if you look at this this one
is giving me
a pattern now here i am looking at
x-axis y-axis which is not really named
we do not have a name to this graph
and we are looking at the data it does
show me some kind of pattern but
might be we can make it more meaningful
so i can do it this way where i say my
data second column let's give access as
year x axis y axis is consumption
now that has changed
the x-axis and y-axis now i can also
give some more details i can say type
should be line
i have the line width i am saying color
is blue
and let's do this so this looks more
meaningful might be shows a wavering
pattern of consumption over years
i can also give a
limit of x that is 0 to 2018 and that
basically shows me the range now we can
change that and we can be more specific
and saying x limit should be 2006 to
2018
and let's look at this now this one once
you have given a proper limit it shows
the line graph and it shows what was the
consumption in 2006 and over a period
till 2018.
i can then
use any of these options are fine but it
depends on what and whom you are
presenting the data or what kind of
analysis you are doing so i can do a
plot i can choose column second x lab
which is x axis y axis type is line
width giving x limit y limit and then
i'm giving a title to this which is
consumption graph
and then basically you are looking at
the line graph
now those are the options which you can
do either you could be very specific or
you could just
give
your column which you want to plot or
obviously make it more meaningful by
giving all the details
now what we can do is if we would want
to look at
this data and understand it better
rather than just looking at a simple
line i can take the log values so here
i'm saying log of
my data to second column so i'm taking
log values of consumption and i'm taking
the difference of logs so i can say
difference and then you can basically
increase or decrease this by multiplying
it by some number so rest remains the
same i'm changing the color and let's
look at this plot and you see this
basically is giving me a better pattern
which makes meaning here we see the log
values so this is you are using a simple
plot function
in r you can also use ggplot now for
that we can install the ggplot package
it's already there in my machine so i'll
say no
i will access this by using the library
gg plot 2
and now i can use gg plot to plot so
the way you specify here you can say
mydata2 that's the data frame i am
saying type as o and when i am saying
line i am basically going to
use x axis which is year y is
consumption and let's look at this plot
so again we are back to the one which we
were doing earlier really does not make
any sense it gives us some data
but then really does not give me enough
information
i can
in my aesthetics i can say x as year y
is consumption i can do a grouping and
then i can give line and plot so again
we have some information but really does
not help me right now let's look at
other example so i'm just doing the same
thing here and i'm looking at line type
being tasked i'm using the gg plots
other methods such as geom line and gm
point to give me more information and if
i look at the
plot it does give me data it tells me
what are the different values it gives
me some kind of pattern but i would
still prefer the way we were doing with
plot now
we can change the color and obviously
add details to it so what we see is when
you use the plot method which i did
earlier it was choosing pretty good tick
locations that is every two years
and labels the years for the x axis
which was helpful
right but with these data points which
we were seeing here
or say for example this one
or say this one
or say this one we are looking at some
data but then that
really is quite crowded
and it is hard to read you can look at
the values but then it really does not
give you enough information so we can go
for plot method but then we will see how
we can consider different data now if i
would want to plot the solar and wind
time series so let's see how do we do
that
so
wind column is what i'm interested in so
first thing is it was always good to
find out the minimum and the maximum
values in every column so i'm saying
minimum i'm saying let's put in here my
data 2
and then let's look at the values so we
are looking at the columns
we know consumption is the second column
wind is the third column
and
you have solar as the fourth and this
one is the fifth so let's say let's find
out the minimum of each of these columns
which we would want to plot so let's say
minimum of data third column and here
i'm also saying remove the n a values
because we do not want to consider the n
a values so let's let look at the
minimum that shows me 5.7757
what is the maximum value it is 826 so
that also helps me in giving a limit if
i want to plot wind on y axis i can give
a y limit from 5 to 850
consumption wise let's find out the
minimum from second column and maximum
and similarly for solar find the minimum
and maximum and wind plus solar minimum
and maximum so this will be helpful when
you would want to plot multiple graphs
or
give some limits so that's fine now for
multiple plots as i said
instead of having one plot let's plot
consumption and wind and solar and try
to see a pattern so i can say par
function and i will say three rows and
one column so
now when i start plotting you will see
you will have multiple plots in one
single window so let's see how we do it
so here
let's look at plot one so this one is
consumption as we did earlier
and let's look at the data so that gives
me some data you can always do a zoom
and you can look at the data you can
basically expand this graph or you can
reduce this graph to see
what kind of pattern we have in
consumption similarly we can
basically choose
date being
x axis
my consumption being y-axis right so
this is being more specific because here
we have a range but it really does not
give me enough information so i will
basically give
x-axis y-axis i will give the name that
is daily totals and then i will
basically give consumption color and y
limit based on my minimum and maximum
limits so let's do this
and now we can
look at the data here so let's see this
data
makes a little more meaning because we
are looking at the dates
and let me do a zoom so it shows me all
the dates it shows me the data points it
shows me
how the data
pattern is changing for consumption
now
this is for consumption so what we can
do is
we can also extract specific data so if
you see here i have done some testing
where i am saying okay i would want to
get
a date specifically
i would want to extract some value so we
are looking at the date column but if
you remember we did not change the data
type we just changed the data type of
date column we extracted year month out
of it
it would be good if we can
convert a column into date time format
and put that in our data frame now
let's look at the plot2
this is mainly for
your
column
which should be consumption and wind and
solar so here i see it is solar data and
i can plot this one
to see how it looks like
and that tells me from 2006
onwards we have some pattern
i can
be more specific where i say
i would be giving date and then
the
column for solar x-axis y-axis what is
the type what is the y limit and what is
the color
it is always good to specify your x and
y axis give a name rather than let it
automatically pick up now this makes
more meaning because it shows me some
dates
similarly we can do for wind
so either you do it just by giving the
column
or you give your x and y axis so let's
look at this one
and this shows me the data so we can
choose plot three
this one we can choose plot two
we can choose plot one and we can put
all that data in one graph
so that's when you are putting in multi
plots in one particular graph you can
always do a zoom
you can always look at the data right
and this is usually useful to look at
the pattern what kind of pattern we see
what data we have and so on now
moving forward so we have seen how you
are creating these plots all in one
window let me reset this back to one
plot per window
and let's basically plot time series in
a single year so what we have seen is
that when you look at the plot method it
was quite crowded then we looked at
solar and wind and if you compare that
you will see your consumption pattern
your solar pattern your wind pattern and
basically we can see from this
particular data some kind of pattern
so electricity consumption is highest in
the winter
where we will see what is the
consumption
is it highest in winter or is it in
summer we can see that by breaking a
year
further into months we can see that but
we see a pattern which goes for every
year or every two years being highest at
a particular point of time and then it
drops down
so electricity consumption is highest in
winter and that might be due to
electrical heating
and increased lighting usage and lowest
in summer
now when you look at electricity
consumption appears to split into two
clusters we can always look at the
consumption one with oscillation
centered roundly around 1400 gigawatts
so you can always look at fourteen
hundred gigawatts and you see all the
values here which are in that particular
consumption
another with fewer and more scattered
data points centrally roughed around one
one five zero so if you really expand
this you can see you will have lot of
data points at this point
now
we might guess that these clusters
correspond with weekdays and weekends
which we can see if you break that data
into yearly monthly weekly and so on now
if you look at solar production
that is highest in summer when sunlight
is most evident and lowest in winter so
obviously when you are making or
gathering some insights when you're
looking at the data you are also using
your domain knowledge your business
knowledge your
you know knowledge of business to
understand how this goes
if you look at wind power production
that's again highest in winters and
drops down in summer so due to stronger
winds and more frequent storms and
lowest in summer
so there is some kind of increasing
trend in wind power production over
years which we can see here
over the years and
all the time series data what we are
looking at
is
referring or showing us some kind of
seasonality that is we are looking at
seasonality in which a pattern is
repeating again and again at regular
times
at regular intervals so if you look at
consumption solar and wind time series
that oscillates between high and low
values on a yearly time scale which we
can break down and see i'll show you
that
it corresponds with the seasonal changes
in weather over the year
so seasonality
does not have to correspond with
meteorological reasons for example if
you look at retail stale sales data
that will show you yearly seasonality
with increased sales in particular
months
so seasonality when we say can occur on
other time scales so the plots what we
are seeing here
they are fine
but if you look at those plots they
might
show some kind of weekly seasonality
also
so in your consumption corresponding to
weekdays and weekend so let's plot for
one single year now how do i do that so
first is i will look at mydata2
that shows me the structure it shows me
date which is factor other columns which
are all numerics
now like we did earlier i'll repeat this
step where i'm going to convert the date
column into date type
look at head of it look at class of it
look at the structure of it right and
then what i want to do is i want to add
this
as to my data frame so i will create a
variable called mod data
and this one will have as data and i'm
formatting
the value of x which is date time into
month day and year so let's do that
and now you look at the mod data which i
created like modified data so this is
the format i have it is in date type if
you carefully see here and then i can
look at the head of it
so it saves me more data
now
we are what we did here is when i said
my data 3
so
my data 3
we did a
c bind and i did a mod data which is
going to add this column to my
other columns of my data too so my new
data frame is my data 3 let's look at
the structure of it and you see there is
this date column i can delete it i can
remove it i can let it be right so that
depends on our choice might be we want
to once our analysis done we want to
remove the mod data right so we can keep
both of them
now
let's
basically extract data for a particular
year now how do you do that so this is
some wrangling so i will say mydata4
let's call it mydata4 and i will use
subset function so subset will work on
my data 3 that's the data and what i'll
do is i will do a subset how do how is
the subset found so i'll say take the
mod data
column the value should be
greater than or equal to 2017 and should
be less than
2017 december 31st so i'm getting data
for one year and i'm storing it as my
data four
let's get the head of it and you see we
are specifically looking at 2017 related
data
now let's do a plotting of this where i
will only
create a plot for one year so i'm saying
my data for that's my new
data what we got
so
here i am going to take the first column
which is mod data i am going to take the
third column which is consumption so i
am looking at the date format for one
year consumption values for it and then
rest of the things as we have done
earlier let us look at the plot and this
makes more meaning right so when you
look at this plot it tells me jan to jan
it shows me some kind of pattern where i
have divided the year into months
right and it is broken down into say two
months so jan and march and may and july
and so on but we still see a pattern and
that gives me good understanding of
pattern where i've broken it down into
months
so this is where you have taken time
series in a single year to investigate
further and this is what we see
right now we can clearly see there are
some weekly
oscillations
what one more interesting feature is
that at this level of granularity that
is when you're looking at yearly data
there is a drastic decrease in
electricity consumption in early january
and late december during the holidays or
probably we can assume that this is
holidays now i can zoom in further and
look at just jan and feb data
let's see how we do that and let's see
how we work by zooming in the data
further so to
zoom in the data further let's see how
we do it now here we have this mydata4
which is basically having a subset right
so let's work on this one so i will say
my data 4 which earlier i was taking
data 3 i was doing a subset and i was
giving the date but this time i will
make it more
narrower so i will say my data 4 i will
say subset from my data 3
and i will choose mod data column which
we have modified with the date format i
will choose the starting date as 1701
that is jan and then let's go till feb
and let's create this
now let's look at the head of this so it
shows me we have the data which is jan
and then you you can basically look at
more on this
now again as i said earlier let's find
out the minimum of this from the
first
column so that is basically your mod
data so let's look into this one
and that basically
will give me minimum and maximum let's
look at the values so this one tells me
jan 17 january 1
and maximum is
your
feb 28th second month 2017. so we are
actually looking at two months data here
let's look at the y minimum so this is i
will look at
column three now what is column three
consumption so let's look at the minimum
value for consumption
maximum value of consumption let's look
at the values which can be given as our
limits
now this is the minimum and maximum now
let's do a plotting for this data which
has been narrowed down
for consumption based on my data so i am
saying
my first column which is mod data and
then third column which is consumption i
am giving some
naming convention for sorry namings for
your x-axis y-axis
what is my
consumption
or what is my title here what is the
color and then you see i'm using x limit
to give the minimum and maximum limit
and y limit so let's look at this data
and if you
look at this data
it is specifically for two months and
again i can look at the pattern here
what i can also do is i can add some
grid here
so i can basically look at this data and
make more meaning out of it so it is
bi-weekly data you can see now i can add
a line here using ab line and then i can
basically choose what lines i would want
to add horizontally
so that basically allows me to dissect
the data and look at data in a more
meaningful way i can also
add vertical lines so vertical lines is
i'm saying sequence will be minimum
maximum and i'm saying an interval of
seven
so let's do this and
this basically has added some lines
every week and you can see at the end of
week it is dropping and then it is
starting again it peaks somewhere in the
middle of the week and again it
drops down so this is you're looking at
your consumption data right now what we
can also do is we can create some box
plots so when we looked at zooming in
data for jan and feb you can add some
data points like this so consumption is
highest on the weekdays as i showed you
here and lowest on the weekends so this
is what we are seeing when we are
breaking the data or zooming it further
for a couple of months
so we have vertical grid lines
and we have nicely formatted tick labels
that is jan 1st and 15th feb first and
so on so we can easily tell which days
are weekdays and weekends with use of
these grid lines and basically breaking
it down so there are many other ways to
actually visualize your time series data
depending on what patterns you are
trying to explore you can use scatter
plots you can use heat maps you can just
use histograms and so on
now moving further we would want to
explore the seasonality right so when
you further explore the seasonality of
our data we can use box plots basically
to group the data by different time
periods and display the distribution for
each group now how do we do that
let's come here and let's see how box
plot works so i can just do a simple box
plot and i can choose my consumption
column and that gives me just the
consumption data but this really does
not give me any meaning i can look at
solar data i can look at the wind data
and we can also see some outliers here
so we can create box plots but
if we would want to do a box plot what
is box plot it is basically a visual
display of your phi number summary that
is you want to look at your mean median
you want to look at your 25th percentile
50 percentile
or 75th percentile so we can use a
quantile function use the consumption
column and then you basically give
a vector which shows you find number
summary so that's your quantile and then
let's do a box plot so if you are
looking at quantile it tells me what is
the minimum what is 25th percentile 50
75th 100 that's from my consumption
column so let's create a box plot for
consumption
let's give it a name as consumption
let's give y axis as consumption and a
limit
for
y-axis now that's my consumption graph
so i can look at yearly data now that
will make more meaning rather than just
looking at the complete consumption data
so how do we do it early so we will say
consumption
and then i will say the year column so
it is consumption but grouped based on
year
so here i can give x axis y axis and i
can give y limit so let's create this
and this makes more meaning we can give
some coloring scheme here but now i'm
looking at 2006 2007 8 9 and so on and
we can look at the data what is the
range right it gives me five percentile
or sorry five number summary of the data
per year and it basically allows me to
look at the seasonality of this
similarly we can create box plot
by just giving consumption yearly
grouped and here i am giving the title
as consumption y-axis
x-axis and y-limit
wherein i can also use less so this is
one more feature which you can do and
that basically will give me
the tick points if you compare this one
to the previous graph
so when i created this previous graph i
had 2006 2008 and i had from 600 to 1800
and if i go for the next one
i am basically seeing more useful
information now let's look at monthly
data
so
i would want to group it based on months
and let's create that so this gives me
the monthly data where i'm looking at
months
and i could select a particular year or
i can just do a grouping based on months
so
i can have multiple plots to see a
difference here so let's do this
now let's create a box plot for
consumption which is monthly data and
let's give it a color let's look at the
wind data which is again grouped monthly
and let's look at the solar data which
is grouped monthly
now if i zoom in it basically gives me
the seasonality of the data
for your wind for your consumption for
your solar so what we are doing is we
are creating these box plots
which are giving us
values now what i can also do is i could
look at the day wise also but before we
look into this how do i
infer some information from these box
plots which are being created so this is
what we have done where we are looking
at the data for month and these box
plots give me ear seasonality
which we were seeing in earlier plots
but give some additional insights so if
i look at the data here it tells me the
electricity consumption is generally
higher in winter
now this is based on months so we can
see consumption is higher in winters
and lower in summer so we can obviously
look at our plot we can see where it is
lower where it is higher and then
we can
look at the median and lower two
quartiles are lower in december and
january compared to november and
february so that is you look at the
quartiles and you will see
that
the median and lower two quartiles are
lower in december and january
here jan and december so you can look it
from my plot
now
this is giving you some idea on
seasonality
now
that might be due to business being
closed over holidays now this one we
were also seeing when we looked at time
series for 2017 only and box plot
basically confirms that there is this
consistent pattern throughout the years
now when you look at
your
solar and wind power production both
will give you a year seasonality what we
are seeing here
and
if basically i look at the data so
it depends on what parameters you are
choosing but if you look at solar it
will reflect the effect of occasional
extreme wind speeds associated with
storms and other transient and since we
are grouping it based on months we can
see this pattern is quite evident every
year
now what we can do is we can group the
data day wise so here let me again reset
this to
one plot per graph
now i'll say box plot i'll say
consumption which is group based on day
now we know that there is a day column
and let's give a while limit and let's
look at the data so this is where i'm
grouping the data day wise
so you look at 31 days and you look at
the box plot so this is where you are
plotting it on a daily basis
so you can look at the data you can
break it down to a particular week so
here i have given
a day and i have chosen all the 31 days
but i can break it down to a week and i
can look at the data so
if we look at the data per week or per
day we can basically infer that
electricity consumption
where i'm doing a consumption group by
day
is higher on weekdays than on weekends
so
time series with strong seasonality
can
often be represented with models that
can decompose signal into seasonality
and long trend
now this is
an easy way now how do we look at the
frequency of the data that could be
interesting to see
so let me
look at
say the yearly data
which we were seeing here
now let's go further and here
we have looked at data so what we will
do is we look at the frequency now when
you look at the frequency
when you talk about frequency in your
data so we have the modified date column
which gives me a frequency and if we
really look into the data that will tell
me
that the data is on a daily basis so for
that let's look at my data three again
which gives me data and you can just see
all the data's data or dates are in
sequence so you're 22 23 24 25 26 and so
on i can look at i can access a d player
package
that is basically
allowing me to work in a better way now
i can look at the summary of this and
for all my columns i am seeing
what is the minimum phi number summary
date and consumption so date does not
show me anything because this is not in
a date format it is just a factor but
other things have the fine number
summary so we are looking at wind plus
solar
we are looking at year and month and day
and all these columns now what we will
do is we will want to find out the sum
of each
column
how many entries does it have and we
will say the value should any value
should not be considered so let's look
at this one so it tells me for my
particular columns
so let me run this again
and that shows me
for each column how many values you have
and
these
counts
do not include the n a values
now similarly i can find out
specifically for consumption i can find
out is there any n a value so i'm saying
is dot n a and let's find out if there
is any n a value or missing value in
consumption it says zero
okay that's good
if you look in wind
it tells me there are
1463 entries which are any
similarly solar
similarly
wind dot solar or wind plus solar so it
gives me a count of
n a values that is missing values
and also values which are not missing so
to understand frequency what we can do
is we can find out the minimum
on the date that is the first column and
i am saying
rm
na dot rm is true that is get rid of n a
values and find out the minimum
and let's look at the minimum value
this is the minimum from my modified
date
now if i would want to get the frequency
i can basically use sequence function so
i can say
from x minimum that is the minimum value
i want to look at the frequency that is
day wise and let's just look at five
entries and see if there is a
day by day frequency
so let's look at the value of this and
obviously it tells me there is device
frequency
so that allows me to look at the
frequency look at the type of it it is
an integer class is a date
so similarly we can say from x minimum
we can basically look at the frequency
month-wise
and i can again look at five records so
that shows me monthly data
right so i can
extract the data for frequency similarly
yearly data and that's also very useful
now
we can select data which has n a values
for wind
so how do i do it i would want to find
out
the wind column and i want to find out
where the values are and a so
i will create a variable
and here i will say mydata3
and then i give a conditional where i
say is na
in the column so let's do this now once
i've done this
once i've done this i have said that my
selected wind data from my data 3 where
we said na values
and i will give the names to this so
name should be in my data3 i'm
interested in mod data consumption wind
and solar so these are the four columns
i'm interested in let's look at first 10
records here or first 10 rows so that
tells me these are the values where wind
has n a
or missing values
i can always do a view and that gives me
the complete data so it basically shows
me
1463 entries
and here it shows me all n a values so
you can look at all the way to the end
and it shows me wind has n a solar does
have some value here
in the last row but then also if you see
the numbers have
a difference so you have one four six
one and then you have two one seven four
so there is a difference so there is
some data in between where wind has some
values so we have found out n a values
now
what we will do is we will select data
which does not have any values so i will
call it cell selected win2
i'll again use mydata3 i will say which
but now i'm saying not any
from this column and i will select the
data for the columns so i'm interested
in looking at
10 records and this shows me not any
value so no more missing values so if i
really look at this data as i saw
earlier which has n a and if i look at
these values which are not any for the
wind column so looking at these two
result we will know that in year 2011
wind column
has some missing values
so let's focus on year 2011. so how do i
do that let's call it a different
variable i'll say mydata3 i will say
here when i say which where we were
saying na
here i will say the year should have a
value of 2011 and i want all these
columns
let's look at the data here and this is
showing me 2011 but
we
are not seeing all the values so there
are some values but then there are some
missing values also for 2011 based on
whatever analysis we have done so let's
look at the class of this it is
basically a data frame do a view
and this one will help me in finding out
where are the any values so if you just
scroll down
looking at all the data let's search if
wind column has a n a or a missing value
and i will see
if there is any missing value in which
column or which row it is for the wind
column so we have all the values which
are existing
i could select and search for one
specific value and i'll show you how we
can do that so here let's scroll all the
way down so it's like you're exploring
your data
and seeing
is wind column having n a or missing
value for a particular row
and let's scroll here and here you see
there is a missing value for one
particular row so
13th
december 2011 has wind value
15 december has wind value but
your 14th december does not have right
similarly we can search so there was
only one entry which was missing now
that could be for some reason might be
it was not calculated might be it was
not tabulated so we have a missing value
and that
can affect my plotting that can affect
my analysis so let's look at the number
of rows
in this which will tell me how many rows
we have
for 2011 so it tells me 365 so that is
basically the number of days in a year
now we will find out if
there were any values so we earlier
checked total number of na values per
column
that is
in your row number 265 to 269
we can see here 265 to 269.
so this is where we were seeing
are there any n a values right so let's
go back here
and
we want to find out the number of n a
values for a particular year how do i do
it so i can just do a sum i will say is
n a
now i am interested in my data 3
wind column and i am saying my year has
to be 2011 but i am finding out the n a
values
so let's do this and it tells me one and
that's right that's what we saw when we
did a view let's see
how many non-na values you have and that
is 364 so that
basically
satisfies my logic so it's 364 plus 1
missing so there are 365 let's look at
the structure of this it tells me you
have modified date and date format you
have consumption wind and solar now
let's create a variable
selected wind 4
i will save in 3 that is which was
having all my n a and
non n a values for 2011
i will say
let's find out the n a value
because i'm interested in finding out
that particular row so i'm saying find
out where the value is n a and i want
all the columns
let's look at this one and this is my
specific
row which has a n a value
now
we know that data follows a device
frequency which we have clearly seen now
let's select data which has any and non
na values
so
let's say let's call it test1 i will use
win3 which has
any non-na values but now i will say i
want the modified date which should be
greater than 12 12 2001. now remember we
had when we were doing a view we saw
that one particular day or what we see
here 14th of december there is no date
so i will select a subset of data
which includes this n a and non n a that
is might be i can take 13th of december
and 15th of december so let's start from
12 12
so the date should be greater than 12 12
that means 13 and it should be less than
16 so that is 15
and the columns
right so
now we have some data let's look at this
so i have
a i've selected a subset of data i could
have done this using subset also so i
have any and non-any values now
why are we doing this so sometimes you
might have some data for a particular
column and you may want to find out if
there are any missing values might be
you want to fill them up or replace them
with something so that is usually useful
when you are doing a trend detection so
say for example you have data for every
month and might be in one one of the
months you have missed or might be you
have data for every year collected
monthly and then in one of the years for
couple of months you don't have the data
like i can say 2016 i have data for all
12 months 2017 all 12 months 2018 might
be i don't have data from march and june
2019 i don't have data for same months
so i can forward fill or backward fill
them using the previous years same month
data so we can do that so here i have
test data where i've extracted a subset
of data
i can look at the
class of this it is a data frame
structure of this it has the columns now
let's use that library
and
function and use the tidy r package
and what we will do is we will fill it
up so i will use test one i will fill
the wind column which has a missing
value now once you do this if you notice
it has done a forward fill so it has
taken the previous value and it has just
filled up that so you can
fill up the data using different
directions such as up and down left and
right and so on so we can take care of
missing values
in our frequency data which allows us to
basically
analyze the data in a better way now
here we will want to also look at some
more data so this is to deal with
frequencies of fill column
wherein you can take care of missing
values forward filled so filling values
can be done in different directions as i
said and you may want to first convert
your time series to specified frequency
if
your data does not have a frequency but
we had now if you do not have a
frequency might be you can convert it
into a frequency such as weekly daily
monthly as i showed you and then
basically you can
do a forward fill
for the value so for example if i have
my data i can break it down into weekly
and then look at the values and if there
are any values missing for weekly data i
can use a forward fill so that can take
care of my frequency data
then
let's look at the trends of the data
which is the last part of this project
so basically let's look at the trend so
when you say trend what does that mean
so in time series data
you always have some kind of trend so
that will exhibit some slow gradual
variability
in addition to higher frequency
variability such as seasonality and
noise
now
to visualize these trends what we do is
we use what we call as rolling means so
we know how our data is spread over year
or month or day but how about looking at
a rolling average and see what is the
difference so a rolling mean
will tend to smooth a time series by
averaging out the variations and
frequencies
so this can be higher than the window
size so there is something called as
windowing where you can choose a set of
time frame
you can also average out any seasonality
on a time scale equal to window size so
this will allow you to look at lower
frequency variation in the data
so when we are looking at electricity
consumption time series we already saw
there is a weekly pattern there is a
yearly seasonality which we saw using
box plots so we can also look at the
rolling means of the time scales how do
we do that so for this you can use some
package like zoo and then you can
basically use a rolling mean
using this zoo package
and you can say what
is the
frequency with which you want to
calculate the rolling mean
now how do we do this
let's look at this data so here i'm
going to my look at my data 3 which we
have been using so far now let's call it
a 3 day test you can give it any name
i'm going to use my data 3
i'm using the pipe in function
now i will use d plier and i will
arrange the data descending in here now
you can always break it down step by
step and you can see the result of this
so i'm going to arrange this data in
descending order of year
so obviously my last one 2017 or 2018
will be on the top you want to group the
data by year so it depends on how many
years we have we'll see so you can group
the data by year now this data is then
used to basically mutate so mutate
function is going to allow me to use
this rolling mean so i will call it as
says zero three day so i'm going to
calculate a rolling mean every three
days
for my consumption column
and
basically let's ungroup this so let's
see how this works
sorry yeah let's look at this and
here when i'm doing a three-day test
let's look at the result of this and
then i'll explain this so if you see
here we have the test three day column
now this has the rolling average now
what does that mean so first value here
what we see is one three six seven
is the average consumption in 2017
from the first date with the data point
on either side of it that is you can
look at
this
date so 1 1 3 0
then you look at
you are looking at the value 1 3 6 7
here so you look at one one three zero
one four four one one five three zero if
i take a mean of these so for example if
i would just do this part
and that
is giving me
mean okay because i have a comment so
let's basically add anything as comment
and then let's do this so it saves me
one three six seven that's what we are
seeing here right so you've got getting
a rolling average every three days
similarly if you want every five days it
takes the five values and it gets the
mid value right so you can always find
out the mean
rolling mean
for a particular frequency now let's do
that for seven days that is weekly data
and yearly data that is 365 days so how
do i do it same logic my data test
now i am using my data 3 i am arranging
it in a descending order i am grouping
by year so when you do a group by year
so earlier when we did a grouping by and
when we looked at the data it was
telling me how many rows we had
right so let's do a grouping by year and
let's say test 0 7 so that's a rolling
average every 7 days and i'm also saying
take care of the n a values similarly
i'm getting rolling average every 365
days might be you can do quarterly might
be you can do half yearly and let's do
this so let's
create this my data test and let's look
at the result of this so i will use my
data test i will say arrange
based on modified date now we know there
is a column called modified date i want
to just look at 2017 data so i'm doing a
filter
right and then i will choose what are
the columns i'm interested in so i will
look at the 7 and 365 day and let's look
at say first seven records
so let's do this
and that basically gives me the
consumption value modified date year and
my rolling seven day average order of
seven day mean
which is for first 7 days and then 365
you will not see the data here but if i
do a view on this i can basically see
the values
so you can always select a particular
column to see the
values these are the values for every 7
day rolling average
this is for 365 days every 365 days so
you see all the values are missing but
every 365 entry you will have basically
some data now
let's do a plotting of this and
basically visualize this data which we
are seeing rolling average so let me
first do a plotting one plot per graph
and let's do a plotting i will take
consumption data
x-axis y-axis
color and give a title to this so let's
create this and that's my consumption
data which is
spread over a period of time and that's
fair enough but now let's add some more
plot to this so i will add the seven day
rolling average to this
so for second plot to be added in the
same one in r you can use points so i
will say points i will choose 7 data
column
type is line width
x limit y limit and color so let's do
this
and that's my
pattern seven day rolling average which
basically gives me some kind of trend
similarly i can add one more here and
this time i will choose the 365 day
and look at the pattern lines so now you
see some dots here well you could do it
in a different way so i can just add
legend to this and i can say legend will
be
where in x-axis and y-axis so i am
saying it will be 2500
and y is 1800 so my legend will come in
somewhere in here i am saying my legend
will have consumption
test
and this one i can give some names i can
give what is the color
i can say what kind of
legend it explains what is
for each color and then basically a
vector so let's add a legend to this and
i've added a legend now you can do a
zoom and look at the data
and
here i see that
my x-axis is fine but y-axis is going a
little
out of my plotting area so i can
actually change that so here i have 1800
how about making it 1600
and let's look at this one
so
we can basically
go for this one and start again here
plot
and points and line and then add a
legend right and you can basically place
your legend anywhere in the plot so this
basically is giving me the trend what
i'm looking at
my
rolling average
so similarly you can look at the trend
for wind and solar data so what we are
seeing here is when you look at trend
this is one more way of looking at it
you can always create plots in different
ways so
seven day rolling mean has smoothed out
all weekly seasonality which we were
seeing here in my graph where you look
at every seventh day preserving the
yearly seasonality so
7 day will tell
that electricity consumption is
typically higher in winter and lower in
summer so better is you break it down
yearly so here if you look at every year
you can see when is winter when is
summer what is the seasonality what your
trend what you are seeing here and if
there is a decrease or increase
for few weeks
every winter
so similarly if you look at 365 now as
you said as i said rolling average
basically
reduces the variation so if i look at
365 rolling mean we can see long-term
trend
in electricity consumption is pretty
flat now that's what we are seeing it's
kind of pretty flat there is not much
variation over the years if you really
join these dots
so
we can basically see some highs and lows
and that gives me a trend now this is
how you can do a trend detection and
similarly we can do plotting for wind
and solar so this is a
small project which i demonstrated using
r
now all this code
which you have here in the form of a
project dot r file you can find here in
my github page this is a document which
explains some things feel free to
download this and you can add details to
it this is the sample data set which you
can also find in my repository in the
data sets folder so continue learning
and continue practicing r
excel is a really powerful tool for data
analytics and reporting and pivot tables
are one of the features that excel
offers for creating tabular reports to
summarize our data
let's begin by understanding what is a
pivot table
a pivot table is a tool that summarizes
and reorganizes selected columns and
rows of data in a spreadsheet to obtain
a desired report
it does not actually change the
spreadsheet data it simply pivots or
turns the data to view it in different
perspectives pivot tables are specially
useful with large amounts of data that
would be time consuming to calculate
manually
now
let's understand the different
components of a pivot table
so there are four main components
first we have rows when a field is
chosen for the row area it populates as
the first column in the pivot table
similar to the columns all row labels
are unique values and duplicates are
removed
columns
is the second component
when a field is chosen for the column
area only the unique values of the field
are listed across the top
then we have values each value is kept
in a pivot table cell and displays the
summarized information the most common
values are sum average minimum and
maximum
finally we have filters
filters apply a calculation or
restriction to the entire table
so let's jump over to microsoft excel
and let me show you the data set that we
will use in this demo
so with india being ready for its 16
census in 2021
that is next year it is a good time for
us to analyze india's last census data
from 2011 and see where different states
and cities across india stood in terms
of population literacy and other
socio-economic factors we will analyze
this data by creating different pivot
tables in excel and explore some of its
features so let's begin
first i'll show you one of the features
that excel offers us so suppose i click
on any cell and hit control plus q
you can see our entire table is selected
and at the right bottom there's an
option of quick analysis
now you can see by default excel has
prompted certain features such as
formatting we have charts totals and
there's one more called tables
now excel by default has created some
pivot tables for us now the first one
you say is sum of district code by state
names
next we have sum of sex ratio by state
name
then we have some of child sex ratio
some of male graduates and some of
female graduates by state name and there
are others before creating our pivot
table so let's have a final look at our
data set
so first column you see is the city
column so there are different cities
from different parts of india
then we have the state code we have the
state name
district code we have the total
population followed by male and female
population
next you can see we have the total
literates from each city
then we have the male and female
literates
next we have the sex ratio
then we have the child sex ratio
next we have total number of graduates
and finally you can see we have male and
female graduates so using this table
we'll create several pivot tables
now first of all let's create a pivot
table to find the total population for
each state and sort it in descending
order so you can see here we have the
problem statement
so our first pivot table will have the
total population for each of the states
in descending order
so to create a pivot table you can click
any cell
in your data
go to the insert tab
and here
left you can see we have the option to
create a pivot table so let me select
pivot table
now my range is already selected the
entire table
and here i'll choose existing worksheet
because i want to place my pivot table
in the same worksheet
and i'll give my location i'll point to
cell q5
now let me click ok
you can see the pivot table fields
appears here on the right
now since we want to find the total
population for each state so what i'll
do is
i'll drag my state name onto rows
so here in our pivot table you can see
we have the different state names listed
now
we want
the total population for each of these
states
so
in the field list i'll search for total
population which is this one and drag it
under values
you can see
we have our sum of total population for
each of these states
by default
excel will sum any numeric column you
can always change it to average minimum
maximum anything you want now we want to
sort this column in descending order so
i right click
go to sort option and choose z to a
that is largest to smallest
you can see here
in 2011 maharashtra had the highest
number of population
or the total population in maharashtra
was the highest then it was uttar
pradesh we had andhra pradesh
and if i come down we have nagaland and
andaman nicobar islands towards
the end
so this is a simple pivot table that we
created
now the next problem we have is we want
to find the total sum of literates in
each city belonging to a certain state
so let's see how to do it
i'll click on any cell go to insert
and here i can click on pivot table
my range is selected
i'll choose existing worksheet and give
my location
which is q5
i click on ok
now here
we want to find the total sum of liters
so what i'll do is
first let me drag
total literate's column to values you
have the total sum of literates from all
the states
next i want to see the sum of total
literates based on states and cities so
let me first drag
state name onto rows and then we'll drag
city
onto rows
you can see here we have our pivot table
ready
to the left of the pivot table you can
see we have the state names and
the cities per state
and on the right you can see the total
number of literates from each city if i
scroll down we have assam then you can
see we have bihar
and if i keep scrolling we have all the
states haryana himachal pradesh there's
jammu and kashmir which has now become a
union territory
we have jharkhand karnataka and other
states as well moving on
okay so the next thing we want to see is
what is the average sex ratio and the
child sex ratio for each state
with that we also want to find the
states that had the highest and lowest
sex ratio in 2011.
so let's create a pivot table for this
and click on any cell go to insert
choose pivot table
click on existing worksheet
i'll select cell q5
and click on ok
now
since we want
the average sex ratio and the child sex
ratio so first i'll drag those columns
either you can manually scroll and
drag it or here you have the option to
search for it
so if i look for child
you can see we have
the same
column listed i can just drag it from
there
let me delete this
and i also want the sex ratio
so i'll place it on top of child sex
ratio
next
we want to see it based on
different states so what i'll do is
i'll take
state name and put it under rows
so here you can see we have our pivot
table ready
on the left you can see we have the
different state names listed and on the
right we have the values
now we want to find the average now by
default
excel will sum the numeric columns you
can see it tells you sum of sex ratio
and child sex ratio
so what you can do
you can click on this drop down and go
to value field settings
and here summarize
values by you can choose average
you can see the custom name it says
average of 6 ratio
click on ok
our entire column is now
giving us the average sex ratio
similarly for
this column let me convert it into
average i'll again click on the drop
down
go to value field settings
click on average
and click ok
and you can see here we have the average
of child sex ratio
for each of the states
now the next question says
which states had the highest and lowest
sex ratio so we'll consider this column
so we'll sort it in any order you want
you can do it either ascending or
descending let me short it in descending
order
you can see we have our
column sorted now
so in 2011
kerala had the highest sex ratio
and if i scroll down to the bottom you
can see himachal pradesh had the lowest
which is around 818.
up next
let's explore one more feature of pivot
table so suppose you want to see the top
or bottom few rows
of a pivot table
you can do that as well
so here we have a question at hand
we want to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates
so let's see from the entire pivot table
how we can filter the top three cities
so i'll go to insert
click on the pivot table option
go to existing worksheet
click on q5
and hit ok
now since we want to find the top three
cities i'll drag
city column on to rows and then
we want the female graduates so in the
search bar i'll look for female
and i'll choose this column that is
female graduates and drag it
here on to values
so i have
the sum of female graduates for each of
the cities
now since we want to find the
highest number of female graduates in
the top three cities so let me first
sort this column
i'll sort it in descending order
now we have it sorted now from this you
can say that delhi greater mumbai and
bangalore
are the top three cities
but it's displaying all the cities for
us
so let's filter
only the top three so what you can do is
right click
and go to filter
under filter you have the option of top
10 i'll select this
here i only want the top three
so either you can
go down like this or you can directly
type three
your column is already selected let me
just click on ok
there you go
we have the required pivot table ready
and it only displays us the top three
cities with the highest number of female
graduates
now the next thing we want to see is how
to use a slicer in a pivot table so we
have a question here
what's the total population for all the
cities in rajasthan and karnataka
so let's create a pivot table for this
and see how you can use a slicer to
filter the table
click on existing
i'll click on a location this time q6
click ok
now since i want the total population so
i'll drag total population on to values
and then
i'll select
the city
onto rose and then the state name also
i'll place it on top of city
so you have
in the pivot table all the states and
their cities
and on the right you can see the total
population for each of these cities
but our question is we want to find only
for rajasthan and karnataka
now for that what you can do is
go to insert
and create a slicer either you can
create from this option or you can go to
pivot table analyze option and here you
have the option to create or insert a
slicer and click on this
and
since we want to slice the table based
on
state that is rajasthan and karnataka i
will choose state name
as my slicer field
you can see this is my slicer here
now
you only want
the data for rajasthan and karnataka so
i'll search for
these two
so here we have karnataka so let me
select karnataka first
and i also want for rajasthan
so let me select rajasthan also
you can see in our pivot table we only
have data for rajasthan and karnataka
so this pivot table
shows you different cities from
karnataka and the total sum of
population from each of the cities and
similarly we also have for
rajasthan
moving ahead
now we will see another very interesting
feature of pivot that is how you can
create percentage contribution of a
table
for example we have a question here
what's the percentage contribution of
male and female literates from each
state
now we want to see in terms of
percentage and not as sum or average
let's do that i'll create my pivot table
click on existing
and i'll select an empty cell
okay
now here since we want to find the
percentage contribution of male and
female literates
so first i'll drag
male literates onto values
followed by
female literates onto values by default
it has summed up the male literals and
female literacy value
and also
i want to drag
state column
to rows
so here you can see the sum of male
literates and female literates per state
i want to convert this as
percentage contribution so
what we can do is
i'll select any cell
and
i'll right click
and i'll go to show value as
and here i have the option to select
percentage of grand total so i'll select
this
you can see we have the percentage
contribution of male literates to the
total
now if i sort this you will get to know
which state
contributed or has the highest
percentage contribution
so we have maharashtra for male
literates
then we had uttar pradesh in 2011
if i come down
we had meghalaya nagaland and andaman
and nicobar islands
as those states which had little or
minimal contribution to male literates
similarly let's do it for female
literates
i'll go to so value as and select
percentage of grand total
so you can see here also maharashtra
uttar pradesh then gujarat and all had
the
highest percentage contribution to
female literature
so this is another
good feature
to convert your data and see it in terms
of percentage
now moving ahead
let's say we want to find the bottom
three cities from each state that had
the lowest female graduates
we can do that as well i'll go to insert
click on pivot
go to existing worksheet select an empty
worksheet and click on ok
now since i want to see based on
states as well as cities so let me drag
the state name first onto rows
and let's drag the city column onto rose
next
we want female graduates so let me look
for female graduates in the field list
i'll drag it on to values
now we have the list of
states and their respective cities
and to the right of the pivot table you
can see the sum of female graduates from
each city
now
first i'll
sort this column
i'll right click go to sort
and click on
shortest to largest
now we have sorted our female graduates
from
shortest or smallest to largest now
since i want to find the bottom three
cities from each state
i'll come to this cell
right click
go to filter
and select top 10
now i'll replace to opt-in with bottom
and i want the bottom three
cities from each state
i have my
column selected that is some of female
graduates if i click on ok you can see
here
some of the states don't have three
cities so you can see andaman and
nicobar islands has only one city that
is sport player
while the remaining you can find
the bottom three cities with the lowest
number of female graduates so andhra
pradesh had these three in assam we had
nagao then there was dhibrugar and
silcha
similarly if we come down in haryana we
have palval kathal and zind
if i come further here you can see for
karnataka this gangavati this rani benue
and the scholar similarly you can see
for kerala as well
now moving ahead
now in the next example i'll tell you
how you can create a calculated field or
a calculated column in excel with the
help of a pivot table
so in a pivot table you can create or
use custom formulas to create calculated
fields or items
calculated fields are formulas that can
refer to other fields in the pivot table
calculated fields appear with other
value fields in the pivot table like
other value fields a calculated field's
name may proceed with sum of followed by
the field name
so here
we have a sales table that has columns
like the items which has different
fruits and vegetables
and those have been categorized as
fruits and vegetables we have the price
per kg and this is in terms of rupees
and we have the quantity that was sold
now let's see if you want to find the
sales for each item in the table you can
create a calculated field
so your sales column is going to be
the product of price per kg
and quantity so let me show you how you
can do that with the help of a pivot
table
i'll create a pivot table first
click on an empty cell
hit ok
now
if you see on the top
under pivot table analyze
and under calculations we have the
option fields items and sets
if i click on this drop down
i get the option
to create a calculated field or insert a
calculated field i click on this
i'll give my field name as sales
and
i'll select my formula
i'll first click on
price per kg and hit insert field
i'll give a space hit shift 8 to give
the product symbol
and then i'll double click on quantity
now this is my formula for sales that is
price per kg multiplied by quantity
i click on add
and i click on ok
if you see here
there is a calculated field that is
present in the pivot table fields which
is sales but it did not add it to our
original table our original table is the
same but here we have added
a calculated field which is present only
in the pivot table list now we can use
this it has already taken it under
values
now let's say i want to find the sum of
sales for
each item
under each category
you can see it here
we have our category fruit
and we have our category vegetable
and under that we have different
items like apple apricot banana
similarly in vegetables we have broccoli
this carrots corn eggplant and others
so this is how you can create
a calculated field in a pivot table
now this one more good feature that
excel offers us in pivot table is to
create a pivot chart so you can use your
pivot table and create different charts
so i'll show you how to do that
if i go to insert
here i have the option of recommended
charts
click on this
excel
gives me some default charts which you
can use
let's say i'll select this
let me drag it
a bit to the right
here you can see i'll close this pivot
field list this is a nice
bar chart that excel has created this is
called a pivot chart now here you can
see the category fruits and vegetables
and the different fruits and vegetables
or the items
in the y-axis you can see the total
sales
if you see
from the graph
guava made the highest amount of sales
now if i sort this
let's sort this first
you can see it here fruit guava made the
highest amount of sales now since i
sorted and changed my pivot table
the pivot chart also automatically gets
updated
similarly there are other charts also
that you can create let's go to the
insert tab
and
let's click on recommended charts again
let's look for a pie chart so this is a
pie chart that you can create let me
click on ok
so here is our pie chart and each pie
represents
a certain item
and the pie that has the highest area
represents
it had the highest amount of sales in
this case you can see
it is guava and similarly we have other
items as well this is fruit banana
that's corn
and we have spinach and others
let's explore a few other charts so
first i'll
click on my pivot table go to insert and
under recommended charts let's now
select a
line chart
if i hit ok
move it to the right so this is a line
chart
you can see it starts
from guava
which had the highest amount of sales
then it
drops
and in the x-axis you can see the
different items similarly when it starts
with the vegetables
broccoli made the highest amount of
sales with
2800 rupees
and our lowest was
eggplant at 900 rupees
for fruits papaya sold the least at 700
rupees
let's take another chart i'll go to
insert under recommended charts let's
see
this time we'll see a bar chart now this
is a
horizontal bar chart and not a vertical
one we just saw a vertical
column chart like this
this is an horizontal
bar chart now you can always increase
and decrease the size of these charts
let's
explore
a last chart let's take
the area chart for now
so this is an area chart again it looks
similar to the
line chart it starts with guava which
had the highest amount of sales
similarly papaya under fruits had the
lowest amount of seals under vegetables
it was
broccoli and finally eggplant made the
lowest amount of sales under vegetable
now let's go to our first sheet and
summarize what we have done in this demo
for people tables in excel so we had our
data
this is
a 2011 census data from india we had the
different cities the state names
and we had the total population total
literature female literates male
literates we had the sex ratio total
graduates and other information
so we began by understanding
how to create a simple pivot table
where we calculated the total population
for each state and sorted it in
descending order we found that
maharashtra uttar pradesh
had the total population in 2011.
then
we saw
another private table where we
calculated the total sum of literatures
in each city belonging to a certain
state so you can see we had the
different state names and
the cities under each state
then
we saw another feature where you could
calculate the average of a certain
numerical column so here we calculated
the average sex ratio and the child sex
ratio for each state and found out which
one had the highest and lowest sex ratio
after that we saw
how you could find or filter tables
we saw how to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates we found out that delhi
greater mumbai and bangalore but the top
cities with highest number of female
graduates
next
we saw how to use slicer in a pivot
table so we sliced our table based on
rajasthan karnataka state and saw the
total population for all the cities in
rajasthan and karnataka
in the next sheet
we
explored another feature that was to
find the percentage contribution of male
and female literature from each state
then
here we saw how to find out
the bottom three cities for each state
having lowest female graduates and one
thing marked that some of the states did
not have three cities for example
andaman had only one city that was sport
player
but the others we found out the bottom
three cities
that had the lowest female graduates
finally we looked at how to create a
calculated field in a pivot table
so we saw
how to create a
calculated field called sales
and then we explored how to create
different charts and graphs so this was
an area chart that we saw
there's a column chart we also saw or
looked at a bar chart that was a
horizontal bar chart
similarly we saw how to create a pie
chart as well
in this video we'll be creating two
dashboards using a sample sales data set
so if you want to get the data and the
dashboard file that we'll be creating in
this demo then please put your email ids
in the comments section of the video our
team will share the files via email
now let's begin by understanding what is
a dashboard in excel a dashboard is a
visual interface that provides an
overview of key measures relevant to a
particular objective with the help of
charts and graphs
dashboard reports allow managers to get
a high level overview of the business
and help them make quick decisions
there are different types of dashboards
such as strategic dashboards analytical
dashboards and operational dashboards
an advantage of dashboards is the quick
detection of outliers and correlations
with comprehensive data visualization it
is time saving as compared to running
multiple reports
with this understanding
let's jump into our demo
for creating our dashboards we'll be
using a sample sales data set
let me show you the data set first
so here is the sales data set that we'll
be using for our demo
so this data set was actually generated
using a simulator and is completely
random it was not validated though we
have applied certain transformations to
the data using power query features
so this data as you can see has
1000 rows so using the simulator we had
generated thousand rows of data
similarly
if i go on top you can see
this data set has
17 columns
now let me give you a brief about each
of the columns so first we have the
region column so we have middle eastern
north africa this north america asia
sub-saharan africa and others
similarly we have the country names from
which the item was ordered
the third column is the item type so we
have different items cosmetics
vegetables there's baby food cereal
fruits etc
then we have the representatives name or
you can see this as the customer name
who ordered the product
then we have a sales channel column so
there are basically two channels
whether the item was sold offline or
online
next we have the order priority column
now here c stands for critical
then we have h which is for high
priority orders then we have m for
medium priority orders and finally we
have l which is for low priority orders
you can see the order date column
then we have the order id the ship date
next we have units sold
which is basically the total number of
units sold for each item
then we have the unit price column this
is the price at which
each product was sold
then we have the unit cost column which
is basically the production cost for
each of the items
next we have the total revenue
the total revenue is actually the
product of units sold and unit price
then we have the total cost column now
the total cost column is actually the
product of units sold and the unit cost
similarly we have the total profit
column so total profit is the difference
between total revenue and the total cost
and finally
we have created two more columns that is
order year and then we have
order month now these two columns were
actually generated using the power query
features
so we use the order date column which is
this column and extracted order year and
order month
so first we are going to create a
revenue dashboard where we'll focus on
generating reports for revenue by order
year revenue by year and region revenue
by order priority and much more
we'll create separate pivot tables and
pivot charts and format them to make
them look more interesting and
presentable
we'll add slices and timeline to our
dashboards in order to filter it based
on specific fields
now let's create our first report to see
the total revenue generated each year
so we need to create a pivot table for
this
i'll click on a cell in my data set
and then i'll go to the insert tab
here we have the option to select the
pivot table
i click on this
you can see
my table range is selected
next i want to place my pivot table in a
new worksheet
and let's just click on ok
there you go
so we have a new sheet where i can place
my pivot table
so first
i need to find the total revenue
generated by each year
so what i'll do is
i'll drag my order year column
under rows
and then
i'll select the total revenue column
under values
you can see i have my pivot chart ready
now if you want you can sort this
so from the data you can see we have
order year from 2010
to 2017.
now
based on this data let's create our
pivot chart so i'll click on any cell
go to insert and here you have the
option to select recommended charts i
click on this
now actually i want a line chart so i'll
click on
line here and select ok
there you go so we have successfully
created our first pivot chart
now
let me show you how you can format this
chart to make it more readable
so first let me delete
these so i'll right click and select
hide all field buttons on the chart so
this will delete the
buttons present on the chart
now
let me go ahead and
edit the chart title
so the title i want is total revenue
i'll type it down
by year
all right
next
let's do a few more transformations
so if i click on this plus sign
which is actually for chart elements we
have some options like to add access
access titles chart title data labels
this grid lines legend and others
okay
so
let's remove the legend now
you can see the total legend is gone
now let me
add access titles so we'll label our x
axis and y axis
so here under x axis
i can
write it as
year
similarly on the y-axis i'll put
revenue
okay now you can move
a bit
all right
now
let me select this chart style option
and go to colors first
here
i'll select
yellow color
okay
and then let me go back to style
let's select a new style from this list
i want
this style
okay
now
you can also add
data
labels so i'll just click on data labels
you can see we have
the revenue for each of the years now
this is not readable at all
so we'll format this a bit
if i click on this arrow
here i have more options
if i scroll down you can see we have
something called as number here
i'll expand this
and under category
i'll select custom
now here we'll give a format code
which is a bit different
so this is actually a kind of a formula
so i'll write if
my revenue value is greater than
let's say
9 lakhs
99 000
let me make sure there are 6
9's here so 1 two three four five and
six okay we are good to go
i'll close the bracket
i'll give a hash
give to commas
so if the revenue is greater than
9 lakhs 99 000
i'll put it in the format of millions so
within double quotes i'll write m
i'll give a semicolon
followed by
another hash
and if the value is less than
the desired number
it should be
0 million
let me click on add
all right you can see how nicely we have
formatted our data
and you see here we have
added the new format which is in
millions
all right now if you want you can go
ahead and
adjust the
boxes let me move this a bit up
i'll delete this
now if you notice this line chart you
can make a few conclusions
for example if you see here in 2010
the total revenue generated was nearly
175 million
now this came down to 150 million in
2011
then the revenue constantly grew from
2011 till 2014
it reached 195 million
and after
2014 it again came down to
180 million
and the revenue dropped significantly
between 2016 and 2017
in 2017 the revenue was just 96 million
now before moving ahead to my next chart
let me just rename this sheet
so i'll write it as
revenue
by year
all right
now
let's analyze the revenue generated each
year in different regions so for this
we'll create another pivot table
let me close this
i'll click on any cell
go to insert
and select pivot table
i just click ok so that my pivot table
is placed on a new sheet
all right
now this time we want the revenue by
each year and region so first of all
let's drag
region to
columns
then
let's drag the order year column under
rows
and then
i'll select total revenue on to values
so here you can see we have the pivot
table ready
so for 2010 you can see in asia
this was the revenue generated
similarly
if you see for 2013 this was the total
revenue generated in europe
and
we have for other years as well
now let's
create a line chart based on this pivot
table so i'll select any cell in the
pivot table i'll go to insert
and i'll click on recommended charts
from this list i'll select my line chart
and click on ok
there you go
so we have our next
pivot chart ready
so
on the right you see the different
regions that are present in different
colors let me just expand it so that you
can see all the regions we have
so in total we have
seven regions
and each of the regions have been
represented in different colors
so if you notice this graph
for the
sub-saharan african region
in 2012
sub-saharan africa made the
highest amount of sales
now from the sample data you can also
tell
that the revenue for north america has
been significantly low compared to other
regions
similarly if you see
for
europe
this was the revenue trend between 2010
and 2017.
so if you see here in 2011 the sales
were at this level then it significantly
dropped in 2012
then in 2013
there was a huge spike and then and
again
came down in 2015 and so on so you can
make your own conclusions by looking at
these
line charts now let's
format this chart so first of all let's
delete the
field buttons present on the chart
and we'll also
delete the legend
all right now
let me just reduce the size of the chart
next
we'll
add a chart title
so
we'll
give the title as
revenue
by
year-end
region
okay
you can also format the
y-axis in terms of millions
so i'll right click on this axis
and i'll select format axis
i'll scroll down and here we have
the number drop down
let me scroll again
under category i'll select custom
and
we'll use this format that we created
for our previous chart there you go you
can see
our access labels have been changed in
terms of millions now
so let's close this and let me save it
now you can
reduce the font size or increase the
font size let me just show you suppose
you want to increase the font size of
the chart title so you just select it
and from here you can either reduce or
you can increase you can see now it's 12
if you want you can make it 16.
similarly you can also edit the
access labels also
by selecting the chart title you can
also move it to left or right or you can
place it in the center as well for the
time being let me just keep it to the
left
all right
now
we'll see the revenue and total cost by
each region
and will create a combo chart for this
so let me show you how to do it
i'll go to my data sheet
i have my cell selected
go to insert and click on pivot table
let me just click on ok
all right
so for this
i'll select
my region onto rows
and then
i'll have
two columns under values the first one
is
going to be total revenue
and the next column will be the total
cost column
all right so here we have the pivot
table ready now based on this pivot
table
let's create our pivot chart so i'll go
to recommended charts and if you see
below
at the bottom we have combo chart so
this is the
preview of the combo chart all right now
let me just click on ok
there you go so we have a nice combo
chart ready here
now the way to look at it is
the bars represent the total revenue
which is this column
now
the line represents
the total cost
so
let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so first of all let's delete the
field buttons all right and let's also
remove the legend from here
next
we'll add
data labels so i'll click on data labels
here
okay so these are the
data labels for
the bars or
the revenue column
now
let's format the data labels in terms of
millions so i'll click on this arrow go
to more options
if i scroll down
i have number
from here i'll select custom and
i'll choose my type that is
in millions
all right so you can see we have
formatted our
data
next thing we'll add
a chart title
so here i'll write as
revenue
by
region
it's actually
revenue and total cost
by region
before moving ahead let me
rename the sheets as well i'll write
revenue and
total cost
similarly
sheet 3 also am going to rename it as
revenue
by
year
and region
so this
makes your sheet more readable
all right
now moving ahead
next
we are interested to get the revenue
generated by order priority
and for this we are going to create a
pie chart so let's go to the data sheet
and create our pivot table first
i click on ok
now
i'll select order priority under rows
and under values i'll select total
revenue
so this is a
very simple pivot table so you have your
order priority so c is for critical h is
for high l is for low and m is for
medium
now based on this let's create a pie
chart so i'll go to recommended charts
and here you have
pie chart
i want to select
this 3d type of pie chart
and i'll click on ok
all right so we have our pie chart ready
let me just resize it
and from here i'll remove the fill
buttons
and i also don't need the legend so i'll
delete this as well
all right
now let's give a chart title so this is
going to be
revenue by
order
priority
now let's add
our data labels
i'll check this option
okay
now let's again format this in terms of
millions
so here
i'll click on the last option i'll go to
numbers
under category i'll select custom
and
my type is going to be in terms of
millions there you go
let me close this
i will just
move this
to the center
all right
now if you want you can change the color
of the text as well
so let's
have it in white color and see how it
looks okay so this looks pretty decent
cool
now
moving to our next report
so this time
we are going to find the total revenue
by countries so we have multiple
countries present in our data set we
want to visualize the revenue generated
in each country
so for this we are going to create a
horizontal bar chart so let me show you
how to do it but before moving ahead let
me just rename this sheet so i'll write
revenue
by
i'll just put op which stands for order
priority
all right
now let's create our horizontal bar
chart i'll go to insert
click on pivot table
and select ok
so i want my revenue based on different
countries so i'll select country
and put it under rows
and then
i'll choose total revenue and place it
under values
so here you have the different country
names we have afghanistan this albania
let me scroll down you have bangladesh
there are
a number of countries you have czech
republic there's estonia france gabon
similarly if you scroll down
we have india there's jamaica italy
and all the way to the bottom if we go
we have new zealand this netherlands
philippines portugal
we also have
singapore
lots and lots of countries
we have the uae united states of america
zimbabwe and others
all right let me go up
so based on this pivot table let's
create our pivot chart
so i'll go to insert and select
recommended charts
from here
i'm going to select the column chart you
can see the preview here and let me
click on ok
alright
so here you can see
the different country names at the
bottom and
the revenue for each of the countries
let's go ahead and edit this chart
so first of all i'll delete
the field buttons okay
and let me also remove the
legend here i'll write
revenue
by
countries
this is going to be my
chart title
okay
let's format this chart a little more
so i'll click on this option
and we'll select a new style let's say
i'll select
style 6
okay
and
let me now go under colors and we'll
select the color of the bars
so let's choose this color okay
so you have
a horizontal column chart ready
and at the bottom you can see the
different country names and we have the
revenue
cool
now
let me go ahead and
rename this sheet so i'll write
revenue
by countries
and hit enter
okay
and finally
we create another report which is going
to be part of our revenue dashboard
and this is
revenue by items so we'll visualize
our revenue for different items present
in the table
so if you see this we have
cosmetics vegetables cereal fruits this
cloth snacks households and other
products as well
so let's check the revenue for each of
these items
so we'll continue the same drill i'll
create my pivot table on a new worksheet
and this time i am going to drag
item type under rows
and
will have the total revenue under values
so here on the left of the table you can
see we have the different
item names and then we have the
total revenue
so let me just
short this
total revenue
from largest to smallest so
you can see here office supplies made
the highest amount of revenue
followed by household then cosmetics
and fruits
made the lowest amount of revenue
i'll click on this go to insert and
select recommended charts
this time i am going to create a bar
chart so this is how my bar chart is
going to look like
i'll select ok
all right
now let's format this chart a bit
i'll delete the field buttons
and i'll delete the legend as well
and
let's edit the chart title so this is
going to be
revenue
by
items
cool
we also want to
change the
color of the bars so i have selected all
the bars i'll go to my home tab
and here let's say i want to select
green color
all right
i've edited my chart a bit now
let's
make it
14
and i'll remove the
bold
okay
here if you want you can change the font
also let's keep it in blue color all
right
finally
let's rename this sheet so i'll write
revenue by
items
cool
finally
now it's time for us to merge
all the charts that we have created
to our dashboard
so let me show you how you can create
the dashboard i'll create a new sheet
and first thing i'm going to do is
i'll click on the view tab and
uncheck gridlines so this will remove
the gridlines present in the worksheet
next
i'm going to insert an image
so we'll have a background image
on our dashboard
so the way to do is i'll go to the
insert tab and under illustrations
i have the option to select pictures or
insert pictures so i'm going to insert
picture
present on the device that is my
computer
i'll go to desktop and here i have a
folder called excel dashboard files
and i'll select this dashboard
background and hit insert
so this is going to insert an image
now
let me just
drag this image so it covers a fair
enough portion
so i'll hit shift and i'll drag it
all right
so you can see i have successfully
added a background image if you want you
can still
expand this background image
a bit to the right cool
now the next thing
is going to be
the title of the dashboard so i'll click
on insert and here
i have the option to select
a text box
so
i'll click on a text box and
i'm going to place a text box in the
middle
and i'm going to name this text box as
excel
revenue dashboard
on
sales
i'll
centralize it
let's do some more formatting so i'll
select this text box
on the top you can see
shape format
here
i'm going to expand this
shape fill
and i'll select no fill
so
my text box is transparent now
and i'll also remove the outline all
right
now let me just double click on the
title of my dashboard and i'm going to
select
a font you can select whichever font you
want
let me stick to
britannica bold
and i'll increase the size to let's say
30
all right
i'll just
drag the
text box
i'll make the text as white instead of
black
all right so we have our
title of the dashboard ready
now if you want you can also insert some
icons to this dashboard so i'll go to
insert and i'll click on illustrations
again
and select
pictures
i'm going to add
this to pictures which is of a store and
a cart
to make it look
visually appealing so i'll
place the icons
here and similarly let me just copy it
and i'll place the
cart and the store
to the right as well
all right
next the idea is to
bring in all the charts that we have
created and place it on the dashboard
so let me copy
each of the charts and
place it
on the dashboard
so i'll
hit
ctrl v to paste it
and we'll resize this as well
all right
similarly let me bring in all the other
charts as well
all right so now you can see i have
added
all my charts and graphs to this
dashboard
so you can see here we have
our line charts our
column charts the combo charts this pie
chart
and others
now let me go ahead and
format these
charts a little more so you can see this
looks a bit cluttered
so let's adjust the
labels let me bring this down
similarly i'll bring
190 million
a little below
all right
this looks fine now
one more thing we are going to do is
we'll remove the
white background from each of the charts
and make it transparent so let me show
you how to do it so i'll select this
chart
then i'll right click
and go to
format chart area
here on the right you see we have an
option called no fill so if i select no
fill you can see the white background
is gone now
similarly let me also remove the grid
lines so i'll select the gridlines and
hit delete so you have also removed the
grid lines from here
now
let's also remove the white outline that
we have so i'll select this chart
go to format
and here
i'll go to shape outline and i'll select
no outline
you see this
so we have our total revenue by year
which is a line chart
and this is completely transparent now
now what i'm going to do is
i'll place this chart over a box so i'll
go to insert and in insert we have the
option to create a shape
so i'll
click on illustrations and here
i'll choose a shape
and let me select a rectangle
so i'll just
create a rectangle here
all right and now
what i'll do is
i'll select this and bring this to front
i'll right click
and choose
bring to front
and i'll place this
shape
below it
all right now the next thing is to edit
the shape so first i'll change the color
of this box so let me select this blue
color
and
and let me increase the transparency so
i'll
right click and go to format shape here
i'll increase the transparency let's
keep it to
25 percent
or let's say
20 percent
all right
next thing
we'll just convert all the
font to white color
including the access labels
the chart title
will also
convert all the
access labels to white color so it looks
better
now we'll just
adjust our
chart over here
next thing let's just
remove the outline so i'll go to shape
outline and i'll select no outline
you see
we have now formatted our chart
let's just
pull this a little up
all right
now we'll add
this blue background to all the other
charts so we'll first add the background
make it transparent and then we'll
convert the font text to white color to
make it more
readable and visible so
for the time being i'll just pause the
video and come back again
all right so now you can see on your
screens
we have nicely formatted our dashboard
so
i've added a few logos for
each of the
charts you can see the logos here so for
revenue by countries we have a globe
then if you see here this is kind of a
map or a location
similarly we have all formatted the
color of the bars
then we have also formatted the
labels in terms of millions
if you look on the y-axis even the
revenue for year in region are all
formatted in terms of millions
if you want this you can also format the
total year by revenue in terms of
millions
so the way to do is you can select this
graph
right click and go to format access
here if i scroll down
you have numbers
and
under category i'll select custom
then i'll select my type as
this format
which is in millions
and
you see here we have successfully
formatted our
y-axis labels
all right
so the next thing
is to add slicers and timelines to a
dashboard now slicers are used to format
your data based on a particular column
suppose if you want to see revenue by
certain items you can add item as a
slicer and you can view the entire
dashboard similarly
for timelines you can add
date columns so if you want to see what
was the amount of sales or revenue
generated on a particular year or a
particular month you can do that using a
timeline
so
i'll select one of the charts
and then
either you can go to the insert tab and
here you can see under filters we have
slices and timeline or
if you go to the
pivot chart analyze tab
here also you have
insert slicer and timeline option
so i'll select insert slicer here first
now it's giving me the list of
fields present in the
data set
so i'll select
country
region
and let's say
we want to
know by
item type and sales channel so these are
going to be my four
slicers i'll click on ok
you can see it here we have our
four slicers here and these are the list
of values on the region we have asia
this europe north america and others
similarly we have the different country
names for country slicers
and then for item type also we have all
the items that were present in our data
set
now
moving ahead we need to connect
all the slices to a dashboard
so what i'll do is
i'll right click
on this option and i'll go to report
connections
okay so under report connections you
have
all the pivot tables that we created
you currently see only one of the pivot
table is selected so we need to
select all the pivot tables so let me
check
all the pivot tables present in this
workbook and click on ok
alright now that we have connected
one of our slicers we'll now connect the
other
remaining slicers
so i'll right click on this go to report
connections
and i'll check
all the pivot tables present in this
worksheet
click on ok
similarly let's do it for
the country slicer
i'll go to report connections and let me
select
all the pivot tables
and finally we have
the item type so i'll right click
go to report connections and then i'll
select
all my pivot tables
and let's hit ok
all right now let me just
organize this a bit so i'll
place my pivot tables
to the right
i'll just reduce the size
let me scroll down
i'll add
my region slicer here
similarly
i'll add my final slicer that is sales
channel
now in our next dashboard which is going
to be
the profit dashboard i'll show you how
to add a timeline
all right
now i have arranged all my slicers
so let's say you want to find the
revenue that was generated for
an item type let's say
beverages so you can just select
beverages here
and
all your charts
so the respective revenues so you have
the total revenue by year for
beverages only
similarly here you can see the revenue
by year in region only for
beverages item type
if i scroll down
now this chart represents the
revenue that was generated in each of
the countries only for item type
beverages
let me just uncheck it
all right
let's say you want to see
the revenue generated for a country like
india so i have selected india here
and now you can see
my graph has changed only for
country india
you can see here it is showing only for
india now
now similarly you can also filter your
revenues based on the different regions
let's say you want to
know the revenue generated
based on sales channel so we have two
sales channel that is offline and online
suppose you want to know the revenue
generated offline so i'll just
select
offline you can see
the values have changed so these were
the revenues generated for each of the
items only for offline
if you
see here
now these were all the
offline sales for the different regions
so
this is
our entire
excel revenue dashboard on sales
we created multiple charts and graphs
then we applied
different formatting we added
different icons then we formatted the
labels also
next we added
slicers
and
finally we saw how we could filter our
data based on these slicers
likewise now we are going to create a
profit dashboard based on the same data
so before moving ahead let me rename
this
sheet as
revenue dashboard i'll write rev
dashboard
okay
now
we'll move to our data sheet and
start creating our pivot tables and vivo
charts for the profit dashboard
all right so let me go ahead and create
my first pivot table so
i'll create
a new worksheet
this time i'm going to create a line
chart
to visualize the profit for each year
so i'll drag my
total profit column
to values
and
my order year to rows
so here you can see we have our
pivot table ready
now you can sort this data to
get an idea
as to which
year had the highest profit and which
year had the lowest profit so from this
pivot table you can see since i have
sorted this data in
descending order so 2014
had the maximum amount of profit and
2017 had the least amount of profit
i'll just do control z to undo it all
right now based on this pivot table let
me go ahead and create my po chart so
i'll go to recommended charts and click
on a line chart so this is the preview
of the chart
i'll click on ok
let me close this
similarly
we are going to
edit this chart now so first i'll hide
all the field buttons present on the
chart
and i'll
rename the chart title as
total
profit
by ear
next i'm going to remove the legend so
i'll delete this
let's do some more formatting
so
i'll go to style
and
this time
i'm going to select
my style type okay
and if you want you can
choose the colors as well for the timing
let's have this yellow color
next let me add the
data labels
so again if you see here this is not
formatted properly
so let's go ahead and format the
labels
so i'll click on number
and i'll select custom here
and the type i'm going to select is in
millions
and i'll click on
close
so here you can see we have our
line chart ready which shows total
profit by year
let's
rename this sheet as
profit
by
all right
now let's move back to our data sheet
again
next
we are going to
show the total profit by countries for
this i am going to create a map so let
me first create my pivot table
so i'll go to insert and i'll click on
pivot table
let me click on ok
since i want
the country names so i'll select country
under rows and then i have
my total profit under values
the next thing i'm going to do is i'll
just rename the row labels as
countries
and then i'm going to delete the
grand total which you can see at the
bottom so here we have the grand total
let me just delete the grand total so
i'm going to select this pivot table
go to the design tab
here we have subtotals and grand totals
i'll
switch off the grand total let me just
verify it again i'll scroll down you see
the grand total has gone now
all right
now
we want to create a
map out of this the way to do is
i'm going to
select my data
copy it
i'll go on top
and i'll paste it here
using this data i can create my field
map now so i'll go to insert
here we have the option to create a
field map
there you go
you can see we have our map ready
i can expand this
as you can see
our map has a color scale which comes
from light gray color to dark blue color
so the countries that are in gray or you
can say light blue
have the lowest amount of profit
while the regions or the countries that
have been shaded in
dark color
a dark blue color have highest amount of
profit
i will go ahead and delete this
scale
okay next
we need to connect this
map to the original data source so what
i'll do is
i'll right click on this map and i'll go
to select data
here instead of the previous range i'll
give my
new range now so
my new range
will be my original pivot table that i
had created
i'll go on top and click on ok
so we have our
map ready now now if you want you can
change the
color of the shade so i'll just go to
colors
and let's say we'll keep green color
so the countries that are shaded in dark
green have the highest amount of profit
while those which are highlighted in
light green color are
are the countries that made
least amount of profit
okay
now moving on
next we want to create
a pivot table
that will show us the profit by
year and sales channel
so for this we are going to create
another line chart
so i'll go to insert and click on pivot
table so i'll select
new worksheet
here
since i want to know the profit by year
first of all i'll drag my order year
column to rows
and then
i'll choose my total profit column under
values
next i'm going to select my sales
channel under columns
there you go so we have our pivot table
here
now based on this pivot table let me
create my pivot chart so i'll go to
recommended charts
and i'm going to create a line chart
i close this
you see here
based on this
chart you can tell
the profit generated with
online
sales were actually
lower than that of offline so here the
blue line represents offline profit and
the orange line represents online profit
if you mark clearly in year 2012 the
online profit was actually higher than
the offline profit
so
let me go ahead and
edit this chart a bit so we'll delete
the field buttons i'll also delete the
legend for now
let me go ahead and
add
a chart title so i'll write
profit
by
year and
sales
channel
okay
so this is my
second report
before moving ahead let me
just rename this sheet so i'll write
profit
by
countries
similarly
let me
rename this sheet as
profit
by
year and let's say sc for sales channel
okay
moving ahead
now i want to
create a pie chart
based on a pivot table that will show
the profit by sales channel only so this
is going to be a simple pie chart so
i'll first
go to insert click on pivot table and
click on ok
so i'll drag my sales channel under rows
and then will have the total profit
column under values
so this is my simple pivot table now
let's create our pivot chart which is
going to be a pie chart
let me explore
the other types of pie charts we have
okay so i'm going to select a donut
chart here i click on ok
let's
edit this chart i'll remove the field
buttons
let me now remove the legend as well
i'll just resize it
and this is going to be
profit
by
sales channel
okay
let's also add
data labels
and here again
i am going to
format this label
i'll select the category as custom
and my type
will be in millions okay
let me just
move this
to the left
and this to the right
okay
let's also delete the lines cool
now let me just rename this sheet so
i'll write profit
by
let's say c which stands for sales
channel
cool
finally
i'm going to create a report that will
show the revenue and profit by items
so i'll go ahead and create my
pivot table first
this time i'll choose my
total profit under values
and will also have
the revenue column
so i'll put my revenue at the top
then
i'm going to select
item type under rows
so here is my pivot table
based on this pivot table
let me now
create a combo chart
so you can see the preview of the chart
the blue bars represent the total
revenue and the orange line represents
the total profit
i'll click on ok
let me close this
first
let's remove the field buttons
let's also remove
the legend here
then we'll add a chart title i'll name
it as
revenue
and
profit
by
items
okay
if you want you can also go ahead and
change the color of the bars
so let me just select
one of these colors okay
all right
so we have our five reports ready that
we are going to use
for our profit dashboard
next let's create a new sheet
and we'll get started with building a
dashboard so i'll click on a new sheet
let me just
rename this as
profit dashboard
all right
we'll continue with the previous drill
so first of all let's go to
the view tab and remove the grid lines
now
we'll
insert a background image
like we did for our revenue dashboard so
i'll go to insert under illustrations
i'll click on
pictures and select this device
i'm going to have the same background
i'll click on insert
all right so you can see we have a
picture of a company or you can say an
organization
let's just
drag this
a bit to the right
we'll adjust the size also all right
now let's copy the title of my profit
dashboard so here you can see i have
brought my revenue dashboard
and i'll copy the title and the logos
that we used
for the revenue dashboard
i'll paste it on my new dashboard
let's just align it
in the center
all right the next step
let me now go ahead and edit the title
so this is actually going to be
excel
profit dashboard instead of revenue
now
we'll copy each of the charts that we
just created for example
the revenue and profit by items then we
had
profit by sales channel
all this we are going to copy one by one
and put it on the profit dashboard
so let me just copy a few now
we'll paste it here
and later on we can make the adjustment
copy this as well
similarly i'll bring the other three
charts on to my sales dashboard
okay so here on my
profit dashboard i have added all the
charts
and have
aligned and reshaped it so that it looks
good
i have also
made some formatting for example have
reduced the size of the
chart title
now let me go ahead and
show you a few more formatting that we
also did for the revenue dashboard first
let's remove the white background from
all the charts so i'll select
the first chart i'll right click and
i'll
click on
format chart area
here under fill i will select no fill
next i am going to remove the grid lines
so i'll just delete it
let me close this
now we also have a
outline so i'll go to design
actually format and i'll remove the
outline
next i'm going to add
a blue box at the back like how we did
for the revenue dashboard so let me
select a blue box from here and i'm
going to paste it here okay
let me just select
the chart and i'll bring this to front
and i'll move this
to the back
next i'm going to change the font color
all to white
so that it's clearly visible and it's
more readable
i'll do it for the x-axis as well okay
so here
i have my first
chart ready
the same i'm going to do for the rest of
the charts
okay so now you can see here
i have formatted all my charts i've also
added a blue background
you see here i have also formatted the
y labels in terms of millions which is
actually the profit
similarly here i have added the data
labels this is for revenue
some of the charts also have the data
legends so here you can see the blue
color represents offline
and the red represents online similarly
here
you have the legends
i've also formatted the
map as well
okay
now the next thing
is to make this dashboard more
interactive so we'll add our
slicers as well as timeline
first let me show you how to add a
timeline
so i'll
select one of the charts
and i'll go to insert
under insert i have the option to create
a timeline
so i'll just
click on timelines
so timeline is actually based on date
columns so since in our data set we only
have two date columns one is order date
and one is ship date so excel has only
shown us two columns so i'm going to
create my timeline based on order date
so i'll select my order date column and
i'll click on ok
you can see here this is called a
timeline i can expand this
now this timeline is based on months now
if i
scroll this timeline you can see here i
have my
order year 2010 and i have all the 12
months similarly we have for 2011 then
we have for 2012
all the way till
2017. now you can filter this in terms
of years quarters months or days let me
just select year now
so i have
years from 2010 till 2017.
let me just squeeze this
and i'll place it somewhere here
on the right
now let me go ahead and create a few
slicers for my profit dashboard so i
have selected one of the charts
under insert i'll click on slicer
you can see it gives me the list of
columns from which
i want to create slicers
so i'll create a region
let me also select
country
let's say i
want the representative's name or the
customer's name
and i'll click on ok
so here i have created three slicers
let me
first
resize it and i'll place it
on the right
similarly i'll place the
country column also
then we have
the region slicer
i'll
resize this and i'll bring it here
okay
the next thing we need to do is
i have to
connect all the slicers and the timeline
to
the pivot tables
for the profit dashboard so i'm going to
click on
the multiple select option and go to
report connections here
i'm going to select
all the pivot tables that are related to
profit
so here i have selected four and i need
one more which is
pivot table number 10 i click on ok
similarly let's create
or connect my region filter to all the
pivot tables so i right click
go to report connections
here i'll
choose all my pivot tables which are
based on profit
i'll click on ok
let's do it for the country slicer as
well
click on ok
and similarly i'll connect my timeline
as well i'll go to report connections
and i'll select
all the pivot tables related to profit
then i'll click on ok
let me now go ahead and create another
slicer based on sales channel so i am
selecting one of the pivot charts
i'll go to insert click on slicer
and i'll select
sales channel and hit ok
so i have my sales channel
slicer now let me connect it to all the
respective pivot tables
that are based on profit
click on ok
now
let me just bring it here
all right
the next thing i want to show is
how are we going to use the timeline
first
so you see we have all the
years here from 2010 till 2017
now suppose
you want to know the profit that was
generated in the year 2012 so i'll just
click on
this range and now you can see our
charts only so information for 2012. so
this dot represents there was 51 million
profit in the year 2012. similarly you
can see here
the profit by sales channel for 2012
from the map you can see the different
countries and the
profit
each of these countries made in 2012.
if i scroll down you can see
the revenue and profit by items
now
if i select
another year let's say 2013 i can just
drag this to the right and
now you can see
our profit by year and sales channel for
offline and online you can see the map
or the line chart for total profit by
year so in 2012 it was 51 million and
then it
went up to 54 million in 2013.
similarly
our map has also changed now this is a
sort of an information that we have you
can click on this and
check the information that
excel has prompted
all right so this is how you can use a
timeline
now as i said
we checked by
years you can also see it for months and
quarters as well
let me just
uncheck it
i'll
send it back to the place where it was
and i'll reduce the size
okay
now suppose
you want to check the profit made by
different representatives you can select
them one by one
let's say adam churchill
this is the
profit generated by
adam churchill
similarly
you can select multiple persons as well
now suppose you want to see the profit
by different countries so you can use
the country slicer
let me just bring this to the middle
and
let's expand our chart a bit
okay so here you have the
profit by different countries chart i'll
just
bring this to the front so that you can
see it clearly
okay
now here suppose you want to see the
profit generated
in let's say united kingdom you can
select united kingdom so this is the map
of united kingdom and it
tells you the total profit that was
generated in united kingdom
and
below you can see
the revenue and profit
for all the items that was sold in
united kingdom so you had beverages
clothes household office supplies so you
can see clearly
office supplies item made the highest
amount of profit in
united kingdom
now you can also select
multiple countries let's say
i want to know for france as well
so my
map will change accordingly so now i
have
united kingdom and france selected and
the other charts present
in my dashboard change accordingly
now i have my
country selected as india you can see
the map of india here
and these were the respective profit
values
now one thing to note here is this is
actually
not millions that should be in k that is
thousands so please mark this as
1000 and not in millions
even for this this is actually k and
naught million
all right
so we have successfully
created our second dashboard that is
on
profit
let me just resize this a bit and we'll
place it
where it was earlier
cool
so we saw
how to create different pivot tables in
pivot charts and then we formatted our
pivot charts based on our requirement we
saw how to edit the colors now let me
show you one more thing
you can also change the
look and feel of the dashboard by going
to the page layout tab under page layout
you have themes so here you can select
different themes currently we are
with the office theme now let me just
select
another theme let's say facet
you see
the colors have changed and it looks
really beautiful
similarly let me try out
another
theme let's say organic you see
our chart has changed let me just delete
this okay so now once you change the
theme the
text also change a bit you can see
the slicers are in a different font
let me explore one more theme let's say
this time i am going to choose depth
and
this is more
of a
green type of color
you can play around and select
whatever theme suits the best
all right
now let me just move back to my revenue
dashboard and see how it looks
there you go
so since we changed our theme even our
revenue dashboard is also impacted
so
this is how it looks now
you can always go ahead and
play with different themes colors fonts
and effects all right
so in this demo we saw
how to create a revenue dashboard so we
created line charts this combo chart pie
chart
horizontal and vertical
bar charts and then we learnt how to add
slicers and
connected to different pivot tables
and we filtered our data to see
revenue as well as profit by items by
countries by different regions
sales channel
we learnt how to create
a map
and lots more
let's quickly see
some more examples of doing data
analysis using excel and for that we can
use
some inbuilt add-ins which can be added
to our excel sheet so for example if you
would want to do a descriptive
analytics or descriptive analysis on
your data say for example getting your
descriptive statistics such as your mean
median mode and so on so we can do that
and we can use excel for it so for
example you can
if you are given some data say i have
temperature price of ice cream units
sold and i would want to have
descriptive statistics on this what i
can do is i can click on file
and here in file you can click on
options and within options click on
add-ins
now within add-ins you have excel
add-ins which is selected here so click
on say go for example and that shows
what add-ins are available and you can
choose which ones are you interested in
so for example i have chosen analysis
tool pack and solver add-in and click on
ok now that basically should add more
options to your excel so if you click on
data
so here you see data analysis and solver
and this is what we would want to use to
get our descriptive statistics for these
three columns so for example let's say
temperature
or you can even give the names later
once you get your descriptive statistics
so for example let's go for data
analysis
and here it says what are you interested
in there is a two factor with
replication you have correlation
covariance descriptive statistics you
have histogram so let's click on
descriptive statistics click on ok
now this one basically asks your input
range so while your cursor is blinking
here
also it is said
grouped by so let's give it a range so
for example i will say say temperature
now if i do this and i have selected the
heading just look at that and now you
need an output range so let's just
select this
and then you can have your cursor
blinking here
let's
select save fields here
and this is where i would want the
output now it also said what options do
you want so it has output range we can
then select summary statistics
confidence level so i will say summary
statistics is what i'm interested in say
okay and this says input input range
contains non-numeric data now why is
that because we chose temperature the
heading also so click on ok and here we
will alter the range
so this one
is our range should be
only
the values numeric values on which we
would want the descriptive statistics we
have output range already selected we
have summary statistics and now you can
click on ok
and that basically gives your
descriptive statistics for temperature
so here i could basically
given a value for this so i can say
temperature
and that's my descriptive statistics for
temperature
might be i can just do some formatting
and
that's it so that gives me descriptive
statistics for the values here
now similarly we can do it for price of
ice cream
so what we need is we need to basically
go for data
data analysis
descriptive statistics say okay
now you need to give a range so here i
will
change my range to these values output
range is already selected
now we are interested in summary
statistics click on ok and this says
output range will overwrite existing
data press ok to overwrite data in range
i will say cancel now that's not what we
want to do we need to give a new range
so let's select our new range which is
here
and now click on ok so now we get the
values which is for your price of ice
cream so again we can basically
select this and say price of ice cream
and we got our descriptive statistics
for price of ice cream and like we did
earlier i can select this
i can basically do a merge and center
and that gives me descriptive statistics
for price of ice cream so we could also
basically change this
now i can go into data and i can go into
data analysis
descriptive statistics so we know that
we had selected this b2 to b8
and this one which is h6 to h19 we would
want to shift it
might be two columns up so might be i
can just say h5
and i can manually change it to at 17
and let's say okay
and
we will basically get this
and i can get rid of this
so i can have it in the same range so
similarly so this one will have to be
renamed and i can basically say price of
ice cream
and that's basically my descriptive
statistics for
my price of ice cream
and similarly we can do it for the third
column which is units sold
so we would want to have this now let's
see we can click on data we can click on
data analysis descriptive statistics so
we need to give the range correctly so
this time our range changes to units
sold
now we can also say labels in first row
okay if
we were selecting the heading so let's
do it in this way so in my range
in my range
let me empty this
i can basically select this which we
know
has non-numeric data in the first row
say for example i'll say labels in first
row i'm interested in summary statistics
and this range will now have to be
changed from h
to basically something like
j
so let's say j
and let's select these values so that
should take care of things and now you
see you have your units sold you did not
have to manually rename it
and you have basically got the
descriptive statistics so this is how
you can simply perform analysis
using data analysis here
you can basically get your descriptive
statistics for your columns and then you
can do whatever needed formatting you
need
to basically make your data look
in a
good way
now let's look at one more example of
data analysis
where we may want to look at the
frequency of values or frequency of
values occurring in a range of values so
for example if you have been given
temperatures
you have been given some pins where you
would want to identify how many values
fall into the range of 0 to 20
20 to 30 30 to 40 40 to 50 and the
easiest way to do that would be creating
histogram now histogram is usually used
for data analysis where you would want
to look at different variables or say
features for example temperature is one
such feature might be there might be one
more variable or feature such as sale of
ice cream and you would want to see
if
the increase or decrease in temperature
affects the increase or decrease in
sale of ice cream might be a sale of ice
cream is a is a response based on
temperature so it depends so sometimes
you may want to find a relationship
between two variables
whether they are positively or
negatively related or you would want to
do different kind of analysis and in
certain cases we may want to
first do analysis on one single variable
look at the frequency of values might be
also look at the defects and for which
we can use something like pareto chart
so we can go for histogram and that
basically gives us the frequency of
values now how do we do that so we have
already added the
add-in which is data analysis earlier so
we can just use the same thing again
here we would want to create a histogram
so let's say okay now
i have already selected input range so
if you see here my input range is
temperature which is also with the
headings
and i have bin range which is basically
the range of values so for example i can
select this and that's my bin range i am
selecting
or the option labels because i'm using
the first
row which has the heading such as
temperature and pins now we need to give
an output range so for example let's say
i would want my data here
and that becomes my output range so you
can have a sorted histogram or basically
a pareto chart
so if that's what you are interested in
looking at the frequencies for your
different ranges and here i am also
selecting chart output because i would
want to have a visual histogram which
gives us the frequency and it's as
simple as this just click on ok and now
you get your bins so it basically tells
you frequency of values which is
basically 20 but that does not mean it
is only talking about the value is 20 it
is basically talking as a range of 0 to
20
so we have 0 to 20 that is 2 so we can
basically say there is 120 here with the
20 being the maximum value and then
there is one more 20 so that's your 0 to
20 then you have 20 to 30 which shows
three values so might be in that case i
can say 26
is one thing then i can say 30
that's the second one
and then basically i can look at 22
so
basically this one does not select 20 as
the lower range but it basically selects
30 as the higher range so i do see 20 to
30 there are three entries similarly we
can see values for 40 and 50 and since
we have selected pareto or sorted
histogram that shows in a descending
order what is the highest frequency of
values within a particular range
so that shows me highest frequency is
five and then you have three and three
and then two so this is how we can
create a histogram and we can perform
analysis on a single variable
now
as discussed earlier as i said sometimes
we may
be interested in finding out the
correlation between different variables
such as say here we have temperature
price of ice cream and units sold and we
may want to
find out the correlation between one
variable to another variable or we would
want to find out the relationship
between variables
are they linearly related are they
positively related negatively related
and so on and for that we can use the
correlation
of your data analysis add-in so for
example you want to find out correlation
of temperature and units sold and what
we can do is
we can find out that using a formula so
for example if i search for something
like
co
relation and let's search so there is a
function called correlation which we can
use and we can use this to calculate the
correlation of temperature and units
sold so for example let's select this
and that's the function so it says give
me an first array and a second array so
we are interested in finding out
correlation of temperature and units
sold so let's select
the range of values for temperature
and then i am interested in finding out
the correlation of temperature in units
sold so let's select this
and that basically gives me a range of
values it gives me the correlation value
which is 0.2859
say okay and that's your value
so similarly we can do it for
temperature and price ice cream so let's
go for
correlation
so that's the function we are interested
in you need to give a range of value so
here we are interested in temperature
and price of ice cream so let's select
temperature
and then the second array or list of
values is price of ice cream let's
select that
let's close our bracket and here we have
the correlation value of temperature and
the price of ice cream similarly you may
be interested in finding out temperature
and units sold like what we have done
earlier
so we can do the same thing based on
function so this is same as
correlation of temperature in units sold
so i can get rid of this one now how do
i do it using the data analysis add in
so for that what we need is we need to
go into data we need to click on data
analysis and here you have the option
called correlation let's select this now
that basically needs an input range so
we need the range now i might be
interested in finding out the
correlation between temperature and
price of ice cream and units sold so
i've selected all the columns here
we will say group by columns obviously
we need to select labels in first row
because that is basically taking care of
the first row is heading now output
range you can just give one simple cell
and that's where your data will start
from or you can give a new workbook so
click on ok
and that basically gives you
that basically gives your
correlation of your different variables
and what are the values and we can check
these values
based on the values what we have here so
we have basically
temperature
and price of ice cream
and that basically shows me
0.96149
you have temperature and units sold so
you have 0.2859
now you can also look at units sold and
say for example price of ice cream
you can look at these particular values
so if i would be interested in finding
out
what is the relationship between these
variables i can easily find using
correlation so i could be
basically writing in a formula here and
selecting what are the cells so here we
were selecting a2
and c
here we were selecting a and b now might
be i'm interested in price of ice cream
and units sold and if that's what i'm
interested in then i will give a range
of b2 to b8 c2 to c8 and similarly you
can get your analysis or correlation
values
so it's very simple in excel and you can
use either the data analysis tab
and
get your correlation or you can use
formulas and do that
now one more important part of data
analysis is doing your sampling now
sampling could be periodic sampling or
random sampling so sometimes you may
want to look at a variable and you may
want to get some values based on
periodic data that means
might be i'm interested in range of
values i'm interested in seeing a sample
of values for
a particular period which could be
basically
a range of values or you could just do a
random sampling so for example if i go
for periodic sampling so out of these
values which i see here might be i want
to see
say periodic sampling that is a
frequency of two values how many times
we have these values occurring here or i
would go for random sampling so
basically randomly i would want to pick
up
say three temperature values now how do
i do it so for example here i have seven
values now if i go
for periodic sampling
the sample
or periodic sample value which i need to
give has to be lesser than the total
input values
so for example we can do this let's go
in here
and let's go for data analysis so we can
go for sampling here click on ok and
that needs a range of values so we will
select a2 to a8 now i could have
selected all the values for this one
temperature and in that case i can give
labels which is going to take care of
the first
row
now here we can go for
number of samples which we are
interested in or giving a period so
let's go for period and say for example
i have seven values so what if i select
five
so for example if i say five that means
i could just get one value
so basically when i'm saying five out of
seven so that's just giving me out of
five i want
one value so i can then just give an
output range so here i can basically
select this cell i'll say okay and now
you see
it just shows me
one value
so out of the first range that is i've
said five it has given me the fifth
value that's your periodic sampling so
for example we want more values so let's
reduce this period
to might be 2 which basically gives me
every second value so i can basically
say
for example 2 and say ok
and then
say ok so that shows me
26
then you have 35
then you have 40 and then well this one
does not have any more values so that's
your periodic sampling now if you go for
random sampling that's basically
randomly picking up values and you can
choose how many values you want so go
for data analysis go for sampling i'll
go for number of samples how many you
want so for example out of seven values
randomly i want three values
and i can just give this say okay
and
then we will do a cancel because we need
to change that range so let's select
this and say okay and that gives me
random three values from this
values of temperature so we can use
excel to do a simple sampling and we can
choose whether we would want to go for p
hello everyone and welcome to this
interesting video tutorial by simply
learn today we are going to perform two
hands-on projects on cove data analysis
using python and tableau this is going
to be a really interesting and fun
session where i'll be asking you a few
generic quiz questions related to
coronavirus please make sure to answer
them in the comment section of the video
we'll be happy to hear from you covet or
corona virus is an ongoing global
pandemic of coronavirus disease that
emerged in 2019 and was first identified
in wuhan china
it is defined as an illness caused by a
novel coronavirus called severe acute
respiratory syndrome coronavirus 2
commonly known as sars cove ii
on march 11 2020 the who declared coven
19 a global health emergency the virus
has so far infected over 22 crore people
and killed more than 4.5 million
innocents
in india there have been over 3.3 crore
confirmed cases and nearly 4 lakh 41 000
deaths have been reported so far
this data is according to official
figures released by the union ministry
of health and family welfare
as the world tries to cope up with this
deadly virus we request all our viewers
and their family members to follow all
the necessary precautions to avoid
getting infected
quiz time
now let's see our first quiz in this
project
what does corona in corona virus mean
here are the options is it a beer
b respiratory is it c crown or is it d
sun
this is a very generic question
i am sure a lot of you may already know
some of you may not
please let us know your answers in the
comment section of the video we'll be
glad to hear from you
now in this video we will use
three different kuvin19 data sets and
perform data analysis using python and
tableau
the project will give you hands-on
experience working on real-world data
sets and how you can use the different
python libraries to analyze and
visualize data and draw conclusions
you will learn how to create different
plots in tableau and then make a
dashboard from the visuals
the project will give you an idea about
the impact of coronavirus globally in
terms of confirmed cases that's
reported the number of recoveries as
well as active cases
we will also see how india has been
affected since the pandemic started and
dive into the different states and union
territories to learn more about the
covet 19 influence and the vaccination
status
first let me show you the two data sets
that we'll be using
so for our first project using python
we'll be using the first two data sets
kovid 19 india and covet vaccine
statewise
let me open the two data sets
okay
so this is the first data set you can
see here
we have
the date
we have the time
then we have the different state names
scroll down you can see we have kerala
tamil nadu delhi haryana rajasthan
punjab
telangana and other states
then we have something called as
confirmed indian national so actually
this
two data sets confirmed indian national
and confirmed foreign national we won't
be using so in the demo itself we'll be
dropping these two columns
what we are concerned about are the last
three columns the
cured cases or the recoveries
the number of deaths reported and then
we have the
total number of confirmed cases
let me just
sort the b column that is the date
column so that you have an idea
about the recent data we have
i'll continue with the current selection
and
sort it you can see here
this is
till
11th of august 2021
so this data was collected from kegel it
has some discrepancies that we will see
in the demo the data is available for
free
we will provide the link to the data
sets in the description of the video so
please go ahead and download them
the visualizations and results that you
will see in the demo are based on the
datasets that we'll be using we haven't
preprocessed the data to remove outliers
or any missing values
now before i jump into the demo let me
show you the second data set that we are
going to use
okay so covet vaccine state wise is my
second data set
let me open it
there you go
so
this is the second data set that we'll
be using in the python
project you can see we have a column
called updated on then we have the
state again you can see here there are a
few discrepancies here
uh
it has taken the country name and not
the state name below you can see there
are the
different state names
and
you can also see we have information
about the total doses administered
we have the sessions sites
first does administered then we have the
second dose
then we have information about male and
female doses
you can see here the different
vaccines
administered covaxian and kobe shield
you have sputnik v
and here are the different age groups as
well
and finally if you see we have
male individuals vaccinated the total
number of female individuals vaccinated
for a particular day
we have information about transgender
individuals vaccinated and finally we
have the total individuals vaccinated
each day
all right before we jump into the
hands-on part let's have a look at the
second quiz in this project
so
here is the second quiz question
which is the first country to start
covet vaccination for toddlers
is it a japan
b israel c portugal or is it d cuba
this is a very recent development that
took place if you watch daily news
updates on coronavirus you will be
definitely able to answer the question
please give it a try and put your
answers in the comments section of the
video it is really important for our
viewers to know the right answer
all right
so now let's begin
with our demo
so i am on my jupyter notebook
so the first project we are going to use
python jupyter notebook
i'll just
rename this notebook as
kovid
data analysis
project
and click on rename
all right
so first and foremost
we need to import all the necessary
libraries that we are going to use so
first i'm importing pandas as pd this is
for
data manipulation
then we have numpy as np
numpy is used for numerical computation
then we are importing
matplotlib c bond and plotly
these three libraries will be used for
plotting our data and creating
interesting visualizations finally i'm
also importing
my datetime
function
all right
so i'll hit shift enter to run the first
cell
now it's time
to load our first data set
which is related to
the kovid19 cases in india for the
different states and union territories
so i'll create a variable called kovid
underscore df dfs for data frame
i'll use my pandas library
and then
give the read underscore csv function
since our data sets are
csv files
and inside
double quotes i'll pass in the
location where my
data sets are present
so i'll just copy this location
i'll paste it here
we'll
change the backslash to forward slash
and after that i'm going to give my
file name followed by the extension of
the file
i'll say covaid 19
india dot csv
let's go ahead and run it
all right
now
to see the first few
rows
of the data frame i'm going to use the
head function
i'll say head and within
brackets let's say i
pass in 10 which means i want to see the
first 10 rows of data
if i run it there you go here you can
see from 0
till 9 so we have 10 rows of information
and these are the different
column names you have s number
date time state or union territory then
you have confirmed indian national
confirmed foreign national
cured cases debts reported and the
confirmed cases
all right
now moving ahead
let's use the
info function to get some idea about
a data set
if i run it you can see here
it gives us the
total number of columns we have nine
columns the total number of entries or
the rows we have eighteen thousand
hundred and ten rows of information
starting from zero till
eighteen thousand one hundred and nine
you see here the different types of
variables or column names that we have
then it has information about the memory
usage as well
and this side you can see
the data types
cool
now we'll use another very important
function which is
to get
some idea about statistical analysis the
basic statistics about your data set for
that i'll be using the describe function
okay
so if you can see here
the describe function is for
numerical columns only
and you have the measures such as count
the mean standard deviation
maximum minimum the
25th percentile 50th percentile and the
75th percentile value
okay
now let's move ahead and import the
second data set
which is related to
vaccination
so i'll create a variable called vaccine
underscore df
i'll write pd dot
read underscore csv function which is
present in pandas
library i'll move to the top and i'll
copy the
file location
and we'll change the name of the file
copy this and
let me paste it here
and instead of kovid underscore 19
underscore india
i'm going to say governed
underscore
vaccine
underscore
statewide
okay
so this is the data set that we saw
covered underscore vaccine underscore
state wise
all right
let me run it
cool
and
let's display the first
seven rows of information from this data
frame
i'll be using the head function and
inside the function i'll pass in seven
there you go so here you can see we have
from zero till six
there are total
24 columns
a lot of them have null values you can
see here
all right
now
from the first data set which is the
covered underscore df data frame
we'll be dropping a few
unnecessary
columns such as the time column
confirmed indian national and confirmed
foreign national as well as the s number
we don't need these columns so it's
better to learn how to drop the columns
for our analysis
so i'll say kovid underscore df
dot
i'll use the
drop function
and within square brackets i'll pass in
the
column names the first is s number
i'll give a comma
within double quotes i'll say the next
column is time
my third column that i want to drop is
confirmed
indian national
give another comma
within double quotes i'll say
confirmed
foreign national
outside the
square brackets i'll give another comma
and pass in my next
argument
that is in place equal to i'll say true
i'll give another comma and say
access
equal to one
let's run it
okay it has thrown an error let's debug
the error
says confirmed indian okay it should be
indian national and not indian nation
i'll just
mention it as national will run it again
okay
now we have
removed these four columns
let me show you the data set now
there you go
so we have only the date column state or
union territory cured that's and
confirmed
now
let's see how you can change the format
of the
date column for that you have the
function called to datetime
i'll say
covid underscore df
i'll pass in my column name that is date
i'll say equal to
pd dot
i'll use the pandas function that is to
underscore
date time
i'll say kovaid underscore df which is
my dataframe name
pass in my
variable which is date
give a comma
and i'll use my argument that is format
equal to
i'll say percentage y
give a dash say percentage
m
give another dash and say percentage d
let's run it
and i'll print
the head of the data frame
cool
now moving ahead
now we will see how to
find the total number of active cases
so active case is nothing but the total
number of confirmed cases minus the sum
of
cure cases plus that's reported
so let's
find the active cases i'll give a
comment
okay
i'll first write my
data frame name that is covered
underscore df
within square brackets i'll give my new
column which is active underscore
cases
i'll say equal to
[Music]
kuvit underscore df
and my first column would be
the confirmed cases column
minus
i'll say
kuvid underscore df
then i'll pass in my cured column
plus
i'll again say
kovid
underscore df
and
add my
deaths column
this time let's print
the last
five rows from the new
data frame that we have created
okay
let's run it it has thrown an error
let's debug it
says
dataframe object has no attribute tails
this should be
teal
there you go
you can see here we have added a new
column called active cases which is
the confirmed cases minus the sum of
cured and
that's reported column
now we will learn how to create a pivot
table using the pandas
library
so in this table we'll be
summing all the
confirmed deaths and
cured
cases
for each of the states and union
territories
so we'll be using the pivot underscore
table function for this
i'll create a variable called statewise
and say pd dot
i'll use the pivot underscore table
function
i will pass in my
data frame that is covet underscore df
and then
give my
values parameter
inside the square brackets i'll pass in
my
columns
confirmed
deaths
and then we'll have the
cure column
i'll give a comma
and next
argument would be index
which is going to be my state
slash
the union territory column
let me bring this to the next line so it
is more readable
i'll say union territory
i will
give a comma now
and pass in my last argument which is
agg
function that means aggregate function
and
this function would be max
all right
let's run it
okay
now i'm going to find out the
recovery rate
so recovery rate is basically
the total number of qr cases divided by
the total number of confirmed cases into
100.
so i'll say
statewide
and within
square brackets i'll
pass in my
variable that i want to create which is
recovery rate
this will be equal to
the
cured cases
multiplied by hundred
by the total number of
confirmed cases
within square brackets i'll give my
column as
confirmed let's run this
okay
i'll just copy this column
paste it here so this time we are going
to find out the mortality rate
so mortality rate is nothing but the
total number of deaths divided by the
total number of confirmed cases into
hundred
so i'm just going to
replace the
names here i'll say
mortality
all right and then instead of cured i'll
say
my deaths column
in 200 divided by the confirmed cases
let's run it
okay
now
we are going to
sort the values
based on the confirm cases column
and we'll sort it in descending order so
let me show you how to do it i'll say
state wise equal to
i'll use the function short underscore
values
so
i'll pass in my variable statewise dot
and use the
short underscore
values function i'll say
bye i want to sort it by my confirmed
cases column
give a comma and i'll say
ascending
equal to
false
let's run it
now we are going to plot our pivot table
using a nice
visual
so for that i am going to use
my
background underscore gradient function
and inside that function will pass in
our cmap parameter
i'll show you how to do it
say style dot
background
underscore gradient
and inside this we'll pass in a
parameter called cmap
so c map stands for color maps this is
present inside the matplotlib library so
here you can see there is a nice
documentation on choosing color maps in
matplotlib
this is provided by matplotlib.org
if i scroll down you can see there are
a number of c maps that you can use
purples blues
you have something called reds
there are other things like magma you
have summer autumn spring winter
cool
all these
you can use whichever color map that you
want and here you can see the different
shades
or the gradients
okay
so i am going to use
my color map as cube helix
let me run it and show you the
pivot table
there you go
here you can see we have our pivot table
ready
now as i said in the beginning there are
a few
discrepancies in the data set so here
you can see
there's one called maharashtra and
there's also maharashtra triple star
this you can ignore even if i scroll
down you have madhya pradesh followed by
three asterisks you can ignore this
value as well even for bihar we have
so these have been duplicated
and
here you can see the different
state names and union territories then
on the top you have the confirmed cases
cured cases
the debts reported and the new
columns that we created
these are calculated columns recovery
rate and mortality rate
and we have ordered it in
descending order of confirmed cases so
so far
our data says that maharashtra has the
highest number of cases followed by
kerala karnataka tamil nadu andhra
pradesh and uttar prades so these are
the top
five states which have the highest
number of
confirmed cases
even if you see the mortality rate is
also high for maharashtra
and
if i scroll down
the mortality rate is also high for
uttarakhand if you see here
if i scroll further
your punjab the mortality rate is also
high
all right
so this was our first
visual that we created in the
kobe data analysis project
now moving ahead
we'll see the
top 10 states based on the number of
active cases
so we'll start
i'll give a comment top 10
active
cases
states
okay
so
we are going to explore another very
important pandas function in this which
is known as
group by
so i'll first
pass in my data frame which is kovid
underscore df
dot followed by the group by function
i'm going to group my data based on
state slash
union territory column
then i'll say
dot
max which is to find the
maximum value from the states
that have
the highest
active cases so i have passed in my
active cases column
and
we're also going to group it
based on the date column
after that
we are going to sort the values so i'll
use my function that is sort underscore
values
i'll say
short by
my column that is
active cases
let me bring this to the next line
underscore
cases
give a comma and say
ascending equal to
false
say dot
and then
i reset my index
for that i'll use reset underscore index
function
okay
let's check if everything is fine
i have
missed a square bracket here let me give
another square bracket here
okay
and all this we are going to store
in our
variable called top underscore 10
underscore
active
underscore cases
okay
now let me go ahead and
run this cell
okay there is
a syntax error here
now let's run it okay
now i'll create another variable called
fig
here we will pass in
the plt which is for matplotlib
library and will give the
figure size
using the
fig size
argument
it's equal to and within a tuple and
passing the size let's say 16 comma 9
we'll run it
okay and
let's give
a title to our plot
so here we are going to create a
bar plot
so
using plt.title we'll pass in the
title let's say top 10 states
with
most
active cases in india
i'll give a comma and pass in the size
of my title
let's say 25
okay you can see we are slowly
being able to
create our graph
the most important thing is to pass in
the
x-axis and the y-axis
i'll say ax which is for axis
to pass in the axis i am going to use
the bar plot function that is present
inside the c bond library
i'll say sns.bar plot
i'll say data equal to
my
variable which is top underscore 10
underscore
states
this is actually active states
all right and now
i'm going to use the
i lock
function
and
take the first 10 states so i'm using a
colon and then giving 10 as my value
iloc is for index location
i'll give a comma and say my
y axis to be
active cases
give another comma and say my x-axis to
be
state
slash
union territory
give another comma
we are going to pass in the line
width
to 2
i'll say line width equal to 2
and will give an edge color
let's say the edge color is
red
ok
so i have my
axis defined now
let's run it
there's an error here it says stopped in
active states not found
let's go to the stop and see the exact
okay so this is
top 10 active cases let me change it
to cases here
now run it
okay the x axis also has a mistake this
should be
state slash union territory
now let me run it there you go we have
our
plot
created but as you can see here the
labels of the
different states and union territories
are overlapping so for that
let me first pass in the
x labels i'll say plt.x
label
and my
x label would be states
then i'll say plt dot
by label
my y label will have the total
active cases
and finally i'll write plt dot show
before i run it let's collate all the
lines of code that we have written for
our
top 10 states for most active cases in
india into one cell
so what i'll do is i'll just copy this
and we'll keep
adding
in this cell itself
okay
i'll go to the top
next we'll copy
my figure size
and we'll
paste it here
next let's take the
title and put it here
give us peace
and we are going to copy
this cell
and i'll paste it here
all right
now it's time to run it
there you go
you see it here
we have a nice
bar plot ready on the top you can see
the title top 10 states with most active
cases
and you see the edges are in red color
for all the bars
on the x-axis you have the different
state names maharashtra karnataka kerala
you also have andhra pradesh gujarat
west bengal and chateau's card
so as you can see
maharashtra
has the
highest number of active cases based on
our data followed by karnataka caroline
tamilnadu at second third and fourth
place respectively and in the ninth
place we have west bengal in the tenth
place we have chattisgarh
on the y-axis you can see the total
active cases
which are
in lakhs
okay now moving ahead now we'll see the
top 10 states based on the total number
of
deaths reported
so i'll give a comment
top states
with
highest
debts
okay
so i'll first
create my variable
saying top 10 underscore
deaths
this will be very similar to
what we did here
just that we need to change a few
column names so instead of active cases
we'll be using deaths
okay
so i'll start with my
data frame that is covered underscore df
followed by using the
group by function and i want to group my
data
based on
the state slash
union territory column
then i'll choose the max function
and within
double square brackets i'll pass in
my column names deaths and date
let's make it consistent i'll be using
single quotes
okay
i'll say dot
i'm gonna
short my
result therefore i'm using the sort
underscore values function i want to
sort it by
deaths column
i'll give another comma and say
ascending equal to false which means i
want to order my result in
descending order
then i'll say dot reset underscore index
okay
after that i'll give my
figure size i'll say plt dot
figure
and within
brackets i'll pass in my argument which
is
fig size
equal to using a tuple i'll say 18 comma
let's say 5.
now let's give a title for that i'll use
the title function which is present in
the matplotlib library
i'll say
top 10 states with
most
deaths
and let's give a size to the title 25
now it's time for us to give the access
labels i'll just scroll down
okay
so i'll say ax equal to
again this will be a bar plot so i'm
using my c bond library followed by the
bar plot function
my data will be
top
underscore 10 underscore deaths
which is this variable
i'll give
my index location i loc
i'm going to choose
12 states the reason being
there are some discrepancies in the data
i'll show you once i plot this result
so in the y-axis we'll have
deaths column
in the x-axis we'll take
state
slash
union territory
okay
i'll give another comma
and say
line width
equal to 2
and will give
an edge color to our
bars like we did here
so i'll say edge color
equal to let's say
black
okay
now
finally
we'll give
the x label the y label
so i'll say plt dot x label
x label would be states
my y label
will be
total death cases
then i'll write plt dot show
now let's run it
there you go
you can see here we have a nice bar plot
on the top we have the title top 10
states with most deaths
now
what i specifically wanted you to
see was these discrepancies in the data
you can see here maharashtra is repeated
twice even in our data that we collected
from kegel
karnataka
spelling has an error you can see here
we have a few
rows of information where karnataka is
spelled as
a a k-a-r-a-a-n instead of k a r n a
all right so to
remove
these
two results or to ignore these two
results i had given
my index location till 12 so we have
maharashtra karnataka tamil nadu
delhi then uttar pradesh west bengal
kerala punjab andhra pradesh and
chattisgard
with the states that have the
most number of deaths
reported
okay
now we'll create a line plot to see
the
growth or the trend of active cases for
top five states with most number of
confirmed cases so the states are
maharashtra karnataka kerala tamil nadu
and uttar pradesh i can show you
so these are the states with
highest number of active cases
okay
hello everyone
welcome to today's video tutorial by
simply learn
in this video we are going to perform a
really interesting data analysis using
python on the spotify music streaming
service platform data set
i'll also be asking you a few questions
related to spotify during our discussion
please make sure to answer them in the
comments section of the video
so now let's get started
spotify is a swedish audio streaming and
media services provider founded in april
2006
it is the world's largest music
streaming service provider and has over
381 million monthly active users which
also includes 172 million paid
subscribers the total number of
downloads on the spotify app in the
android store exceeded 1 billion in may
2021
so millions of people listen to music
all day even i am hooked to music as an
analyst what's better than exploring and
quantifying data about music and drawing
valuable insights
before i move ahead i have a twist
question for you people
the name spotify comes from a
combination of two words so which are
those two words please let us know your
thoughts in the comments section below i
would like to repeat the question again
the name spotify comes from a
combination of two words so what are
those two words we would love to hear
from you so please put your answers in
the comment section below
now let's use python libraries and
functions to analyze and visualize our
data set
first i'll show you the two datasets
that we'll be using
so here is the first data set that we'll
be using for our demo and then i have my
second data set called spotify features
which is essentially about the
genres of the different soundtracks
now these datasets have been downloaded
from
kegel.com
now the links to the data sets have been
provided in the description box please
go ahead and download them
now let me just go ahead and brief you
about the columns that are present in
our first data set which is about tracks
we have our column a which is id this is
the unique id for each of the songs then
we have the name column which is
essentially the name of the song
then we have a column for popularity
so the popularity ranges from 0 to 100
then we have duration in
milliseconds this is the duration of the
track in milliseconds next we have a
column called explicit now we are not
bothered about this column because
we are not going to use it in our
analysis then we have artist so the name
of the artist who has composed or
sung the
song
then we have
id of the artist
then we have a column for
release date which is basically the date
on which the song was released then we
have a column for
dance ability
so this describes how suitable a track
is for dancing based on a combination of
musical elements such as tempo rhythm
stability
beat strength and overall regularity the
value ranges between 0 and 1.
next we have a column for energy so the
energy is a measure between 0.0 to 1.0
and represents a positive measure of
intensity and activity typically the
energetic tracks feel fast loud and
noisy
higher the value the more energetic is
the song
then we have a column for key so key is
the pitch
notes or scale of song that forms the
basis of a song there are 12 keys
ranging from 0 to 11.
moving ahead we have loudness so the
overall loudness of the track in
decibels it ranges from -60 to
zero decibels
then we have mode
so songs can be classified as major and
minor 1.0 represents major or one
represents measure and zero represents
minor
next we have
speechiness
so speechiness recognizes the presence
of spoken words in a track
more exclusive speech like the recording
example talk show audiobook or poetry
the closer to 1.0 the attribute value
then we have
a column for
the causticness
so a confidence measure of 0 to 1 of
whether the track is acoustic or not so
1.0 represents high confidence the track
is acoustic
then we have other information about
instrumentalness
then we also have a column for
liveness so liveness detects the
presence of an audience in the recording
then we have a column for
valence so balance is a measure between
0.0 to 1.0 and describes the musical
positiveness conveyed
by a track or a song
and finally we have
the columns for tempo and time signature
now
even in the second data set we have
almost the same
columns just that we have an additional
column that is about the genre of the
songs present in the data set
cool
now let's head over to our
jupyter notebook and we'll start with
our analysis
okay so one more thing to remember
our data has information from
1922 onwards so all the songs from 1922
till 2021
cool
okay so i am on my jupiter notebook so
you can see i have a few cells that have
already been filled up
so we'll start with our analysis first
of all let's go ahead and import the
necessary libraries so i'm importing
numpy pandas
matplotlib and c bond for my analysis
and visualization
i'll hit shift enter to import the
libraries all right
and
in the next cell i'm going to load my
data set using the pandas read
underscore csv function i have my
location already
put here let me show you the
location where the data files or the
data sets are located so this is my
location under chrome downloads i have a
folder called spotify datasets
okay
so let's import and
check the first five rows in the data
set so for that i have used the head
function there you go
so here you can see i have my first five
rows of information from the data set
and on the top you can see the different
columns you have id name popularity
artist
then we have the release date dance
ability energy key loudness
liveliness or liveness
balance tempo and other information cool
now
let's check for
null values in the data set i'll just
give a comment as
null values
every time when you download a data set
from an open repository there are
chances that the data set would contain
null values so it's better
to check them beforehand
so i'm going to use the is null function
present in the pandas library
pd i am using because i had
imported pandas as pde
so pd dot is null
then
i am going to use the variable name df
underscore tracks because i imported my
data set and stored it in the variable d
of underscore tracks
so i have my data frame under
df underscore tracks variable
and then i'll use the sum function to
check the total number of null values
present in the data set for each of the
columns
if i run it there you go
so here you can see
my name column has
71
missing values or null values
and we don't have any null values for
the rest of the columns
okay
now let's use the info method that will
give us the total number of rows and
columns in the data set and we'll also
check the data types and the memory
usage so i'll say
my data frame name that is df underscore
tracks
dot info
if i run it
you can see here
now if you mark there are total 5 lakh
86 601
names or
the names of the songs present in the
data set while the rest all have 5 lakhs
86 672
so clearly there are total 71 song names
or sound tracks missing from our data
set
and below you can see the
data types we have float integer and
object and then you can see the memory
usage
cool
now before i move ahead with our next
analysis i have another question for you
which artist or musician has the most
number of followers on spotify i repeat
which artist or musician has the most
number of followers on spotify please
put your answer in the comment section
below we would be happy to hear from you
now let's
move ahead and do our first major
analysis in this
demo
we are going to find the 10 least
popular
songs present in the spotify data set so
i'll create a variable called sorted
underscore df
that will be equal to
my data frame name that is df underscore
tracks
dot i am going to use the
sort underscore
values function
and say
my column name is popularity
so i am going to sort the values
based on the
popularity
and then say
ascending equal to
true
since i want
only the
least popular songs
and then
i'm going to say
head of
10 which means i want the top 10 least
populous songs now let's go ahead and
print sorted underscore tier
if i run it
you can see
we have the list of
10 least popular songs on spotify you
can see that popularity is zero
and you can see the
names of the
songs some of them are
songs which are not an english language
and you can see the artist names as well
cool
now moving ahead
let's see some descriptive statistics
for the numerical variables that are
present in our column
so i'll say
df underscore tracks dot
describe
which is the function to get some
descriptive statistics
and i'm going to use the transpose
function after that
if i run it
there you go so we have the
statistics about count mean standard
deviation
minimum value 25th percentile 50th
percent 75th percentile and the maximum
value for these columns like popularity
duration in milliseconds
then we have energy key loudness mode
cool
now if you see this
popularity column the minimum value is 0
and the maximum value is
100 and you can see the 50th percentile
is 27 which is essentially the
median
you have the standard deviation as 18.37
then similarly you can check for the
other
features as well
cool
now
we'll see the
10
most popular songs which are greater
than 90. so we are going to check for
the
top 10 songs with popularity greater
than
90 let me show you how to do it
so in this cell i am going to create a
new variable called
most popular
and i'll say df underscore
tracks
dot this time i'm going to use the
query function that is part of pandas
library again
i'll use the
column that is popularity
and we'll set the condition popularity
should be greater than
90
i'll give a comma and say
in place equal to false because i don't
want to change my original
data frame
and then i'll say
sort underscore
values
and
i'm going to sort it based on
popularity
in
descending order so i'll say
ascending equal to false
and then let's
take only the
top 10 popular
songs so i'll say
most popular use square brackets
use square brackets and
then pass the slicing operator and say
colon 10
now if i run this there you go
so here you can see the
10 most popular songs that is present in
our spotify data set first we have
features by
justin bieber
daniel cesar and gabon
then we also have a song name called
driver's license
astronaut in the ocean
save your tiers
we also have the business streets
and heartbreak anniversary
so these are the most popular songs that
are present in our data set
based on their
popularity you can see peaches has the
highest popularity with
100
all right
now moving to the
next cell
so here we are going to set the index to
be
release date column in the main data
frame so i am setting my index using the
set underscore index function i have
passed in my
column name as release date and i am
saying in place equal to true which
means i want to change it in my original
data frame and then i'm changing
the value to
date time format
and let's print the head of the
data set
so you can see here we have successfully
changed our index now here you can see
instead of 0 1 2 3 we have the release
date
column
and the
rest of the columns are intact
cool
now let's move ahead
so suppose you want to check the artist
at the 18th row in our data set you can
use the index location method for that
let me show you how to
filter only specific rows of information
from the data set i'll use my data frame
df underscore tracks and using double
square brackets i'll say
my column name which is artist
and i'll use the
index location
method and say let's say i want to check
the artist who is present
in the 18th row in my data set so i'll
use ilok 18 if i run it
the artist's name is
victor voucher
cool
now let's move ahead
we are going to convert the
duration in milliseconds to
just seconds
so
if you see our data set
we have a column called duration in
milliseconds so all our songs are
present in milliseconds let's convert
them
into just seconds so for that
i'm using the lambda function and
dividing the
values in
by thousand so that they get converted
into just seconds
i have used increase equal to true so i
want to change it in my original data
frame
let's run it and do the necessary
changes all right
now we'll print the head of the data set
just to
check the duration column so i'll say df
underscore
tracks
dot
duration
dot head
if i run it there you go so
you can see the values have now been
changed to just seconds
cool
i have the final quiz question for you
who has the most monthly listeners on
spotify
please put your answers in the comment
section below we'd be glad to hear from
you
now coming to the next cell
so here we are going to create a first
visualization that is going to be a
correlation map
we are going to drop
three unwanted
columns and those are key
mode and explicit and then
we are going to apply
pearson correlation method
now i have set my figure size to 14
comma 6
and then we are using the c bond
heat map function to create our
correlation map
i have put
the
variable that is
correlation underscore df you can see
above we had created this
and then i am setting
annotation equal to
true
so
this will write the data value in each
cell
i have set fmt equal to
dot 1
g so this is a string formatting code to
use when adding annotations then i have
set my v min and v max so these are the
values to anchor the color map otherwise
they are inferred from the data and
other keyword arguments
cmap here stands for color map you can
just search for
sns c map you will get the documentation
so
you can choose whichever
color palette or the color map you want
here i have used inferno
and i have set my line widths and line
color finally i am giving a title to my
correlation map and i have set the
extract labels let's go ahead and
run this to get our
first visualization
if i scroll down there you go we have
got a
nice
correlation map
so here on the
right side you can see the scale it
ranges from minus 1 to
plus 1
minus 1 means the variables have
least or negative correlation
while the values which are above 0.0
means that the variables have a positive
correlation
now here you can see
there are
values like minus 0.7 for energy and
acousticness which means if the energy
is
high
the
acousticness is really low again for
loudness and
say speechiness if the song is loud the
speechiness is low so there is negative
correlation but if you see
for energy and loudness there is a
really high correlation between these
two variables you can see the value is
0.8 so if the song is loud
this implies
the song has really high energy and vice
versa
now if you see for a few other variables
there is
negative correlation between
acousticness and
danceability
there is negative correlation again
between
balance and
acousticness similarly there is positive
correlation between energy and balance
which is 0.4
and even for danceability and balance
that is positive correlation which is
0.5
cool
so from the correlation heat map you can
note that acousticness appears to have a
strong negative correlation with energy
so if you see for acousticness and
energy there is a strong negative
correlation
and there is a moderately
strong positive relation between
loudness and popularity so if you see
for popularity and loudness the color is
orange which means it lies in this
positive region
and
there is also a
moderately strong positive relation
between danceability and balance so if
you check for danceability and balance
here there is
a moderately strong positive correlation
all right
now let's move ahead
we are going to sample our data and take
just 0.4 percent of the total data and
we'll create two regression plots using
this data so let me
first sample my data so i'll create a
sample data frame
using my original data frame which is df
underscore tracks and say
sample
i'm going to
use the int function and see
0.004
multiplied by
the length of my original data frame
which is
df underscore
tracks
all right
now let's
run this
and we'll
print
the
length of my
sample data frame
if i run it you can see
point
four percent of
my total data set is
2346 rows
cool
now we are going to create a regression
plot between loudness and energy now in
our correlation map we saw
there was
a positive correlation between
loudness and energy which was 0.8 let's
plot it in the form of a regression line
so i'll use
plt
dot
figure
i'll set my
figure
size
equal to let's say 10 comma 6.
i'll say sns dot
regression plot so i'm using the
function called reg plot
and i'll use my data as
sample underscore
df
give a comma
and say
in my y-axis i'll have my column
loudness
and in the x-axis we'll have
energy
i'll give a
color to
my
data variable let's say the color is c
then i'll set my
title
to
loudness
versus
energy
let's say correlation
all right
let's make sure everything is
fine
now
we'll run and see our result
there you go
so
you can see here clearly
there is a very high positive
correlation between loudness and energy
on the y-axis we have loudness and on
the x-axis we have energy
and you can see
all the
data points
or the songs are
in one direction
so if the
energy increases the loudness of the
song also increases and similarly if the
loudness of the song decreases your
energy of the song or the track also
decreases so there is a very high
positive correlation and you can see the
regression line here it has gone
and is increasing gradually
cool
now similarly i'll just copy this code
and we are
going to see another
regression plot this time for
two different features
let's say we have
popularity in the
y-axis so i'll say popularity
and then in the x-axis we have
let's say acousticness
i'll change the
color to let's say b which stands for
blue
and
will set the title to
popularity
versus
i'll have
because thickness
correlation
scroll down and we'll run it to see the
result
there you go
so i have the
different points for the songs and here
you can see the
regression line is
downwards which means if the
acousticness of the song increases the
popularity decreases and similarly if
the popularity increases acousticness
decreases
you can see
the
downward trend of the regression line
all right
now in the next cell we are going to
create a new column called
year from our
release date column
and i have changed this to
date time format let me just run it
cool
now after that
we are going to create a distribution
plot to visualize the total number of
songs in each year since 1922 that is
available on the spotify streaming app
so i have used my c bond library and
dist plot function now one thing to
remember you need to update your c bond
library to
this
version if you haven't done it so use
this command pip install dash dash user
cbon and
the version
so
here in the distribution plot
we are going to plot a histogram so i
have used kind equal to hist which
stands for histogram
let's run and see the result
okay so here you can see i have my
distribution plot so the
plot tells us that the
number of songs for each year in the
data set according to their release date
have increased in the recent year since
music became more accessible to people
globally with technological advancements
so earlier you can see there were very
few songs available in the
1920s later on the
number of songs
increased rapidly and now you can see we
have a lot more songs available for
people to listen
cool
now
we are going to see the duration of
songs over
the years for that again we are going to
create a
bar plot
so i'll
first create a
variable called total duration equal to
df underscore
tracks dot
i'll use the duration column that we
created with seconds
and then
i'm going to
set
my
figure dimensions so i'll use figure
underscore
dims for dimensions equal to
18 comma
7
after that i'll have my
figure access defined so i'll use the
matplotlib
subplots function
and
i'll set the
figure size
equal to
my figure dimensions
and then
i'll say
figure equal to
sns dot
i'll use the
bar plot function
and say
my x axis to be
years
my y-axis will be
total
duration or total underscore dr that we
created here
i'll set my axis equal to ex
and then
i'll set error width
equal to
false
let's set the title for my plot
as
title
equal to
your
bosses
duration
and finally i'll say plt dot x text
i'll rotate it by
let's say 90 degrees
all right
let me just recheck once if everything
is fine and then we'll go ahead and run
it
my axis error width title
okay let me just run it
we'll see the result in a moment
if i scroll down
you can see we have the
bar plot for the
different years and the duration of the
songs in seconds in the y-axis so
earlier in the 1920s you can see the
duration of the
songs were
less and later it
increased around
late
1930s and
this remained consistent until
2010 where the
duration was
high
but after 2010 you can see the
duration of the songs have started
decreasing
now in the
next cell
i'm going to create a line plot to
analyze the average duration of the
songs over the years
it is going to be similar to
our bar plot just that now we are going
to visualize it in terms of a line
so i have my
code ready
you can see here i've used my c bond
library and the line plot function in
the x axis i have years and in the y
axis i have total duration i've set my
title to
your voices duration and i'm rotating my
x labels by 60 degrees let's run it and
we'll see the output
there you go
now if i scroll down you can see we have
a nice
line plot
and on the x-axis you have the
ears and on the y-axis we have the
duration
we can see that the songs from
1920s to
1960s have comparatively shorter
duration
since most of the songs tended to be
more singing beast rather than
instrument beast
after
1960s you can see the duration of the
songs started increasing
until
i would say 2010
and
in the present day the duration of the
songs have started declining since the
attention span of the average listener
is also declining
all right
now let's move to our second data
analysis project which is based on
genres of the songs so i am
importing my data set using the band as
read underscore csv function i have
given my location
and here i have my
data set name followed by the
extension of the
type so this is a csv data set let's go
ahead and run it
okay
now
let's print the first
five rows of the data set
i have
stored my data set in a data frame
called df underscore
genre
i'll use the head function to get the
first five rows of information
i'll hit shift enter to run it there you
go
can see here i have my genre column
artist name track name track id
popularity acousticness
duration in milliseconds again
and we have the rest of the other
columns that we saw in our first data
set just one thing to note here key is
present in terms of
c d e c minor f minor
and not in terms of numbers between 0 to
11
now we'll see
the duration of the songs for different
genres
for that i am going to create a bar plot
so i'll start with setting the title for
my plot as
duration
of
the
songs
in
different
genres
i'll use the
c bond library
and
i'll set
my color palette
to let's say
rocket
will give a comma
and say
as cmap
equal to
true
this would be color palette
now
i'll say sns dot
bar plot
in the y axis i'll have
genre
and in the x-axis i'll have
my duration column which is in
milliseconds so duration underscore ms
and then i
pass my data frame using the data
argument
so i'll say data equal to df.genr
next
we'll
set the x labels so i'll say plt dot x
label
let's see my x label is
duration in
milliseconds
and then
i'll say
plt dot
by label as
genres
now let's go ahead and
run this
there you go so here
you can see we have the different genres
on the y-axis and on the x-axis you have
the duration in milliseconds
and if you see the graph
for
classical genre and for
songs that belong to
world genre the duration of the songs
are
more compared to
other genres now if you check for
children's music genre the duration
is
less or the least
cool
and finally
we'll move to our last demo where we'll
see
the top five genres by popularity
so i'll say sns dot
set underscore
style
i'll set my
style to
dark
grid
which will be my background
and then i'll say
plt dot
figure i'll set my
figure
size
to
10 comma
5.
then i'll create a variable called
famous
since i want to
take only the
most popular songs based on the genre so
i have created a variable called femus
and i'll pass my data frame name that is
df underscore
genre
and i'll sort the values
based on my popularity column
so i'll say
popularity
and i want to
sort it in
descending order so i'll say ascending
equal to
false
and i'll take the
first
10 values i'll tell you the reason why
i'm taking the first 10 values and not 5
then i'll say sn start
bar plot
and in the y-axis i'll have
genre
in the x-axis will have
popularity
and i'll keep a comma
and using the data argument i'll say my
data to be famous which is this variable
that we created
and then i'll set my
title
as
top
5
genres
by
popularity
all right
now the reason why i took head of 10 is
because there are a few genres which are
repetitive so if you see this we have
children's music
appearing
twice so hence we have taken 10 instead
of 5 let me just go ahead and run it
there you go
so here if i scroll down you can see i
have my top 5 genres based on the
popularity so we have dance pop rap
hip-hop and rigaton so these are the
five genres which are most popular
based on the
data that we have collected
from spotify
all right
hi everyone welcome to this really
interesting video on data analysis of
the 2021 world happiness report using
python
so today we will perform some
exploratory data analysis using python
libraries to analyze visualize and draw
insights from 2021 world happiness data
before i begin make sure to subscribe to
the simply alone channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
first let's understand what the world
happiness report 2021 is all about
the international happiness day is
celebrated every year since 2013 on 20th
of march to emphasize the importance of
happiness in the daily lives of people
so the united nations sustainable
development solutions network published
the world happiness report on 19th of
march 2021 that ranks the world's 149
countries on how happy the citizens
perceive themselves to be based on
various indicators
the happiness study ranks the countries
on the basis of questions from the
gallup world poll
the results are then equated with other
factors such as gdp life expectancy
generosity etc
this year it focused on the effects of
the kovit-19 pandemic and how people all
over the world have managed to survive
and prosper
so using this 2021 data we will answer
critical questions such as the top 10
most corrupt countries
we will plot a graph to understand how
the happiness score is related to the
freedom of making life choices
we look at the life expectancy of 10
happiest and 10 least happy nations so
these are a few examples but we will
explore more about the data in detail in
our demo session
let's get started so first i'll show you
the data set we'll be using in this demo
so this data has been collected from
kegel let me show you that
so this is the csv data set that we have
downloaded from
kegel.com so you can see here world
happiness report 2021
and
we will share the data set link in the
description of the video you can click
on the link to download the data set
now we have information about
149 countries you can see it here count
is 149 let me go to the top
and i'll run through the columns that
are there in this data set
so the first column is the country name
so we have 149 different countries and
then we have something called as
regional indicator we can call this as
just the region
so you can see we have different regions
i have applied a filter
we have central and eastern europe then
we have
common wealth of independent states so
these include countries such as russia
then we have east asia latin america and
caribbean
we also have south asia southeast asia
sub-saharan africa western europe
and other regions
i'll just cancel this and then we have
the
happiness score column that has been
sorted in descending order
so we have finland denmark and
switzerland who are the top three
happiest nations now if i scroll down
we have countries like
rwanda zimbabwe and afghanistan which
are the
least three happy countries
now
there are a few columns that we won't be
using in our analysis so we will learn
how to exclude those columns and keep
only the relevant ones
so columns such as
standard error of ladder score
then we have
upper whiskers and
lower whisker column so we are going to
ignore these columns
we are only concerned about
the gdp column which is this one then we
have the
social
support or the social status column then
we have the health life expectancy
freedom to make life choices
generosity and
perceptions of corruption and
there are a few other
columns
you can see to the right and
these columns are not of our interest so
we are going to ignore them
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and we'll start by importing
all the necessary libraries for analysis
and data visualization
okay so i am on my jupyter notebook so
first step i'll just
rename this notebook to let's say
happiness report
data analysis
i'll click on rename
all right
now we'll start by importing
our libraries so first library i'm going
to import is
numpy as np
then i have
import
pandas as pd
then i'll import two data visualization
libraries cbon and matplotlib
so i'll say import
c bond as sns and then
import
matplotlib
dot
pi plot
which is the module name as plt
and
i'll say
percentage
matplotlib
inline
okay
now let me just go ahead and run this
all right
well now let's set the parameters that
control the general style of the plots
the style parameters control properties
like the color of the background and
whether a grid is enabled by default or
not
so for that i'll say sns dot
set underscore
style
i'll
give it as
dark grid
next
i'll say
plt dot
rc
per amps
which stands for runtime configuration
parameters
i'm going to set my
font size
to
let's say 15
then i'll say
plt dot
rc
params
now i'm going to set the
figure size so i'll say figure dot
fig size
let's say
10 comma 7
next
just copy this
paste it here
now we are going to set the
face color
so i'll say
figure dot
face
color
i want to set it to
peach color so i'm going to
pass in my rgb values for peach
i'm going to set it in terms of hex code
so
for peach the value is
f
e
five
b and four
now let me run it okay
now
it's time to load our data set
so for that i'll create a variable
called data
and
i'll use the
pandas library
followed by the read underscore csv
function because our data set that we
saw
is a csp data set which is this one now
inside the parenthesis
i'll pass in the location of my
data file
so i have my data here
world happiness report 2021 i'll just
copy this location
and we'll
paste it here
and make sure the location is within
quotes
and you need to change it to
either forward slash or double backslash
so here i'm using
double black slash
so let me just include one more
backslash
and then
i'm going to pass in the
file name which is
world
hyphen
happiness
hyphen report hyphen 2021
dot csv
which is the extension of the file
now let me run it
all right
now to display the first five rows of
information you can use the head
function
so i am writing data which is my
variable that holds the
data prime so data.head
there you go
you can see here we have
printed the first
five rows from the data set you have the
country name
regional indicator happiness score
then we have information about the gdp
life expectancy
generosity
then we have
corruption data
and
these are some of the columns that we
are not bothered about so we are going
to drop these columns from our analysis
now
we are going to do that so i will create
a variable called data columns which are
of our interest
so i am going to take only specific
columns i need the
country name so i have
taken country name make sure the column
names are within single quotes so i have
my country name
next i want the
second column which is
regional indicator
give a comma
we also need the
happiness score
next i need the
logged gdp per capita data
so i'll take that column
i'll say logged
gdp
per capita
give a comma my next column would be
social support
give a comma here
my next
column would be health life expectancy
so i'll write
health
life
expectancy
let's give another comma and we'll take
the next column as well which is
freedom to make life choices
so i'll write that column name freedom
to make
life choices
and finally
we'll take the
next two columns that is generosity and
perceptions of corruption so within
single quotes i'll say
generosity
give a comma and
we're going to include the
final column which is of our interest
that is
perceptions of corruption
let me have a recheck
to ensure that i have put the column
names correctly
otherwise it will throw an error
now let me go ahead and run this cell
i'll hit shift enter
all right so we have
successfully
taken the columns that we'll be using
for an analysis
now i'm going to say data equal to
data
i'll pass in my new variable that is
data underscore columns
and i'm going to copy all the data so
i'll say dot
copy
let's run it okay this should be data
underscore columns all right
now
let's rename all these columns we'll
make it more simpler and
easy to understand so i'll say
let's say my new
variable is happy underscore df which
stands for data frame
equal to i'll say data dot
we'll use the rename function
and using a dictionary we will
rename our columns so i have used a
curly bracket
i am going to pass in my
first
column which is country name i'll just
paste it here
then
i'm going to give a colon
and
again within
single quotes i'll say country
underscore name so this is going to be
my new column name i'll give a comma
we'll take the next
column which is regional indicator
i'll paste it here
give a colon
and
the new column would be small r
regional
underscore
indicator
now similarly we will do this for all
the
remaining columns in the data set
okay now i have renamed all my columns
you can see it here
let's run it
now
we are going to display the head of the
data set again
so i'll say happy underscore df dot head
there you go
so we have
only those columns that are of our
interest
so i have the country name regional
indicator happiness core gdp
social support
life expectancy
freedom to make life choices then i have
generosity and
perceptions of corruption
cool
now
we are going to check whether any of the
columns have
any null values so for that i will say
happy underscore df
dot
i'm going to use the is null function
i'll give another dot and we are going
to find
the sum
for each of the columns
you can see from the data we do not have
any
null values in any of the columns in the
data set
dissolve zero
okay
now let's get started with our first
visualization that is
we'll create a plot between
happiness score and the gdp
for
different regions
so for that i'll give a comment as
plot
between
and gdp
i'll just scroll down
cool
first i'm going to
set the
rc parameters so i'll say plt dot
rc
per amps
within square brackets i'm going to give
my figure size so i'll say
figure dot
fixed size
equal to
let's say my figure size is 15
comma 7
i'll set the
title that is plt dot title of my plot
to
let's say plot between
happiness score
and gdp
next
i'm going to say sns dot
let's create a scatter plot so i'll say
sns.scatterplot
i'm going to define my x-axis and the
y-axis for the plot let's say in the
x-axis we have
my data frame happy
underscore df
dot
this should be an underscore
i'll say
a column name as happiness underscore
score
give a comma
and in the y axis we'll have
my data frame name that is happy
underscore df dot
will have the gdp column that is
logged underscore
gdp
underscore per underscore capita
let's give a comma
and we'll pass in hue for
the color
let's see for you am going to use the
original
column or the regional indicator column
so i will say
happy underscore df
dot
regional underscore indicator
and then i'm going to give the size of
the dots as let's say 200
then i'll give a semicolon
come to the next line
i'll say plt dot let me just scroll down
now we are going to define the legend so
i'll say plt dot
legend
and in legend we'll have
the location let's say i want to put the
legend at upper left
corner so i'll say loc which is for
location equal to upper left
give a comma and then say
font size of my legend let's say
be 10
make sure this is within quotes
then i'm going to pass my x-axis labels
and the y-axis labels
so i'll say plt.x label
let's say the x label is
happiness score
and my y label is
gdp per capita so i'll say plt dot y
label
within
single quotes i'll say gdp per
capita
there's an error here this should be
plot
all right so i have
written my code to create a scatter plot
let's run it and see the result
there is some error here
okay this should be
a regional
indicator and not indie catering there's
a spelling mistake let's run it again
all right
so here you can see we have a nice
scatter plot on the top you can see we
have the title of the plot that is plot
between happiness score and gdp
on the x-axis we have the happiness
score from 0 to
8
and above
and on the y-axis you have the gdp per
capita
and if you see here
in this region we have
countries from
western europe which have the
highest happiness core and the gdp per
capita is also the highest
around this region you can see here
which is for green and in the legend you
can see green is for
sub-saharan africa so all these
countries have low happiness score and
even the gdp per capita is also
low
and if you see the
countries for
latin america and
caribbean
you see a lot of the
values lie here so they are all
within the range of 5.5 to
7 in happiness score
and even the gdp per capita is more than
nine for most of them
now even the happiness score is high for
the countries that lie in the north
america and enz region
and even that gdp per capita
is also the highest i can name a few
countries such as australia new zealand
we have canada and
united states of america which belong to
the north america and enz region cool
now there is one country which you see
here
this seems to be like an outlier which
means that this is the country which has
the
lowest happiness score and even the gdp
per capita is also low but it is not the
lowest because you can see here there
are a few countries up here
from the sub-saharan africa which have
the lowest gdp per capita but
the happiness score is higher than this
value
or this country
so
we can assume that this country is
afghanistan which has the
lowest happiness score as per the
2021 happiness
report data
cool
now we'll plot a pi plot to understand
the gdp by region
so by this we can know which region has
the highest percentage contribution to
the world's gdp as per our data
so for that i'll create a variable
gdp underscore
region
equal to
we'll use our data frame that is happy
underscore df
dot i'm going to use the group by
function
and
after that
i am going to use my
column that is
region
so we have named the column as regional
underscore indicator so i am going to
group it by this region column
and i am going to sum the values of gdp
so i am going to use the
logged underscore
gdp underscore per capita
column
and after that i am going to use the sum
function
and let me just print gdp
underscore region
you can see it here we have the
sum of all the
countries for different
regions and their
gdp all total
now this data we are going to plot it in
the form of a pi plot
so i'll say
gdp underscore region
dot
plot
dot
pi
we are going to plot it in terms of
percentage so i am going to use a
parameter
called auto pct
equal to then i'm going to pass in my
format
so i'll say percentage 1.1
f
percentage percentage
then i'll say plt dot
title
let's see the title of my pi plot is
going to be
gdp
by
region
and i'll say plt dot
by label
which is going to be blank
let's run it
okay
so here you can see we have the
peach background at the back because we
had
assigned
a peach
face color you can see it here
so for the first
scatter plot also we had the peach color
at the back
and now you can see
we have sub-saharan africa contributing
20.7 percent to the world's
gdp the reason being we have
around 34 countries in the sub-saharan
africa
and
we have the western european countries
contributing to 16.2 percent of the gdp
to
[Music]
check the least we have north america
and enz region because we only have four
countries america
australia canada and new zealand so
hence they are contributing only 3.1
percent to the world's gdp
okay now moving ahead
let's find the total number of countries
in each region so for this we are going
to use the
group by function that is part of the
pandas library and we'll count the total
number of countries in each region
so i'll just give a comment
as
total countries
all right just scroll down
so i'll create a variable called
total underscore
country
i'm going to use my data frame that is
happy underscore df
dot i'm going to use the
group by function
i'll group
the values based on the region column so
within single quotes i'll say
regional underscore
indicator
and then
i'm going to
find the
total count of country names so i'm
using the column country underscore name
and after that i'll just use dot count
now let's go ahead and
print my variable that is
total underscore country
all right now let me hit shift enter
okay so here you can see
all right so for sub-saharan africa
there are total 36 countries and not 34
as i mentioned earlier so hence you can
see
because it has the highest number of
countries it is contributing the most to
the world's gdp that is 20.7 percent
then we have the
least number of countries in north
america and anc that is only four
we have six countries in east asia
and then
we have 20 countries in latin america
and caribbean 12 countries in
commonwealth of independent states then
we have 17 countries in central and
eastern europe
cool
now
i'm going to show you how to create a
correlation map so that we can see the
relationship that exists between each of
the
variables that are present in our data
set i'll just run through the code and
we'll see the output
okay so here i have my code written for
the correlation map that i want to
create so first of all i am going to
compute the correlation matrix so i have
used the corr function which stands for
correlation
and the method i am going to use is
pearson method now here i have a
wikipedia page opened for pearson
correlation coefficient so
this is a nice article where you can
understand what the pearson
correlation is all about and then i'm
going to set up the matplotlib figures
so i've used the
subplots function and i've given the
figure size as 10 comma 5
and after that we are going to draw the
heat map with the mask so i am using the
heat map function present in the c bond
library and then i have passed in my
variable that is cor which essentially
stands for correlation
and then
i have used mask which is a boolean
array or it can be a data frame and it
is an optional parameter
if it is passed the data will not be
shown in cells where the mask is true
and the cells with missing values are
automatically masked
after that i have used the
c map parameter which stands for color
map so you can customize the colors in
your heat map
and i'm going to
create a
heat map which is in square shape so i
have said square equal to true
and
the axis i am going to pass it as ax
which i have defined here so this is the
matplotlib axis and it is optional so
access in which you want to draw the
plot otherwise you can use the current
active
access
now let me just go ahead and run this
and we'll see the heat map
there you go
so if i scroll down here we have the
correlation matrix and since i had given
my c map as blue
and here you can see it is mostly blue
and we have the scale here
now
i'll tell you how to read this
correlation matrix so wherever the cells
are in blue or dark blue color this
means that the variables have very high
correlation
and
all these cells where you see light blue
color or grayish and white color
this indicates that
the
variables have very low correlation for
example
there is very low or
almost negative correlation between
happiness score and perceptions of
corruption so obviously if the citizens
of a country feel that there is a lot of
corruption in the country that happiness
score would obviously be
less or low
and if you see
there is also low correlation between
happiness score and generosity
there is
then low correlation between
health life expectancy and perceptions
of corruption
and if you see these places
there is
really high correlation between the
happiness score and
gdp per capita
again for social support also there is
very high correlation
now if you see even for
social support and healthy life
expectancy there is very high
correlation
but there
is low correlation between
making life choices and generosity
and there is
negative correlation between corruption
and
freedom of making life choices you can
see it is almost white color which means
it falls around this region so negative
correlation
similarly for
logged gdp per capita and
corruption there is
negative correlation
all right
okay now we are going to visualize
a bar plot
that will
tell us the corruption in different
regions
so i'll just give a comment
corruption
in
regions
let me just scroll down
okay
so i'll create a variable called
corruption
which will be equal to
my
data frame that is happy underscore df
now first of all i am going to use the
group by function to group
all my regions so i'll say
regional underscore
indicator which is my
column name present in the data set
and after this
i'm going to find the
average
of the
corruption that is perceptions of
corruption so
i am going to pass in my
variable name that is
perceptions of
corruption
and i'm going to use the
mean function to find the
average corruption in each of these
regions
now let me just go ahead and print my
variable that is corruption
if i run it
you can see here
i have the values for the different
regions and from here you can see
that
central and eastern europe has the
highest perceptions of corruption as per
the
questions answered in the poll
and if you see the
table
we have western europe
and the north america region with the
least perceptions of corruption
now we are going to visualize this using
a bar plot now so first of all
i'll
set my
parameters
by giving the
figure size
i'll say
fig
size
it's rather figure dot fixed size
i'll just add figure here
okay
and now
let's say
i'll assign it as 12 comma 8
now i'll give a title to my plot so i'll
say plt dot title
and my title of the plot is going to be
perception of
corruption
in
various
regions
all right
then i'm going to define my x label
so i'll say x label will
be regions
and
we'll set the font size of the x label
to let's say 13
or let it be 15
then we are going to set the
y label
in y label i'll have
corruption index
as the label name
again we are going to set the font
size to 15
now i am going to use
x
ticks
parameter
since i want to
rotate the
axis labels in the x axis by 30 degrees
so i'll say
rotation
equal to 30
and i'll say h a which stands for
horizontal alignment equal to right
make sure this right should be within
single quotes
and finally i'll say plt dot
bar
because i am going to plot a
bar graph
i'll say corruption
dot
index
comma
and then i'll say
corruption
dot
perceptions
of
corruption which is my column name
all right
so i have my code ready for the bar plot
now let me just go ahead and
print
the bar plot
make sure everything is correct i'll
just hit shift enter
okay there is one mistake here it says
okay this should be x ticks and not x
tick
let me run it again there you go
so if i scroll down
on the top you have the
title which is perception of corruption
in various regions on the
x-axis you have the
regions label on the y-axis you have the
corruption index and if you see this
as per our table that we created
we have
least corruption in north america and
anc region
then we have the
next least corruption in western europe
but we have the highest corruption in
central and eastern europe as per
their citizens perception
similarly we have the
second and third highest corruption in
latin america and caribbean as well as
south asia
cool
now moving ahead
i'm going to show you how you can find
the
life expectancy of the top 10 happiest
countries and bottom 10
happy countries so for that i'm going to
run you through the code and we will see
the
visualization side by side
okay so i have my code written in
these two cells
so first i am going to find out the top
10
happiest countries and then i'm going to
find the
bottom 10
happiest countries so for that i'm using
the head function and i passed in 10
since i want the top 10
country names and to get the bottom 10
countries as per their happiness score i
am using the tail function
so let me just run it
so we have saved the result in two
variables top underscore 10 and bottom
underscore 10
and to create the
bar plots
we are using
two
different
codes so here you can see i have set my
figure size and access and then
i have my x label as
country name
after that i am setting my
title of the bar plot to top 10 happiest
countries life expectancy i've used my x
stick labels and i'm rotating it by 45
degrees and i have my horizontal
alignment as right
you can see it here we have used the bar
plot function i have the x-axis as
country name and y-axis as
healthy life expectancy column
and i have set my axis
then
i am
using the
x labels and y labels as country name
and life expectancy and similarly i have
my bar plot for
the bottom 10 least happy countries life
expectancy
let's just run it and we'll see the
result
there you go
if i scroll down you can see we have
two different bar plots the first one is
for the 10 happiest countries and then
we have the bottom 10 least happy
countries
so if you see
on an average
the top 10 happiest countries life
expectancy is above 70 years so if you
are from one of these countries you are
expected to live
for more than 70 years
now if you check the
bottom 10
least happy countries you see here
lesotho has less than 50
life expectancy age
and
most of them
are less than
60 years
so if you are from one of the top 10
happiest countries you are expected to
live
10 years more than these
countries that
line the bottom 10 region
cool
now moving ahead
all right so now we are going to see the
plot between freedom to make life
choices and the happiness score for this
i'm going to use a scatter plot
so
i'll first define my figure size so i'll
say plt dot
rc
p-a-r-a-m-s which stands for parameters
i'm going to pass in my
figure size so i'll say figure dot
fig
size
equal to
let's say 15 comma 7
then using the c bond library
and the scatter plot function
will pass in the
x-axis let's say the x-axis is
my data frame name happy underscore df
and
i'll have the
freedom to make life choices
in the x axis
so the column name is freedom underscore
2 underscore make
underscore life
and choices
i'll give a comma
and we'll pass in the y-axis again i'm
going to use my
data frame name
dot
and i'll have the
happiness score
i'm also going to
pass in a hue parameter
to differentiate
the different regions
so i'll say df dot
regional underscore indicator
and i'll give the size of the dots or
the bubbles as let's say 200
now i'll say
plt dot
legend
i'll place the legend
at upper left corner so i am giving the
location which is loc equal to
upper left
and
font size
let it be
12. i'll say plt dot
x label
as
freedom to make
life
choices
and my y label
would be happiness score
all right
now we have the code written for the
scatter plot that i want to create let
me just run it
there you go
so here we have the legend for the
different
regions
and we have the
different colors for each of these
regions
and you can see here
i have
on the x axis freedom to make life
choices and on the y-axis we have the
happiness core
so you can see it very clearly
for the countries that lie in the
western europe region the blue dots
the freedom to
make life choices is more and so is the
happiness score
then if you see
the values in the
green region which is for middle east
and north africa the freedom to make
life choices is lower and hence the
happiness score is also low
and for all these countries that are
part of the sub-saharan africa
some of them have
decent score for freedom to make life
choices but the happiness score is low
again
now if you focus on the
pink dots which is for the southeast
asian countries the happiness score
is comparatively lower but the
freedom to make life choices is more
than
0.8
cool
and again we have one
data point which is
lying at the bottom we can assume this
is afghanistan so in afghanistan the
freedom to make life choices is very low
and even the happiness score is really
low
cool
now moving to our next analysis
we are going to see the top 10 most
corrupt countries
so first i am going to sort the
perceptions of corruption column and
find out the top 10 countries in the
list
so for that i am going to create a
variable called country
i'll have my
data frame name that is happy underscore
df dot
sort underscore
values
by
i am going to sort by
column that is
perceptions
of
corruption
dot
head
and i want to find the top 10 most
corrupt countries as per the
poll
and then
i'm going to
pass in the figure size so i'll say plt
dot rc
per amps
and then
i'm going to set the
figure size so i'll say figure dot
fig size
make sure there is no spelling mistake
let's say the figure size is 12 comma 6
i'll pass in the title so i'll say plt
dot
title let's say the title of my
plot is going to be
countries
with
most
perception of
corruption
after that i'll say plt dot
x label
in the x label i'll have
country and i'll set the
font
size to
13
then i'll say plt dot
by label
in by label i'll have the
corruption
index
next
i'll
pass in the font size for the y label
again it is going to be 13.
now i will say plt dot
x
ticks
i am going to
rotate it by
30
and i'll say
horizontal alignment equal to
right
and then
i'll have my
bar function or the bar plot function so
i'll say plt dot bar
i'm going to pass in country dot
country
underscore name
and then we'll have a variable country
dot
the column name that is
perceptions of
corruption
all right
now if i run it
you can see here
so these are the countries with the
least perceptions of corruption so
singapore has the
lowest corruption index
and then we have rwanda denmark finland
now if you want to see the
countries with the
highest perceptions of corruption you
need to change this head to
tail of 10 since we are sorting it in
ascending order so we would want to know
the
bottom 10
countries if i run it
there you go so these are the countries
with the most perception of
corruption you have
slovakia lesotho
kosovo this ukraine afghanistan
bulgaria romania and croatia all of
these countries have a corruption index
of more than
0.85
cool
now coming to the final section of this
interesting video on happiness
report
data analysis for 2021. i want to
visualize a scatter plot
that will
tell us how the corruption varies in
terms of happiness score
so i'll just say
a comment as corruption versus
happiness
okay
so first of all i'll set my
figure size so i'll say plt dot
rc
params
within single quotes i will give the
figure size
as
15 comma
7
then i am going to use the scatter plot
function that is part of the
c bond library
in the x axis i will have my
column that is
corruption or rather we'll have the
happiness score in the x axis so i'll
say
happy underscore df dot
column name that is happiness
score
let me give a comma and in the y axis
we'll have
the corruption column so i'll say happy
underscore df dot
perceptions
of
corruption
and then
in hue we'll have the
region that is
regional underscore indicator so i'll
say happy underscore df dot
regional
indicator
and i'm going to give the size of the
dots so i'll say s equal to 200.
then i'm going to say plt dot
legend
i'm going to
put it at
lower left corner this time so i am
giving my location as
lower left
and
the font size of the legend i want is
14.
after that i'll just say plt dot
x label
as
corruption
and
plt dot
by label
as
happiness core
now this should rather be the opposite
since in the x-axis we have taken
happiness score
so we'll
put the happiness code label in
x and
i'll have
corruption in y
all right
so i have my scatter plot
code ready let me just run it
there you go
so here you can see
on the lower left i have the different
regions
and on the x-axis i have the happiness
core
on the y-axis i have the corruption
index now you can see the general trend
as per the scatter plot that the
countries with
greater happiness score have lower
corruption index
so you can see these countries which are
from the western european regions have
highest happiness core and the
corruption is also really low so all
these blue countries you can name a few
finland we have sweden we have belgium
france netherland
lying in these regions we also have a
few countries from north america and enc
which are essentially australia then we
also have canada u.s
and new zealand
okay
now if you focus on these
green
region this region
now these are the countries from the sub
saharan africa
and most of the
countries from these regions have a very
low or less than five happiness core but
the corruption is also really high you
can see here they have almost more than
0.7 in the corruption index
now
you also have a country here which is
from the
southeast asia we would like to give you
a task it would be really great if you
can
tell us in the comments section which
country is this
it has more than six
happiness core but the corruption index
is really low which is less than
point
two
now if you consider
middle east and north african regions
the
darker green countries
here also if you see the happiness score
is less than 5 and the corruption index
is also high
now there are a few countries
the
common wealth of independent states for
example
countries such as
ubikistan then you also have kajikistan
we have russia armenia belonging to
these
grey color
dots you also have georgia and ukraine
as part of commonwealth of independent
states
so here you see the corruption is below
0.6 for these countries and the
happiness score is more than
5.
all right
so with that we have come to the end of
this
demo session on world
happiness report 2021 data analysis
using
python
hello everyone
welcome to this exciting video on
olympics dataset analysis using python
by simplyloan
this is going to be a very interesting
and interactive session where i'll give
you a brief about the history of
olympics and throw some light into the
recently held tokyo olympics but we'll
focus more on using olympics dataset
that is available on kegel and perform
some exploratory data analysis
you will understand how to use different
functions in python to analyze and
extract meaningful information
during the course of our discussion i'll
be asking you a few general questions
related to the olympics try to answer
them in the comments section of the
video so let's begin
the olympics is one of the biggest
sporting events on the planet
it is held every four years
the first modern olympics took place in
athens greece in 1896.
as per national geographic
the original olympics took place in 776
bc
so they began as part of an ancient
greek festival with celebrated jews the
greek god of sky and weather
the rings in the olympics logo represent
the five continents europe africa asia
the americas and oceania
from 1924 to 1992 the winter and the
summer olympics took place in the same
year but now they alternate every two
years
before i move on here is an interesting
question for you
only two people have ever won gold
medals at both the summer and the winter
olympics
who are those two people
please share your answers in the
comments section of the video we would
like to know from you
the summer olympics in tokyo began on
the 23rd of july and recently concluded
on the 8th of august
we got to witness some thriller matches
that went down to the wire some amazing
victories and sadly there were a lot of
heartbreaks as well
winning and losing are part and parcel
of any game
fans across the world were really happy
to see this global event happen this
year following last year's postponement
due to the coronavirus pandemic
with our olympic fever high let's take
this opportunity to work around a
project to perform exploratory data
analysis using python to analyze and
visualize past olympics data and answer
specific questions
in this video we will be using specific
python libraries such as numpy pandas
matplotlib and c-bond to make sense of
our data and extract meaningful
information
we are going to visualize our results
with different charts and graphs
before i show you the data set that we
are going to use for our analysis
i have another general question for you
which is the first olympics where all
the participating countries sent female
athletes a repeat which is the first
olympics where all the participating
countries sent female athletes
put the year and the city name where the
olympics was held in the comments
section of the video
we'll be more than happy to hear from
you
now
let me go ahead and show you the data
sets that we'll be using in this video
so here you can see i have my
olympic data set folder that has two
data sets these are csv files one is
called the athlete underscore events and
the other one is called noc underscore
regions
so
we'll be using these two data sets these
data sets can be downloaded from kegel
we will post the data set links in the
description of the video please go ahead
and download them these data sets have
been directly taken from the internet
now i'll show you the data sets
so this is my first data set you can see
on the top athlete underscore events so
i have
around 15 columns you can see the count
here and there are
nearly
2 lakhs 71 116 rows of information
so this is a huge data set that we are
going to use
the other data set we are going
to use in this demo is called noc
underscore regions now here one thing to
notice
noc stands for national olympic
committee this is a three letter code
that is given by the olympic committee
we have the region names so afg is for
afghanistan you have alb for albania elg
for algeria we have also a column called
nodes you find some
notes about the
region for example here antiqua is
actually antiqua and
barbuda
all right
let's move to the
first data set that i showed you
this is a primary data set for our demo
so these data sets have been directly
taken from the internet and were not
validated so the results that you will
see in the demo is purely based on the
data that we have collected
so the file athlete underscore
events.csv contains
nearly 2 lakh 71 116 rows of information
and there are 15 columns
so each row corresponds to an individual
athlete competing in an individual
olympic event
so here id is actually a unique number
for each athlete then we have the name
which is basically the athlete's name we
have the sex or the gender which is male
or f or female
then we have the age of the athlete
which is in terms of integers
we have the height in
centimeters of the athletes then we have
the weight in kilograms
we have the team name these are the
country names you have china denmark
netherland there are around 200 country
names
then we have the noc as i said noc
is a three letter code that stands for
national
olympic committee
we have the games this games contains
the year and the season you can see here
1992 summer you also have the winter
olympic information
all right
then we have a specific year column
to
tell you in which year this event had
occurred
now the year column is also an integer
column
we have the season so whether it was
summer olympics or winter olympics
then we have the city name this is the
host city
then we have the sport name you can see
here we have basketball judo football
tug of war
speed skating
there are so many
then we have another column called event
which is the complete even name as you
can see the sport name is basketball but
the even name is basketball men's
basketball to be very specific
again for speed skating you have
different categories like women's
thousand meters 500 meters
all right
now the final column is the middle
column so it has
the information about the athlete
whether
the athlete had won a medal bait gold
silver branch and n a means the athlete
did not win any medals so we'll use
these two data sets
now let's
get started with the demo
we'll be using jupyter notebook for our
analysis so i'll take you to my jupyter
notebook right away
i've opened it on chrome so this is my
jupyter notebook that we are going to
use you can see here olympics data set
analysis i have already
have a few cells that have been filled
with some piece of code
and you can see there are
some comments written as well we are
going to use this data set
so let's get started
first and foremost we'll import the data
sets so we are going to use
numpy pandas matplotlib and cbon
let me hit shift enter to
import all the
libraries
all right
now the next thing is to load the
datasets
using
pandas read underscore csv function
so i'll create a variable called
athletes
i'll say equal to
pd dot i'll use the read underscore csv
function
and inside this function will give the
location
of the files so i'll copy this location
and here i'll paste
make sure this is within
quotations
and these are all
forward slash
give another forward slash
and after that i'll give the
file name that is
athlete
underscore
events
dot csv
i'll close the quotation
let's run it
okay
similarly we will
load the second data set i'll create
another variable called regions
so it will have my data frame
i'll use the same function pd dot read
underscore csv
i'll just copy this
file path
till here
we paste it
and
i'll give my second file name which is
noc underscore
regions dot csv
you can verify here
the first one is athlete underscore
events the second one is noc underscore
regions
okay i'll close the quotation and we'll
run it again
okay there seems to be some error i
think this is the regions
cool
now moving ahead
let's see the
first few rows of both the data sets
i'll use the head function for that
i'll say
athletes dot head
so this will print the first five rows
from my data set
athletes you can see here
from 0 to 4 you have 5 rows of
information the id name sex or the
gender
each height
weight if i go to the right you have
games
year season sport event and middle
now let's see
the
second data set that we
imported or loaded i'll say regions dot
head
it says regions
is not defined
let me cross check it
okay i have taken it as region let's
make it regions
cool
now let's run it there you go so these
are the first five rows from our second
data set you have noc region and some
nodes
all right
now the next step is to combine
both the data sets so we'll join the
data frames using the pandas merge
function let me show you how to do it
so this is going to be a horizontal join
i'll create a variable
called athletes underscore df
then
i'll use my first
variable which is athletes
i'll say dot merge which is my function
name
i'm going to merge
the regions data frame
i'll use the how parameter
in how i'll give my value as
i want to do a left join
and my common column in both the data
sets is actually noc
so i'm going to use
the noc column as my common column to
merge both the data sets
now let's go ahead and
print the
most data frame i'll say athletes
underscore df.head let's run it
there you go
so
if you see clearly if i move to the
right you can see here we have added two
more columns that were present in the
second data set which was regions so we
have regions and nodes
added to my
first data set that is
athletes underscore
events
cool
now one thing to note here is
see the column names are not consistent
if you see here the rest of the columns
start with a capital letter but if you
see the last two columns that we just
added now start with the lower case
letter so we'll use
the rename function to
make the column names consistent
but before that
let's
see the
shape of the data frame so i'll print
the shape of the data frame to know the
total number of rows and columns
i'll say
athletes if i hit tab
you will see it will give me
the prompt i'll select athletes
underscore df
i'll use the
shape attribute
let's run it
and see the result you can see here it
gives me the total number of rows so 2
lakh 71 116 rows and earlier we had 15
columns in the first data set and now
that we have added two more columns so
the total number of columns becomes
17 now
cool
so now it's time to make the
column names consistent
so i'll show you how to do it i'll say
athletes underscore df
dot i'll use the rename function
and then
i'll say
columns
equal to
i'll use curly braces
my first column
that is region i want to change it to
a region but the r should be capital now
or upper case
i'll give a comma
and then see
my second column
this should be
a region actually
my second column that is notes
i want to
change the first letter to uppercase so
i'll say capital n
the rest all remains same
i'll give a comma here
and say
in place equal to true
so it will change
the column names and will reflect
in this athletes underscore df data
frame
let's run it
now to verify you can again use the head
function i'll run this again
let me scroll down and move to the right
you can see the difference there you go
so we have successfully renamed the last
two columns region and notes
all right
now moving ahead
now
i'll show you how you can use the info
method to print information about a data
frame including the index data type the
column data types
normal values and memory usage
so for that you just need to use the
info function so i'll write
athletes underscore df
dot info
let's run it there you go so here we
have the
data columns you can see total
17 columns you have two lags seventy one
thousand hundred and sixteen rows or
entries
then you have the
different column names and you see it
says non-null and the data type of the
column
below you can see some information about
the memory usage
all right
next
the describe method is used for
calculating statistical information such
as mean standard deviation the
percentiles of the numerical values of
the data frame and much more
it analyzes both numeric and object
series and also the data frame column
sets of mixed data types
so let me show you how using
the describe function you can display
some statistical
summary
i'll just write
describe
and
give parenthesis let's run it
okay if i scroll down
you can see here
by default
the describe function will only give
information about numerical columns
so here you can see we have the total
count the mean of each of these columns
you have the standard deviation the
minimum and maximum value and then we
have the 25th percentile the 50th
percentile and the 75th percentile value
of
the columns id age height weight and
year
all right
now one thing to notice here is if you
see the year column
the minimum year is 1896
so this is when
olympics started
and until recently
the rio olympics that was held in 2016.
all right
now moving
ahead now let's check if there are any
null values present in the columns of
the
data set
so first i am going to create
a variable called
nan values
give equal to
i'll see
athletes underscore df
and the function to check is i'll say is
an a
i'll create another
variable
called nan underscore
columns
and here i'll use the any function i'll
say nan underscore
this
variable which is underscore values
dot i'll see any
and i'll print
my nan columns variable
so this will display the result in terms
of
boolean values so if there are any null
or any n or missing values in any of the
columns it will say true otherwise it
will say false
let's display the result
there you go
so if you mark here clearly
so there are
nearly six columns where we have missing
values you have
age height wheat metal region and notes
columns that have
missing values so hence
it has given us true
the rest of the columns do not have any
any n or missing values hence they are
false
all right
let me scroll down
now
let's see the total number of null
values for the
above
six columns
so i'll say
athletes
underscore df
dot i'll use the function is null
and again i'll use this sum function
okay this should be is null
if i run it
you can see it here
so our age column has
9474
rows where we have null values
then we have
some null values for the height column
as well for the weight column so these
are the total number of
rows where we don't have
any information regarding each height
weight or region
notes this medal is
self-explanatory because a lot of the
athletes who participate in olympics
don't win any medals so for them
the value is any now before i move ahead
i have a question for
you people so the question is i want you
to print the column names containing
null values or missing values in the
form of a list
so
please answer this question and put it
in the comments section of the video we
would be happy to
know your approach
so the question i'll repeat it again i
want you people to print the column
names containing null values or missing
values in the form of a list
so basically
on the top we saw there were
six columns that had
null values i want you to print these
six
columns in the form of a list
all right now moving ahead
now let's see the data for specific
countries
let's say you want to see the athletes
who have participated in the olympic
games from the beginning for india
for that you can filter your result
using a function called query
so let me show you how to do it i'll say
athletes
underscore df
dot
will use the query function
and then
i'll say
team
which is my column name
should be equal to equal to
and the value i'll give is india
now let's
display the first five
rows of information
or the details for the athletes who are
from india if i run this
okay there is some error here
okay so we need to make sure this entire
expression or the condition should be
within
single quote i'll just delete this
single quote from here and we'll add it
in the end
now let's
run it there you go
so here you can see we have
the top five rows
of
the athletes who are from india you can
see here the region is india you can see
the noc's india the team is india
and
let me go to the left you can see the
name of the athlete
the sex each
so for each you have some missing values
you have to wait
team year and everything
all right
similarly you can also check for
japan let me just copy the
above code
i'll paste it here
and instead of india i'll say
japan
i'll run it
there you go
so if you see here
you can see all the details are for the
athletes who are from japan
all right
moving ahead
now i want to know the top 10 countries
who have participated since the
inception of olympics in
1896.
so for that i'll create a variable
called top underscore 10 underscore
countries
and say equal to
i'll use my data frame that is
athletes underscore
df
i'll say dot
team
then i'll use the function
value underscore
counts
i'm going to
sort
my count
in ascending order
just mark the way in which i am writing
the functions
any error in terms of syntax or the flow
will
throw you an error
i want to display the top 10 countries
now let's go ahead and
print it i'll say
top underscore 10 underscore countries
all right
let me run it
okay it has given us an error let's
debug it okay so this should be
value
counts and not count
let's run it again
another error
okay
so this should be
short underscore values and not value
let's run it again
there you go
so here you can see the top 10 countries
participating in olympics since
1896 you have united states then we have
france so these are the number of
participants who have taken part
since 1896.
so the most number of participants have
come from us then we have france great
britain italy germany canada japan
sweden
we also have australia and
hungary i'll scroll down
now we are going to convert this table
that we got or the output that we got
in the form of a graph
so i am trying to create a bar plot to
plot the
top 10 countries who have participated
in olympics so here i'm using the
figure function to give the figure size
so these are the dimensions 12 comma 6.
now i'll tell you what this plt x6 means
just wait for a while
i have given a
title to my plot saying overall
participation by country
and then using the c bond library and
the bar plot function
i am plotting the
x
and the
y axis so my x axis has top
i should make this top 10 countries
because above we used top underscore 10
underscore countries similarly for
y-axis i'll make it top underscore 10
underscore countries and then i'm using
a color palette called set 2
let's run it
there you go so if i scroll down you can
see here we have a nice
bar plot
this is a vertical bar plot
and here you can see the bars which
represent the different country names
first we have united states which has
the highest participation since the
beginning of the olympics then we have
france great britain italy germany
canada
and we have the rest of the countries
cool
now moving ahead
the next visualization we are going to
see is the age distribution of the
athletes
so for this we are going to create a
histogram
i'll be using the matplotlib library
specifically for this visualization
so i'll say plt dot figure
we'll give the figure size using the
argument fig size
equal to
and this will be a tuple actually
my size is going to be 12 comma 6
i'll say
plt
dot
title
now you can give
any title that you want i'll say
age
distribution
of the
athletes
then we'll also give the x labels i'll
say plt dot
x label
this will have each
then we see plt dot
y label
and this will have
the label as number of
participants
next
i'm going to use the hist function so
i'll say plt.test
and i'll
pass in my data frame that is
athletes
underscore df
dot
age
which is my column name comma
i'm going to pass in the
bins
for that i'm going to use the np dot
e-range function so mp is for numpy
and inside this i'll say
10 comma
80 comma
2
so my bins will start from the value 10
and go until 80 with a size of 2
comma
i'll give another parameter that is
going to specify the color of the bins i
want my color to be
orange
and then
i'll use the edge color to separate the
bins
i'll say edge color this is the
parameter or the argument name and the
color i want is white
let's give a
semicolon here and this should be edge
color there's a spelling mistake here
now let's run it and we'll see the
output
so there you go
so this is a nice histogram that shows
the distribution of the age of the
athletes you can see the title each
distribution of the athletes on the
y-axis you have the number of
participants on the x-axis we have the
age values ranging from
10 to 80 with a size of
2
and if you say this
we have
most number of athletes
who have age between
20 to 30 you can see here
so early 20s we have maximum number of
athletes participating in the olympics
we also have a few athletes who are
beyond 40 years of age you can see here
we have a
few athletes
even closer to 60 also
and similarly we have a few athletes who
are
under 18 years of age
all right
now you can see here the bins we had
taken orange color so are all the
bars are represented in orange color
and the edge you can see here we have
the white color
all right
now moving ahead
now in the initial slides of the video
we discussed the summer and winter
olympic games let's look at the
different sporting events that are part
of the summer and winter olympic games
just to give you a heads up the winter
olympic games are held once every four
years for sports practiced on snow and
ice
so here i have my variable name winter
underscore sports so i'm extracting
for season equal to equal to
winter and i am going to display only
the unique values now let me run this
cell
okay so you can see here these are the
different windows ports that are
held
during the winter olympics now similarly
let's see for
summer olympics so what i'm going to do
here is i'll just copy this
cell of code and we'll edit the
variables i'll say summer
underscore sports
athletes underscore df remains the same
here season will change it to
summer
dot sport dot unique remains the same
and
here i'll say summer underscore sports
that should be small now let's run it
there you go
so here you can see we have
more number of olympic sports that are
held during the summer olympics compared
to
winter olympics so these are the sports
that are played on snow and ice
and these are the sports that are played
during
summer
moving ahead
now it's time to analyze the total
number of male and female participants
who have taken part in different games
since 1896 till 2016 rio olympics
all right
so i'll say
gender
underscore counts which is my variable
name
i'll use my
data frame that is
athletes underscore df
dot
my variable name that is sex
dot
value underscore
counts
and then we are going to print
gender underscore counts
let's run this
there you go
so since the inception of olympics
we have more number of male participants
than
female participants
now here in this current cell you
can see we are trying to plot a
pie chart for male and female athletes
so i have given my figure size then i
have my title as gender distribution i
am using the matplotlib library and the
pi function
i am using the variable gender counts
that we used here
then i am giving my labels as gender
underscore counts dot index now i am
using this auto pct the auto pct
parameter enables you to display the
percent
value using python string formatting so
this is my string formatting that i have
used and i'm
initialized my start angle for the pie
chart as 150 degrees and i'm also giving
shadow to my pie chart so i have
written shadow equal to true
let's run it
all right so you can see here this is my
pie chart that shows you the
distribution of the
male and female
participation
so for meal it is 72.5 percent for
female so far it is
27.5 percent as per the dataset that we
have
you can change this start angle to let's
say 180 degree
and it will
change the pie chart to this direction
cool
now moving ahead
this time
we're going to find the total number of
medals that the athletes have won
so i'll use my
data frame athletes underscore df dot
and then my column that is middle i'll
say dot
value
underscore counts
let's run it there you go so you can see
the gold medals the bronze medals and
the silver medals are
very much
similar to each other the numbers are
pretty much the same
all right
now it's time to focus on the total
female athletes who have taken part in
each
olympics
so i'll create a variable
called
female underscore
participants
i'll say equal to and then use my data
frame name that is athletes underscore
df
using
square brackets
i'll say
athletes
underscore df
dot
the gender should be equal to equal to
female
and
i'll use ampersand
i'll say
just copy this
paste it here
lc dot
season
equal to equal to we'll check for summer
olympics
and i want to extract only
the gender column so here it is sex
comma
my year column which is here
okay
and then
i'll say
female
underscore
participants
equal to
i'll just copy this
paste it here
and then
i'll use the group by function
say group by which is part of the pandas
library
i'll say year
and then i want to find the count
i'll reset the index
say
reset underscore
index
is a function
and finally we are going to print
female underscore participants
and let's say the head
all right
so what we are trying to do is i am
trying to filter my data only for the
female athletes
for summer olympics
and here
i am printing
the participation
based on each year so i am finding out
the count
so here we need to add
one more square bracket
all right
now we'll
run it and see the result
the yuko so you can see here from 1900
1904
all these years you can see the female
participation
let me change it to tail so that we have
the recent data of the
olympics
you can see it here for the beijing
olympics 5816
athletes participated in 2012 london
olympics we had
5815 olympics similarly for
the 2016 rio olympics we had
more participation than the london
olympics so six thousand two hundred and
twenty three
women athletes had participated
all right
now here
this is another way in which you can
filter your
data for female athletes so i'm
using two parameters my gender should be
equal to female and season
is summer olympics let me just run it i
have stored it in a variable called
women olympics
now
here i am trying to
find a
count plot or i am trying to create a
count plot using my cbon sns library
i have set my style to dark grid
then my figure size i have given as
20 comma 10
my count plot will have the x axis
as year
the data is women olympics
and palette i'm using as spectral
and then i have given a title women
participation
let's run and see the output
there you go if i scroll down you can
see on the top i have the title for my
count plot which says women
participation and on the y-axis i have
the count
and at the bottom you can see the
different year values from 1900 till
2016
and 2016 had the highest number of
female participation
cool
let me scroll down so in this cell of
code we are trying to plot a line graph
let me run it and show you the output
so this line graph shows the trend
which says plot for female athletes over
time
so here you can see the line graph so
gradually
the women participation has increased in
olympics since
its inception
there was a slight decrease here this is
around
1950s
and again you can see here there is a
decrease with the women participation in
1980 but since then since 1980 there has
been continuous
increase in the participation of female
athlete numbers
cool now coming to the next section
of our analysis
now we are going to filter the data to
see the details of the athletes who have
won gold medals
so
i'll create a variable called gold
medals
it's equal to i'll use my
data frame as
athletes underscore df
and
within parenthesis i'll use my data
frame name
which is athletes
underscore
df
dot
i'll use the condition middle equal to
equal to
and my value would be gold
next
i'm going to
say
gold medals dot head
let's run it
there you go
so here
we have the
top five rows of the athletes who have
won
a gold medal you can see
all the
records have medal as
gold now we are going to use this
subset
of the data and perform some more
analysis
so here
i want to take only the values that are
different from nan so i'm going to use
is
finite
function and inside that i have set goal
middles age
let me just run it cool
now i want to see
the athletes who have
secured a gold medal beyond the age of
60 years
which is very
rare so we'll see the total number of
athletes with more than 60 years of each
having won a gold medal
so here i'm going to say
gold medals
i'll use my
column as id
and then
i'll use
my variable
gold medals
and then
i'll say
age
should be
greater than
60
and then
close my square bracket and say count
okay let me just verify if everything's
fine
yeah
i'll run it
and we'll see the result so there are
total
six athletes who have won a gold medal
having age more than 60 years
cool
now let me
check for which
sport these six gold medals have come
so i'll say
sporting underscore event
this is going to be my variable name
equal to
i'll use the
same variable name gold medals
i'll going to choose
my sport column
and then
i'll give my
condition
age
greater than
60.
now let's go ahead and
we'll print
the variable spotting event
if i run this you can see it here
so
for art competitions
even for archery and suiting and this
one called rook
we have had gold medals from athletes
who had
an age
more than 60 years
now we are going to plot
this result or the table that we
achieved on the top
so i'll say plt dot
figure
i'll give my
figure size
equal to let's say 10 comma 5
then
i'll say plt dot
we'll use
the tight layout
say tight underscore
layout
then i'm going to use the c bond library
and
create a count plot for my variable
sporting underscore
event
then i'll say plt dot
title
i'll give the title as
gold medals
for
athletes
over
60 years of age
let's run it
and if i scroll down you can see here we
have a nice count plot i have my title
gold medals for athletes over 60 years
and since
for archery we had
three players who secured a gold medal
having an age more than
60 years
you can see here archery is three at
competition one
rook is one and shooting we had
one medal
all right
now we'll see the total gold medals
from each country
so for that
i'll say
gold
medals
dot
we'll use the
region column
and
followed by that i'll use the
value underscore
counts function
and
i'll reset the index
with name
equal to i'll provide the
middle column
then we are going to print the
head for the top five
countries let me run it you can see it
here
so
usa
has secured the most number of gold
medals then we have russia germany uk
and then we have italy
cool
now in this cell i am going to create a
plot to
visualize the table that i got
above
so i've used my labels my titles i'm
using the cat plot function that is
present in the c bond library i have my
x axis my y axis the data which is total
gold medals
let me just verify
okay
and we'll run it
if i scroll down
you can see this is a different palette
that i had used which is a rocket
and you can see
usa has got the
most number of gold medals then we have
russia germany uk
italy and france now we also have
included france here which was not
present in this table the reason being i
have used head
as six
so it will give me the top six countries
all right
now we will analyze
and look at the data for the most recent
olympic event that is present in our
data set i'm talking about the 2016 rio
summer olympics
so first of all i'll create a variable
called max year
which will be equal to my data frame
name athletes underscore df
my column name here and i'll use the max
function
then
let's go ahead and print my max here
i'll just show you the output you can
see here my max here present in the data
set is 2016 the rio olympics
next
we will
create another variable called team
underscore names
that will be equal to
my
data frame name athletes underscore df
within square brackets i'll give
parenthesis and then say
athletes underscore df
dot
year
should be
equal to equal to
my
output that is max here
which is actually 2016
and then i will say
ampersand
i'll just copy this
we'll paste it here
this time i'll use the
middle column and c equal to equal to
gold
i'll say dot
team
then i'll say team
underscore names
dot value
underscore
counts
dot head
and will display the
top
10
countries
let me run this
there you go
so in geo olympics
united states secured the
most number of gold medals
now the reason this is 137 is we have
also counted
the team events for example basketball
similarly great britain had 64 gold
medals in total
russia 50 we have brazil 34 argentina 21
france 20 and japan 17.
all right
now
using the above result we are going to
create a bar plot i'll just change this
team underscore list to team underscore
names
similarly here also i'll make the
corrections as
team underscore names
cool
now we'll run it
and you can see here we have a nice
horizontal
bar plot so we have united states at the
top
great britain russia germany china
brazil
so here i am displaying the top
20 nations since i have used head as 20
so these are the top 20 nations who
secured the
most number of gold medals in the u.
olympics
all right
now in the final section of this video
we will create a scatter plot to
visualize the height and weight of male
and female athletes who have won a medal
now it can be a gold medal a silver
medal or a bronze medal
but before that
we
need to filter the data only for
athletes who have won a medal
now if you
had noticed here our
medals column also had a few
null values so we are not going to
consider
those null values here
we are only going to consider for the
athletes who have
one a medal
so for that i will create a
variable called not underscore null
underscore
medals
equal to i'll say
athletes underscore
df
then
i'll give my
let's make it df
i'll give my condition
let me just copy this
i'll paste it here
and then
i'll give my condition
height
and use the
not
null
function
and then i'll say
ampersand create another parenthesis
i'll say
athletes underscore df
this time we'll consider the
weight column
again i'll use the function as not null
and
i'll close the parenthesis
okay i had missed one s here cool
let me just run it now
all right
now we are going to create our final
plot i'll say plt dot figure
i'll give my
figure size
equal to
i'll say 12 comma 10
i'll say
axis
equal to
sns dot
we'll be creating a scatter plot to plot
the
height and weight of the athletes who
have won a medal
i'll say scatter plot
in my x-axis i'll have
height
comma
in my y-axis i'll have
weight
comma
my data should be
not underscore null underscore
medals
so this is what we created here not
underscore null underscore medals
comma
i'll use hue equal to my
sex column
cool finally i'll say plt dot i'll give
a title to my plot
saying
height
versus
weight
of olympic
medalists
cool
now let's see our scatter plot
this might take some time to
keep the result because there are so
many athletes present in a data set who
have won a medal and also we are
filtering
in terms of
hue which is for male and female
there you go so if i scroll down you can
see here
we have a nice scatter plot
on the top you have the title of the
plot saying height versus wheat of
olympic medalist you can see
our age as the hue so blue points are
for the male athletes and orange points
are for the female athletes
and on the y-axis we have the weight in
terms of
kilograms and you have the height in
terms of centimeters
cool
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on
olympics
data set analysis
so we used two datasets to
[Music]
carry out this exploratory data analysis
and we
created some
visualizations to analyze and visualize
the data
all right
hello and welcome to data analytics
interview questions
my name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team that's
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead
today we're going to jump into some
common questions you might see on numpy
arrays and pandas data frames and the
python along with some excel tabloo and
sql
let's start with our first question what
is the difference between data mining
and data profiling
it's real important to note that data
mining is a process of finding relevant
information which has not been found
before it is a way in which raw data is
turned into valuable information you can
think of this as anything from the cells
stats and from their sql server all the
way to web scraping and census bureau
information where the heck do you mine
it from where do you get all this data
and information
then we look at data profiling is
usually done to assess a data set for
its uniqueness consistency and logic
it cannot identify incorrect or
inaccurate data values
so if somebody has a statistical
analysis on one side and they're doing
their you might in the wrong data to
then program your data set up so you got
to be aware that when you're talking
about data mining you need to look at
the integrity of what you're bringing in
where it's coming from data profiling is
looking at it and saying hey how is this
going to work what's the logic what's
the consistency is it related to what
i'm working with
find the term data wrangling and data
analytics
data wrangling is a process of cleaning
structuring and enriching the raw data
into a desired usable format for better
decision making
and you can see a nice chart here with
our discover it we structure the data
how we want it we clean it up get rid of
all those null values we enrich it so we
might take and reformat some of the
settings instead of having five
different terms for height of somebody
you know in america in english or
whatever clean some of that up and we
might do a calculation and bring some of
them together
and validate i was just talking about
that the last one need to validate your
data make sure you have a solid data
source and then of course it goes into
the analysis
very important to notice here in data
wrangling eighty percent of data
analytics is usually in this whole part
of wrangling the data getting it to fit
correctly and don't confuse that with
data cooking which is actually when
you're going into neural networks
cooking the data so it's all between
zero and one values
what are common problems that data
analysts encounter during
analysis
handling duplicate and missing values
collecting the meaningful right data the
right time
making data secure and dealing with
compliance issues
handling data purging and storage
problems
again we're talking about data wrangling
here eighty percent of most jobs are
unwrangling that data and getting it in
the right format making sure it's good
data to use
number four what are the various steps
involved in any analytics project
understand the problem we might spend 80
percent doing wrangling but you better
be ready to understand the problem
because if you can't you're going to
spend all your time in the wrong
direction this is probably
the most important part of the process
everything after it falls in and then
you can come back to it
two data collection
data cleaning number three four data
exploration analysis and five interpret
the results
number five is a close second for being
the most important if you can't
interpret what you bring to the table to
your clients you're in trouble
so when this question comes up you
probably want to focus on those two
noting that the rest of it does eighty
percent of the work is in two three and
four while one and five are the most
important parts
which technical tools have you used for
analysis and presentation purposes
being a data analyst you are expected to
have knowledge of the below tools for
analysis and presentation purposes
there's a wide variety out there
sql server mysql
you have your excel your spss which is
the ibm platform tableau
python you have all these different
tools in here now certainly a lot of
jobs are going to be
narrowed in on just a few of these tools
like you're not going to have a
microsoft sql server mysql server but
you better understand how to do basic
sql polls and also understanding excel
and how the different formats for column
and how to get those set up
number six what are the best practices
for data cleaning this is really
important to remember to go through this
in detail these always come up because
eighty percent of
most data analysis in cleaning the data
make a data cleaning plan by
understanding where the common errors
take place and keep communications open
identify and remove duplicates before
working with the data this will lead to
an effective data analysis process
focus on the accuracy of the data
maintain the value types of data provide
mandatory constraints and set
cross-field validation
standardize the data at the point of
entry so that is less chaotic and you
will be able to ensure that all the
information is standardized leading to
fewer errors on entry
number seven how can you handle missing
values in a data set
list wise deletion in list wise deletion
method entire record is excluded from
analysis if any single value is missing
sometimes we're talking about records
remember this could be a single line in
a database so if you have
your sql comes back and you have 15
different columns
every one of those has a missing value
you might just drop it just to make it
easy because you already have enough
data to do the processing
average imputation
use the average value of the responses
from the other participants to fill in
the missing value this is really useful
and they'll ask you why these are useful
i guarantee it
if you have a whole group of data that's
collected and it doesn't have that
information in it at that point you
might average it in there regression
substitution you can use multiple
regression analysis to estimate a
missing value that kind of goes with the
average imputation input regression
model means you're just going to get
you're going to actually generate a
prediction as to what you think that
value should be for those people based
on the ones you do have
multiple imputation so we talk about
multiple inputs it creates plausible
values based on the correlations for the
missing data and then average the
simulated data sets by incorporating
random errors in your predictions
what do you understand by the term
normal distribution and the second you
hear the word normal distribution should
be thinking a bell curve like we see
here normal distribution is a type of
continuous probability distribution that
is symmetric about the mean and in the
graph normal distribution will appear as
a bell curve the mean median and mode
are equal that's a quick way to know if
you have normal distribution is you can
compute mean median and mode all of them
are located at the center of the
distribution 68 of the data lies within
one standard deviation of the mean
95 of the data falls within two standard
deviations of the mean
99.7 of the data lies within three
standard deviations of the mean
what is time series analysis
time series analysis is a statistical
method that deals with ordered sequence
of values of a variable of equally
spaced time intervals time series data
on a coveted 19 cases
and you can see we're looking at by day
so our space is of days and each day
goes by if we take and graph it you can
see a time series graph always looks
really nice we have like two different
in this case we have what the united
states
going over there i have to look at the
other set up in there they picked a
couple different countries uh and it is
it's time sensitive you know with the
next result is based on what the last
one was koba is an excellent example of
this
anytime you do any word analytics where
you're figuring out what someone's
saying what they said before makes a
huge difference is what they're going to
say next another form of time series
analysis
10. how is joining different from
blending in tableau
so now we're going to jump into the
tableau package
data joining data joining can only be
done when the data comes from the same
source
combining two tables from the same
database or two or more worksheets from
the same excel file all the combined
tables or sheets contains common set of
dimensions and measures
data blending data blending is used when
the data is from two or more different
sources
combining the oracle table with the sql
server or two sheets from excel or
combining excel sheet and oracle table
in data blending each data source
contains its own set of dimensions and
measures
how is overfitting different from
underfitting
always a good one overfitting probably
the biggest danger in data analytics
today is overfitting
model trains from the data too well
using the training set
the performance drops significantly over
the test set happens when the model
learns the noise and random fluctuations
in the training data set in detail
and again the performance drops way
below what the test set has
the model neither trains a data well nor
can generalize to new data performs
poorly both on train and the test set
happens when there is less data to build
and an accurate model and also when we
try to build a linear model with a
non-linear data
in microsoft excel a numeric value can
be treated as a text value if it
proceeds with an apostrophe definitely
not an exclamation if you're used to
programming in python you'll look for
that hash code and not an amber sign
and we can see here if you enter the
value 10 into a fill but you put the
apostrophe in front of it it will read
that as a text not as a number
what is the difference between count
count a count blank and count if in
excel
we can see here when we run in just
count d1 through
d23
we get 19 and you'll notice that there
is 19 numbers coming down here and so it
doesn't count the cost of each which is
a top bracket it doesn't count the blank
spaces either with the straight count
when you do a count a you'll get the
answer is 20. so now when you do count a
it counts all of them even the title
cost of each
when you do count blank we'll get three
why there's three blank fields
and finally the count if if we do count
if of e 1 to e 23 is greater than 10
there's 11 values in there basic
counting of whatever's in your column
pretty solid on the table there
explain how vlookup works in excel
vlookup is used when you need to find
things in a table or a range by row
the syntax has four different parts to
it
we have our lookup value that's a value
you want to look up we have our table
array
the range where the lookup value is
located
column index number the column number
and range that contains the return value
and the range lookup specify true if you
want an approximate match or false if
you want an exact match of the return
value
so here we see v lookup f3
a2 to c8 2 0 for prints now they don't
show the f3 f3 is the actual
cell that prince is in that's what we're
looking at is f3 so there's your prince
he pulls in from f3
a2 to c8 is the the data we're looking
into and then number two is a column in
that data so in this case we're looking
for
age and we count name as one ages two
keep in mind this is excel versus a lot
of your python and programming languages
where you start at zero in excel we
always look at the cells as one two
three so two represents the age
zero
is uh false for having an exact match up
versus one
we don't actually need to worry about
that too much in this zero or one would
work with this example and you can see
with the angela lookup again her name
would be in the f column number four
that's what the f4 stands for is where
they pulled angela from
and then you have a1 to c8 and then
we're looking at
number three so number three is height
name being one h2 and then height three
and you'll see here pulls in her height
5.8
so we're going to run jump over to sql
how do you subset or filter data in sql
to subset or filter data in sql we use
where and having clause
you can see we have a nice table on the
left where we have the title the
director the year the duration
we want to filter the table for movies
that were directed by brad bird
why just because we want to know who
what brad bird did
so we're going to do select star you
should know that the star refers to all
in this case we're what are we going to
return we're going to return all title
directory year and duration that's what
we mean by all
from movies movies being our table
where director equals brad bird and you
can see he comes back and he did the
incredible and ratatouille
to subset or filter data sql we can also
use the where and having clause so we're
going to take a closer look at the
different ways we can filter here filter
the table for directors whose movies
have an average duration greater than
115 minutes
so there's a lot of really cool things
into this sql query and these sql
queries can get pretty crazy
select director sum duration as total
duration average duration as average
duration from movies group by director
having average duration greater than
115.
uh so again what are we going to return
we're going to return whatever we put in
our select which in this case is
director we're going to have total
duration and that's going to be the sum
of the duration we're going to have the
average duration average underscore
duration which is going to be the
average duration on there
and then we course go ahead and group by
director and we want to make sure we
group them by anyone that has an having
an average duration greater than 115.
these sql queries are so important
i don't know how many times your the sql
comes up and there's so many different
other languages not just mysql and not
microsoft sql in addition to that where
the sql language comes in especially
with hadoop and other areas so you
really should know your basic sql
doesn't hurt to get that little cheat
sheet and glance over and double check
some of the different features in sql
what is the difference between where and
having clause in sql
where
where clause works on row data in where
clause the filter occurs before any
groupings are made
aggregate functions cannot be used
so the syntax is select
your columns from table
where what the condition is
having clause works on aggregated data
having is used to filter values from a
group aggregate functions can be used
in the syntax is select column names
from table
where the condition is
grouped by having a condition ordered by
column names
what is the correct syntax for reshape
function in numpy so we're going to jump
to the numpy array program
and what you come up with is you have uh
in this case would be numpy.reshape a
lot of times you do an import numpy as
np
reshape and then your array and the new
shape
and you can see here as we as the actual
example comes in the reshape is a and
we're going to reshape it in two comma
five uh setups and you can see the
printout in there that prints in two
rows with five values in each one
what are the different ways to create a
data frame in pandas
well we can do it by initializing a list
so you can port your pandas as pd very
common
data equals tom 30 jerry20 angela35
we'll go ahead and create the data frame
and we'll say uh pd.dataframe is the
data columns equals name and age so you
can designate your columns you can also
it is a index in there you should always
remember that the index
uh in this case maybe you want the index
instead of one two to be
the date they signed up or who knows you
know whatever and you can see right
there it just generates a nice pandas
data frame with tom
jerry and angela
another way you can initialize a
data frame is from dictionary you can
see here we have a dictionary where the
date equals name tom jerry angela mary
ages 20 21 1918 and if we do a df pd
dot data frame on the data you'll get a
nice the same kind of setup you get your
name age tom jerry angela and mary
write the python code to create an
employee's data frame from the
emp.csv file and display the head and
summary of it
to create a data frame in python you
need to import the pandas library and
use the read csv function to load the
csv file
and here you can see we have import
pandas as pd employees or the data frame
employees equals pd.read csv
and then you have your path to that csv
file
there's a number of settings in the read
csv where you can tell it how many rows
are the top index
you can set the columns in there
you can have skip rows there's all kinds
of things you can also go in there and
double check with your read csv but the
most basic one is just to read a basic
csv
how will you select the department and
age columns from an employee's data
frame
so we have import pandas as pd you can
see we have created our data
we will go ahead and create our
employees pd data frame on the left
and then on the right to select
department and age from the data frame
we just do employees and you put the
brackets around it now if you're just
doing one column you could do just
department but if you're doing multiple
columns you've got to have those in a
second set of brackets it's got to be
a reference with a list within the
reference
what is the criteria to say whether a
developed data model is good or not
a good model should be intuitive
insightful and self-explanatory
follow the old saying kiss keep it
simple
the model develops should be able to
easily consumed by the clients for
actionable and profitable results
so if they can't read it what good is it
a good model should easily adapt to
changes according to business
requirements
we live in quite a dynamic world
nowadays so it's pretty self-evident and
if the data gets updated the model
should be able to scale accordingly to
the new data so you have a nice data
pipeline going where when something when
you get new data coming in you don't
have to go and rewrite the whole code
what is the significance of exploratory
data analysis
exploratory data analysis is an
important step in any data analysis
process
exploratory data analysis eda helps to
understand the data better it helps you
obtain confidence in your data to a
point where you're ready to engage a
machine learning algorithm it allows you
to refine your selection of feature
variables that will be used later for
model building you can discover hidden
trends and insights from the data
how do you treat outliers in a data set
an outlier is a data point that is
distant from other similar points they
may be due to variability in the
measurement or may indicate experimental
errors
uh one you can drop the outlier records
pretty straightforward you can cap your
outliers data
so it doesn't go past a certain value
you can assign it a new value you can
also try a new transformation to see if
those outliers come in if you transform
it slightly differently
explain descriptive predictive and
prescriptive analytics
descriptive provides insights into the
past to answer what has happened
uses data aggregation and data mining
techniques examples an ice cream company
can analyze how much ice cream was sold
which flavors were sold
and whether more or less ice cream was
sold than before
predictive understands the future to the
answer what could happen uses
statistical models and forecasting
techniques
example predicts the sale of ice creams
during the summer spring and rainy days
so this is always interesting because
you have your descriptive which comes in
and your businesses are always looking
to know what happened hey did we have
good sales last quarter
what are we expecting next quarter in
the cells and we have a huge jump when
we do uh prescriptive
suggest various courses of action to
answer what should you do uses
optimization and simulation algorithms
to advise possible outcomes
example lower prices to increase
sell of ice creams produce more or less
quantities of certain flavor of ice
cream and we can certainly uh today's
world with the coveted virus because we
had that in our earlier graph you could
see that as a descriptive what's
happened how many people have been
infected how many people have died in an
area
predictive what do we predict that to go
do we see it going to get worse is it
going to get better what do we predict
that we're going to need in hospital
beds and
prescriptive what can we change in our
setup to have a better outcome maybe if
we did more social distancing if we
tracked the virus
how do these different things directly
affect the end and can we create a
better ending by changing some
underlying criteria
what are the different types of sampling
techniques used by data analysis
sampling is a statistical method to
select a subset of data from an entire
data set population to estimate the
characteristics of the whole population
one we can do a simple random sampling
so we can just pick out 500 random
people in the united states to sample
them
they call it a population in regular
data we also call that a population
just because that's where it came from
was mainly from doing census
systematic sampling
cluster sampling
stratified sampling
and judgment or propositive sampling
and we have our systematic sampling
that's where you're doing like uh using
1 5
10 15 20. use a very systematic approach
for pulling samples
from the setup
cluster sampling
that's where you look at it we say hey
some of these things just naturally
group together if you were talking about
population which is the really a nice
way of looking at this cluster sampling
would be maybe by zip code we're going
to do everybody's zip code and just
naturally cluster it that way
stratified sampling would be more uh
looking for shared things a group has
like income
so if you're studying something on
poverty you might look at their
naturally group people
based on income to begin with and then
study those individuals in the income to
find out
what kind of traits they have
and then judgmental
that is
where the
researcher very carefully selects each
member of their own group
so it's very much
based on their personal knowledge
jumping on the 26 what are the different
types of hypothesis testing
hypothesis testing is a procedure used
by statisticians and scientists to
accept or reject statistical hypothesis
we start with a hypothesis testing we
have null hypothesis and alternative
hypothesis
on the null hypothesis it states that
there is no relation between the
predictor and the outcome variables in
the population it is denoted by h naught
example there is no association between
patients
bmi and
diabetes alternative hypothesis it
states there is some relation between
the predictor and outcome variables in
the population it is denoted by h1
example there could be an association
between patients bmi and diabetes
and that's the body mass index if you
didn't catch the bmi and you're not
medical
describe univariate bivariate and
multivariate analysis
a univariate analysis it is the simplest
form of data analysis where the data
being analyzed contains only one
variable an example of studying the
heights of players in the nba
because it's so simple it can be
described using central tendencies
dispersion
quartiles bar charts histograms pie
charts frequency distribution tables
the bivariate analysis it involves
analysis of two variables to find causes
relationships and correlations between
the variables
example analyzing sale of ice creams
based on the temperature outside
bivariate analysis can be explained
using correlation coefficients linear
regression logistic regression scatter
plots and box plots
and multivariate analysis it involves
analysis of three or more variables to
understand the relationship of each
variable with the other variables
example analyzing revenue based on
expenditure so if we have our tv ads we
have our newspaper ads our social media
ads and a revenue we can now compare all
those together
the multivert analysis can be performed
using multiple regression factor
analysis classification and regression
trees cluster analysis principle
component analysis clustering bar chart
dual axis chart
what function would you use to get the
current date and time in excel
in excel you can use the today and now
function to get the current date and
time
you can see down here with the two
examples where just equals today or
equals now
using the sumifs function in excel find
the total quantity sold by sales
representatives whose names start with a
and the cost of each item they have sold
is greater than 10.
and you can see here on the left we have
our actual table
and then we want to go ahead and sum ifs
so we want the e2 through e20 b2 through
b20
greater than 10. and this basically is
just saying hey we're going to take
everything in the
e column
and we're going to sum it up but only
those objects where the d column is
greater than 10 that's what that means
there
is the below query correct if not how
will you rectify it
select customer id year order date as
order year from order
where order year is greater than or
equal to 2016.
and hopefully you caught it right there
uh it's in the devils in the details we
can't not use the alias name while
filtering data using the where clause
so the correct format is all the same
except for where it says where
the year
order date is greater than or equal to
16
versus using the order year which we
assign under the select setup
how are union intersect and accept
used in sql
the union operator is used to combine
the results of two or more select
statements and you can see here we have
select star from region 1 and we're
going to make a union with select star
from region 2 and it basically takes
both these sql tables and combines them
to form a full new table on there so
that's your union as we bring everything
together
we look at the intersect operator
returns the common records that are the
result of the two or more select
statements
so you can see here we select star from
region one intersect select star from
region 2
and we come up with only those records
that are shared that have the same data
in them
and hopefully you jumped ahead to the
accept the accept operator returns the
uncommon records that are the result of
two or more select statements so these
are the two records or the records that
are not shared between the two databases
using the product price table write an
sql query to find the record with the
fourth highest market price
so here we have a little bit of a brain
teaser
uh they're always fun
and the first thing we want to do is
we're going to go ahead and i'm going to
if you look at the script on the left
we really want the fourth one down so
we're going to select the top four from
product price but we're going to order
it by market price descending sp order
by market price ascending
so we do is we take the top
four
of the market price ascending
and that's going to give us the four
greatest values
and then we're going to reverse that
order and do descending
and we're going to take the top one of
that which is going to give us the
lowest value which would be the fourth
greatest one in the list
from the product price table find the
total and average market price for each
currency where the average market price
is greater than 100 and currency
is in the inr or the aud
so
inr or aud india rupal or australia
dollar
you can see over here the sql query if
you had trouble putting this together
you might actually do some of it in
reverse
and you can see right here where the
average market price is greater than 50
remember we use having not where at the
end because it's part of the group so
group by currency because we want those
two currencies and we want the currency
india the inr or the aud
and
as you keep going backwards we're
actually going to be selecting the
currency the sum of the market price
as total price and the average market
price as average price so there's our
select it's going to come from the
product price which is just our table
over there and then we have where our
currency is in
and like i said you can put together
however you want but hopefully you got
to the end there
so this question will test your
knowledge in tableau exploring the
different features of tableau and
creating a suitable graph to solve a
business problem
and of course taboo is very visual in
its use so it's very hard to test it
without actually just getting your hands
on and if you can't visualize some of
this and how to do it then you should go
back and refresh yourself
using the sample super stored data set
create a view to analyze the cells
profits and quantities sold across
different subcategories of items present
under each category so the first step is
to go ahead and load the sample
superstore data set
so make sure you know how to load the
sample the superstore data set that's
underneath either the connect button in
the upper left
or the
tableau icon up there and be able to
pull in the data set and then once
you've done that you just drag the
category and subcategory on rows and
salaries onto columns
it will result in a horizontal bar chart
so in this one we're just going to drag
profit onto color and quantity onto
label sort the sales axes in descending
order of sum and cells within each sub
category
and if you're at home doing this you'll
see that chairs under furniture category
had the highest sales and profit while
tables had the lowest profit
for office supplies subcategory binders
made the highest profit even though
storage had the highest sales
under technology category copiers made
the highest profit though it was the
least amount of sales
let's work to create a dual axis chart
in tableau to present cells and profits
across different years using sample
superstore data set
load the orders sheet from the sample
superstore data set
drag the ordered data field from the
dimensions onto columns and convert it
into continuous month
drag cells onto rows and profits to the
right corner of the view until you see a
light green rectangle
one of those things if you haven't done
this hands-on you don't know what you're
doing you're gonna run into a bike so
you're gonna be just kind of dropping it
and wondering what happened
synchronize the right axis by right
clicking on the profit axis
and then let's finalize it by going
under the marks card change some cells
to bar and sum profit to line and adjust
the size
and then we have a nice display that we
can either print out or save and send
off to the
shareholders
let's go and do one more tableau
design a view in tableau to show
statewide cells and profits using the
sample superstore data set
in here you go ahead and drag the
country field onto the view section and
expand it to see the states
drag the states field onto size and
profit onto color
increase the size of the bubbles at a
border and a halo color states like
washington california new york have the
highest sales and profits while texas
pennsylvania and ohio
have a good amount of sales but the
least amount of profits
we'll go ahead and skip back to python
numpy suppose there is an array number
equals np or numpy if you're using numpy
depending on how you set it up dot array
and we just have one to nine broken up
into three groups
extract the value eight using 2d
indexing so you can see on the left we
have our import numpy as in p number
equals our np array if we print the
number we have one two three four five
six seven eight nine
since the value eight is present in the
second row and first column we use the
same index position and pass it to the
array
and you just have number two comma one
and you get eight and remember we're in
python so you start at zero not one like
you do in excel
always gets me if i'm working between
excel and python where i just kind of
flip and usually it's the excel that
messes up cause i do a lot more
programming
suppose there's an array that has values
0 1
all the way up to 9.
how will you display the following
values from the array 1 3 5 7 9.
uh so first of all we go ahead and
create the array
np dot a range of 10 which goes from 0
to 9 because there's 10 numbers in it
but we don't include the 10.
we print it out the first thing you want
to do is what's going on here with one
three five seven nine
well if we divide by two there's going
to be a remainder equal to one
and then from python remember that if
you use the percentage sign
you get the remainder on there so the
remainder is one
and then you have the your numpy array
and then we just want to do
a logical statement of all values that
have a remainder of one and that
generates our nice
one three five seven nine
there are two arrays a and b stack the
arrays a and b
horizontally
boy these horizontal vertical questions
will get you every time
and in numpy we go ahead and we've
created two different arrays over here a
and b uh the first one is your
concatenate np dot concatenate
a and b on axes equal one
that is the same as h stack
and in the back end they're still
identical they run the same that's all h
stack is a concatenate axis equals one
how can you add a column to a pandas
data frame
suppose there's an imp data frame that
has information about few employees
let's add address column to that data
frame you can see in the left we have
our basic data frame you should know
your data frames very well basically it
looks like an excel spreadsheet as you
come over here it's really simple you
just do df of address equals the address
once you've assigned values to the
address
using the below given data create a
pivot table to find the total sales made
by each cells represented for each item
display the cells as a percentage of the
grand total
so we're back in tableau select the
entire table range click on insert tab
and choose pivot table
select the table range and the worksheet
where you want to place the pivot table
it will return a pivot table where you
can analyze your data
drag the cell total on the values and
sales rep and item onto row labels it
will give the sum of the sales made by
each representative for each item they
have sold
and finally right click on sum of cell
total and expand show values
as to select percentage of grand total
real important just to understand what a
pivot table is we're just piving it from
rows and columns and switching this
direction on there
and finally we have our final pivot
table and you can see the values rolls
and sum of total sale
so we're going to go ahead and take a
product table this is off of an sql so
we're going to do some sql here
and we're going to use the product and
sales order detail table find the
products that have total units sold
greater than 1.5 million and here's our
sales order detail table so we have a
product table and a sales order detail
table two separate tables in the
database
and we're going to do is put together
the sql query we want to select
pp name
sum sod unit price as cells
and then we have our p p dot product id
from production product as pp inner join
cells dot sales order detail as sod on
pp product id equals sod.product id
group by pp dot name comma pp.product id
having a sum of saw.unit price greater
than
the 150 million there that's a mouthful
and again these sql queries they start
looking really crazy until you just
break them apart and do them step by
step
and what we're looking for is the inner
join
and how did you do the group by this
really wanted to know how do you do this
inner join this comes up so much in sql
how do you pull in the id from one chart
and the information from another chart
and the sum totals on that chart
how do you write a stored procedure in
sql let's create a storage procedure to
find the sum the squares are the first n
natural numbers so here we have our
formula n times n plus one times two n
plus one over six
and you can see from the command prompt
uh or the setup you have depending on
what your login is the command is create
procedure square sum1
declare our variable at n of integer as
begin and then we're going to declare
the sum of integer
set sum equals n times n plus 1 plus 2
times n plus 1
over 6.
and then of course we can go ahead and
print those out print first cast
amber sign in or our variable
as a variable character 20 natural
numbers print the sum of the square is
cast
the
at sum as a variable character 40 end
then we do the output display the sum of
the square for first four natural
numbers we have execute square sum one
and then we're going to put in four and
you can see here where it brings up the
first four natural numbers sum of square
is thirty
write a store procedure to find the
total even number between two user given
numbers a couple of things to note here
first we go ahead and create our
procedure you have your two different
variables the n1 in two
and we go ahead and begin we're going to
declare our variable count as an integer
we're going to set count equal to zero
and then we have while n is less than n2
we're going to begin and if n1
remainder two equals zero so we're gonna
divide it by two even number
begin we're gonna set the count equal to
count plus one we're going to print even
number
plus cast in as a variable
character 10 for printing count is plus
cast variable count as variable
character 10 end else print odd number
plus cast variable number one is
variable character 10. and then we go
ahead and set the
increment our variable one up one so
that goes from n one all the way to n
two and i'll print the total number of
even numbers and you can see here we
went ahead and executed it we're going
to count the even numbers between 30 and
45 and you see it goes all the way down
to 8.
what is the difference between tree maps
and heat maps in tableau
now if you've worked in python other
programmings you should automatically
know what a heat map is
but a tree map are used to display data
in nested rectangles you use dimensions
to define the structure of the tree map
and measure to define the size or color
of individual rectangles
tree maps are relatively simple data
visualization that can provide insight
in a visually attractive format
and again you can see the squares over
here this is our tree map over here with
the
each block also has this information
inside of its different blocks
a heat map helps to visualize measures
against dimensions with the help of
colors and size to compare one or more
dimensions and up to two measures
the layout is similar to a text table
with variations in values encoded as
colors in heat map you can quickly see a
wide array of information
and in this one uh you can see they use
the colors to denote one thing and the
size of the little square to denote
something else
a lot of times you can even graph this
into a three-dimensional graph with
other data
so it pops out but again a heat map is
the color and the size
using the sample super stored data set
display the top five and bottom five
customers based on their profit so you
start by dragging the customer name
field onto rows and profit on columns
right click on the customer name column
to create a set
give a name to the set and select top
tab to choose top 5 customers by some
profit
similarly create a set for the bottom
five customers by sum profit
select both the sets right click to
create a combined set
give a name to the set and choose all
members in both sets
and then you can drag top and bottom
customer sets onto the filters and
profit filled onto color to get the
desired results
as we get down to the end of our list
we're going to try to keep you
on your toes we're going to skip back to
numpy how to print four random integers
between 1 and 15 using numpy to generate
random numbers using numpy we use the
random random integer function
you see here we did the import numpy is
in p random arrangement equals
np.random.randominteger
1 through 15 of 4.
from the below dataframe can jump again
on you now we're into pandas
how will you find the unique values for
each column and subset the data for age
less than 35 and height greater than six
to find the unique values and the number
of unique elements use the unique and
the in unique function
you see here we just did df heights
we're selecting just the height column
and we want to look for the unique
that returns an array
where in unique if we do that on the
height or the age we'll return just the
number of unique values
and then we can do a subset the data for
ages less than 35 and height greater
than 6.
so if we look over here we have a new df
remember this is going to be taking
slices of our original data frame it
doesn't actually change the data frame
so our new df equals the data frame or
df
the data frame where age is less than 35
and the height is greater than six
and in case you're not using uh tableau
which has a lot of its own
different mapping programs in there make
sure you understand how to use the
basics of matplot library plot a sine
graph using numpy and matplot library
and python and the way we did this is we
went ahead and generate an x we know our
y equals np.sine of x if you print out x
you'll see a whole value here our
matplot library pi plot as plt
if you are working in jupiter notebook
make sure you understand the matplot
library inline that little percentage
sign met plot library in line that
prints it on the page in the jupiter
notebook the newer version of jupyter
notebook or
jupiter labs automatically does that for
you but i usually put it in there just
in case i end up on an older version
if you print y you can see here we have
our different y values and our different
x values
you simply put in plt.plot x y
and do a plot show
and before we go let's get one more in
we're going to do a pandas using the
below pandas data frame find the company
with the highest average cells derive
the summary statistics for the cells
column and transpose these statistics
that's a mouthful and just like any of
these computer problems break it apart
so first of all we're looking for the
highest average sales so group the
company
column and use the mean function to find
the average sales
you see here by company equals df.group
by company
once we've done that using the describe
function we can now go ahead and look at
the summary of statistics on here use
the describe function to find the
summary
so by company those are groups we're
just going to describe them and you
could actually bundle those together if
you wanted and just do them all in one
line
so here we go by company dot describe
you can see we have a nice breakout
always good to remember
whether you're using any of the packages
whether it's tableau or
pandas
in python or even r or some other
package being able to quick look and
describe your data is very important
and then we go ahead and just do a basic
apply a transpose function over the
describe method to transpose the
statistics
all we've done here is flip the index
with the column names but if you're
following the numbers a lot of times
it's easier to follow across one line or
maybe you want to average out the count
or it's all kinds of different reasons
to do that and with that we have come to
the end of this video tutorial on data
analytics full course 2022 by simply
learn i hope it was really helpful and
informative thank you and keep learning
you